[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes sir
like check
mic check
realm
yeah i've been patient
[Laughter]
all my levels all my levels what's going
on oh
man
oh man we got so many in here it is
crazy to see all this early hustle and
motivate what's going on let me know if
my level is good let me know if i'm a
little too loud i turn myself up a
little bit but you know if i'm too loud
but uh because i might you know my laugh
when i yell
when i do that they get mad just let me
know when my my high level was too high
but yo there's so many of y'all in here
this is crazy this is crazy man
i don't think king should show up today
which i think
yo what's going on motivate necromancy
what's going on we need there yo
mike mullis og
nlg what's up brother yo i should get
you in here but i i figured you might
have had you know a little sunday
service but what's going on audio on the
phone see okay thank you also you
already know craig cool again what's up
you know what i'm saying joe mac qt clan
ain't nothing you already know boozy
clown what's going on yo allen victor
what's going on only on xbox eagles fan
godly tried it badmind what a bad mind
do you already know gonna be dropping
quick freestyle you don't know
what's up what's good i got energy today
i got energy my daddy's all bad i'm good
i'm good you know say i don't know king
about to do what king gonna do i don't
know
but um
all right no doubt um oh gee i will hit
you matter of fact do me a favor og hit
me um nlg hit me in the dm and i will
talk to you on the uh certain conditions
but um yeah man so we got that
it's gonna be crazy you know what i said
be lou what's up sip lord what's up
what's going on
oh man i know y'all i know y'all want
king we're gonna do it right this is a
monster show
y'all been patiently waiting is the main
event no disrespect to anybody else but
y'all know here in the realm there's
been one lord who's been on his square
there's been one lord who has
prophesied certain things so we got to
give him his flowers but i do have to
set it up you know what i mean i have to
set it up right there's been a lot of
events we've missed so um you know we
got to give you the chronological order
but it's going to be a fun show we got
supposedly allegedly you know some
people coming through and uh we're gonna
be respectful we're gonna have fun
and yeah i might keep the kangaroo okay
i don't know
96 percent right oh yeah i got his 96
percent right y'all y'all spitting these
bars before he come on
kick is the
he makes us great hey malcolm hendricks
what's going on five dollar super chat
gmg fam hey okay okay gmg what's going
on salute salute darron james what's up
gamer man king king wait what king i
know i know he coming he's in the
dressing room he's in the jaw jonathan
be here let's worry that was crazy
all right devito i hope so i hope so
davido 20 eagle fan yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is the energy i need i need y'all i
need y'all like this every week too
christopher i need you
what's going on man account but look
let me go backstage
get addict we got we got a monster show
strapping it's gonna be fun
we're gonna hit this thing from a lot of
angles the lord's obviously got to lose
the latest out of all the other podcasts
but we're definitely gonna try to do
something nice for y'all something
different some fun you know what i mean
so uh get ready buckle up rome and i
appreciate y'all real talk i really like
to see y'all tweet how excited y'all are
for this show
it's very humbling you know make a boy
get emotional but it's all about king
today and what else we got planned so
i'll see y'all in a minute
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't wanna be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
blind
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
i know it's random but i'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start
um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but on the be of dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boy you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to starter regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all to messed up and turned me to
an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
[Music]
i um you could say that i'm very spoiled
for them to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this
is the yoga fire flame they think it's
arson up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
here to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and hey let's be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young woofer
then they would mistake me for addict if
i can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meto i know it's my
destiny worked a cognito who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursued but
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
all right hot bikes and all of that
and we
are laugh
welcome
to the iron lord forecast llc and the
lords of gaming.net episode number 241
it's another glory sunday we're back at
the round table on the lord's date i'm
very excited about our potential special
guest
and we've got microsoft acquiring
activision blizzard
pc and mobile ramifications with
battle.net and king
the desire for call of duty on
playstation
and sony's potential response to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original gaming nights in
the realm here at the round table with
some somewhat time-sensitive intros
based on the flow of the show
my co-host dicomos my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
how we doing sir
i'm doing pretty good i you know i did
desire to do an intro but i desired i
don't want to now so yeah i appreciate
everyone third man we're going to have a
good show hey talk a little bit longer
i'm still copy pasting these super chats
okay so uh
so it's almost copying and pasting these
super chess man we got to talk about you
you know what i've been playing with
your clothes
i've been playing this yu-gi-oh game
damn it
i'm so sick inside of kunami every like
four years just like putting a a
something right like that it's just like
it's like they're doing like the cat
mouse thing oh you want it oh no you
don't
i know how you get with yu-gi-oh bro
yeah
and now it's free to play yeah yeah it's
good but it's a free you know what's
funny i was playing and i was doing
really good and then i kept going up
like because they have like a little
tier system the better you do the better
people you get matched up
but after about an hour i was playing i
was at my girlfriend playing it and i
just started complaining she's like i
thought you were doing good i was like
yeah i was now i'm playing good people
daddy
daddy
and of course hopefully ready with an
influx of super chats to deal with
our most technical gaming lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single-player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patron of
the iron bank my man lord sovereign how
we doing sir
i am generally good this week
it's been a week it's been quite a week
it's been a week gentlemen
so it really has there's a lot to
dissect there's a lot going to talk
about prophecy talk right
yeah yeah um
so before we get into any time like on a
serious note yeah like
ah there's a lot of stuff that's been
said about what's going on this weekend
things that have happened whatever but
um i mean i think there's there's some
things that need to be addressed okay um
so
before i pass it on to king what i
wanted to do is to
um kind of just
show you guys a little a
little statement by somebody that i
consider to be uh quite frankly one of
the great minds of our time okay so i
want to just share that with you guys
let's do that let's do that okay mm-hmm
so uh let's do this i have a feeling
this is going so yeah i'm i'm very
nervous
i don't know what to talk about
let's get whatever's about to happen
[Laughter]
uh-oh
and y'all see yeah yeah i see i see b
it's white needle i see white what that
would be
let's put the let's put the volume up
all right let's do that then now another
one of them doesn't make sense at all
but it's a pie in the sky thing which
one
there is a publisher out there right now
that is
hemorrhaging goodwill left and right
just emerging goodwill are you talking
about cd projekt red no no no no not a
publisher
that's activision bliss oh
i know what you're doing
right now i don't know
yeah yeah but uh i think i think
microsoft
i think microsoft it has that sort of
cleansing thing over there oh he's
softer thomas
he's trying to stop the javascript
know what you're gonna say um god this
is the thing right cod i wouldn't make
cod exclusive i would i would do what
cog what i did with minecraft i don't
want to lose sarah bond to
become my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop the damn footage stop
let me respond to your silliness okay
you you are right you did call that but
to be fair no one in there claimed that
it wouldn't happen we just claimed that
they couldn't oh no no no you said it
again
i said i said i didn't want sarah bond
to be uh put in charge yeah because
that's what i'm saying let me get into
the whole ramifications of the situation
yeah you got to see that you gotta be
back pedaling hold on
you gotta be realistic here at that time
that is such a huge thing to think
though
i'm going to step on the trouble
he put his chest out he's staying order
all the way no no no no he's still on
that you didn't do it don't matter
past this we're gonna let this dude get
all of this right here
right now
if that was a pie in the sky which it
really was and my man my man
did the hail mary
and keyshawn johnson came down he did
the baby paul
[Music]
[Laughter]
and you know what and on god in them
if if
this is this this is the difference
between a lot of you frauds out there
this is the difference between a lot of
you frauds out there they'll be claiming
all this i got choices
this is the hold on man i gotta give my
man his props all right
this is this is a nail on the head just
so so just in case i want y'all to
rewind it i want y'all to put that on
your back i want all you dudes to be out
there capping and screaming
this is dude that said it facts this is
the only dude that said it and everybody
on this channel was like nah man so i'm
gonna i gotta need a sofa i got it
you gotta give us all this need let's
listen
i'm not doing it on camera
[Laughter]
first off real quick shout out to over a
thousand watching the show
more yes
no i was gonna make it i was gonna make
it a lot more production oh
see he tried to put us on a summer jam
screen
we gave you your flight
moving on
of course
we have the incredible
hulk of this
aka
the excess gamer oh
the prophet of xbox swami the king of
the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement we need the hulk hogan moves
man
lord king
how are we doing sir
knock knock
who's this who's there aaron aaron
aaron ain't getting a ring this year
first first first first let me say don't
like the dude second everybody been
claiming that he's the best right but
all he is is a copy of the dude that he
replaced
he's brett favre again one ring out of
here you the best of regular season hype
job that i've ever seen in my life i had
to listen to keyshawn johnson my
favorite dude in the whole world and all
these dudes on espn talk about oh this
is the year aaron is going to clean
through he's going to go through he's
going to do aaron is home god bless
good night
get out of here get cat daddy eric roger
slider is welcome here
it is welcome here because you you keep
bringing up listen i'm not a tom brady
i'm a jet fan i've been beaten into
submission understand this i've been
beaten into submission i've watched
greatness and i appreciate it and y'all
dudes are not respecting the greatness
and the twilight of his career you keep
talking about some dude who don't even
got two they don't got two so stop
talking about the seven man seven man
leave him alone let the seven man do his
thing i'm respecting i'm watching tom
brady's run this football is about how
many rings can tom brady get before him
and giselle disappeared
all it is right now all right so god
bless inganu oh
and i missed it yo he showed me
something yesterday
that i thought if he if he rushed the
dude if if he grappled with him he was
going to tank out and when he grabbed
him by the ankle because then ghana was
doing so much and he had his ankle and i
said no god nah man
he worked so hard
he gone relaxed he didn't panic like
normal big dudes do
he reversed it and he got that so i
honestly it was huge
it was
i'm like yo
i seen you know how when you see
somebody
in the gym and they apply it
to the evolution you see now
wait wait hold on because i can't
believe i missed this yeah he was dude
but he but his oh my god
and i just got to say one more thing
yeah about gary russell jr um
every time you miss weight i always bet
against you shout out to that that was
good you lost um
yeah yeah this week
i'm a huge fraud i've been playing a lot
of stuff inside game pass we know game
class had a huge
explosion on the 20th yes sir but i
can't help but that fortnight cookie
i'm back at the cookie oh you still i
can't believe you but you know
i'm i'm actually a fraud so i love it
laughing
because fortnite was definitely been
i
i honestly am a fraud i'm a huge fraud
but i'm not no no no i love pubg but
it's something about this and i'm trying
to get this spider-man suit so i gotta
grind and until i get that suit i'm not
gonna stop
of course we have the gaming hinger
himself the shinobi law incognito spread
that realism around the iop not telling
what you want here but what you need to
hear
bang bang 90 street gang early
let's go and yeah i saw your dudes i saw
y'all bing bong i saw y'all dudes on my
timeline with your little jokes and your
little memes in the first quarter are
you throwing it you're throwing it up
for yourself look at you now
now i was scared of that if i ever gonna
hold you i was getting that fight i'm
gonna keep it a buck i ain't think that
was going down i did though but i i i
take it i take it but you're all an
honest fan in there fans are really i
see you i see it myself i like the
infamous i see y'all so slow anyway um
for me divina duke you already know the
amazing mr maddie plays check that out
we talk about the deal from a different
angle when it broke early when i'm
saying what a lot of dudes early so
check that out that's up now on youtube
also defining duke ultimate please
support if you can grab the great
developer graham smith from nobody saves
the world check that out lord addicts
raising his head lord attic what's up
i know just before after you go i just
have one thing to say okay cool so
you're checking out our spaceship
exclusive um we got our last word with
ibonses ty got travis we have a girl
vertical vixen amazing check her out
talk about what's going on with um
destiny and sandbox economy and then um
for me it's been nobody changed the
world obviously outright is king new
horizon we're doing expeditions pretty
cool uh demio welcome back shout out to
sinister shout out to italian clowns
shout out to his man scorpion
yeah i got you i got you so add it get
ahead and then i got to do some business
with you just just just quick uh thing
real quick before we move on to the the
main course so i i would be
uh i can't leave kiss smooth out like
that kiss will be doing his uh halo on
legendary challenge it starts tomorrow
so definitely it's on uh you on his
youtube channel so if you guys want some
entertainment go over there to his
youtube channel sometime today subscribe
no doubt no doubt so we got that now
solve oh hold on hold on i see yeah i
see once i'm a little bit of royalty
pulling them already i see royalties
pulling up what's going on fellas oh
is that the legendary it's pittsburgh in
the building it's the black and yellow
in the building what's going on chase
money oh he got thrown by the bushes oh
[Applause]
that's good yeah yeah chase
was good
it's great to see y'all let's start with
chase money chase how you doing brother
i'm good i'm good beautiful morning no
afternoon now yeah right
can i can i see that shirt i got i go
you gotta talk some more so we can show
him in the bushes i bought this shirt
maybe 22nd
2021 your name saving it okay
and i was saving it and then when this
happened and i just happened to be asked
this week y'all scheduled this
when was that november yeah
[Music]
yo how crazy is that right
yeah bro appreciate y'all i gotta do
something too but yeah okay okay no
thanks for the invite no doubt brother
and of course the legendary 3mg lord
advanced gg 3mg my man outside moving
and shaking queens of the building
what's up 3mg how you doing man chillin
man chillin yo shout out to adam cause
he's been keeping us posted with the
whole podcast we was already with it we
was thinking about even going live like
doing the podcast after we was jumping
on yours and we was like you know what
[ __ ] it man let's get it right language
squeeze queen's still in the building
sir squeeze still in the building
[Laughter]
people in the chat saying you in a
spaceship three of you yeah
you're about to take over man you
already know good to have you brother i
appreciate y'all obviously with the
enormity of the news being able to come
in this way you know what i'm saying
it's that type of show but look solve
let's get some business now because
after this
right no doubt set the rules of
engagement uh okay first off rules of
engagement my brothers
as you can see if you look into the zoom
chat right
to the right of share screen is the
reactions button right and this is for
anybody on the show click on reactions
and you're going to see where it says
ray's hand so we're going to have heads
kind of rotating in and out today
because it's going to be
[Laughter]
what we don't want is people talking
over each other yeah i know people got a
lot of bars about today's uh subjects so
anytime you have something to say
somebody else is talking whatever just
put the ray's hand up addict myself or
or even or even uh um cog might will see
it and kind of put y'all in the queue to
know that you're talking next so that
way nobody's talking over each other
everybody gets their bars off yes um and
i'll repeat this as people start coming
in and out because as we said before
we have quite a show for you guys today
so um let's get them and yeah and beyond
that okay you would not believe that i
am still copy pasting it's crazy
it's kind of crazy so and i may have
missed something so
um apologies in advance it's that type
of show yeah it's that type of show you
guys are going wild in this chat which
we really really appreciate so i'm just
gonna roll back let's go and then
hopefully get them on their own on the
rebound just in case they slip through
if you yeah if you see if you see
anything that i i missed
all right we got um
we got twelve hundred
wow you're watching right now that life
please hit that like and share it out it
helps the algorithm it helps
and do me a favor right now if you know
somebody who's down right now yeah and
needs a laugh yeah bring him in for sure
bring him in bring him in always
if you know somebody who got a weak
bladder and you sit next to him
you better move
put your camera on record so you can
throw that up today because i'm gonna
make him pee on himself
let's get it all right let's start off
with malcolm hendricks five dollar super
chat gmg fam in here no doubt
what's up and we got percolator 9000
five dollar super chat i'm here to pay
my dues got my popcorn i am taking a
shot every time i hear the word time
i have a great show guys take a shot
you're gonna be you're gonna be under
the table you'll be under the table
within the next 10 minutes
there we got cat daddy lurk five dollar
super chat no replay this week this
smoke has to be viewed live
then we have render five dollar super
chat looking forward to this nine hour
episode in the iop we wanted people down
there you gotta go let us know walk in
that victory lap sir knees all day empty
knees
then we have five two five filippo five
dollars super chat phil dominus maximus
aurelius c already oh spencer they are
ready
then we got gamer live studio five
dollars for chat jamaican dance move
ryan got a lot of explaining to do and
you better not dodge any questions about
that activision and blizzard acquisition
savages yeah jim is on vacation today
and we got no no taco five dollars
why did we ever doubt king ps6 hmm
what is that can't wait for knack three
on xbox game fast and xbox series triple
x in 2027. hashtag the legend of king
hashtag the book of acts
then we got eliad shlomovic member for
21 months thank you sir
it's time let's
yeah go gotta take a shot it's gonna be
good yeah i've been waiting for the show
where you guys go ham since tuesday
happy to be here live for a change
welcome sir
to see you then we got big mad mo
members
the winner of our series x that's the
man right there it's about to go down
let's get it on pause
[Laughter]
i told y'all when we get uh 1500
subscribers i mean uh 15.
another console mm-hmm yes sir and we
got cedric h 10 super chat microsoft
told sony stop cheesing bro
hopefully this episode is better than
the man in the gown talking right now
behind the pulpit oh my goodness sharing
with my neighbor no we just bought
activist [ __ ]
yo go check out his new videos yeah chad
what's our game we got his youtube
channel man check him out
there we go heart geek cheney 10 super
chat salute to the lords microsoft takes
2022 right at the beginning of the year
spartacus will do what do do what to
change the narrative
xbox ftw king the floor is yours bring
it on xbox iop game pass iop dominance
hashtags all over the place
then we have suicide kings two dollars
super chat i have my popcorn let the
knees taken commence
and we got benny banks aka untainted g
betty blanco for the bronx
from the bronzer
what up lawyers had to come in and show
love nine again going to conference and
microsoft showing their pockets king and
cog love you guys as well as the rest of
the crew keep doing what you do no doubt
my brother thank you
then we have mr wolfe with the one pound
and 79 pence uh
chad king looking like it's christmas
2022
yo put the spacers up for this jacket
we're gonna have
just have king's face going like this
put it in the space
[Laughter]
then we have my old friend
wilbo gadkins
five dollar super chat hey fellas i can
almost never watch you live anymore due
to time zones but this week i made the
exceptions oh i appreciate you thank you
mr gaggins i appreciate that then we got
jay h two dollars over chap i'm here for
jamaican gym go off king
and we got robert braswell new member to
the room put the crest in the chat for
lord braswell
yes yes then we got tazo eg dollar super
chat lord saab shang shang singing
people your soul is mine
he came through
then we have max the lazy otaku with the
50 dollar super chat thank you my
brother
you know it's a special day when the
prophet is getting escorted safely home
the all father lord dominus aurelia
spencer walked into activision with the
johnny silverhand shades on and said
you're mine now blue team is silent
and green team is loud yeah all right so
clearly they're going to keep coming
just doing like three or four more these
are just the ones that i have copy paste
okay i'm gonna stop here all right so
yeah um then we have k johnson five
dollars from chat oh snaps look at the
fellas they back and already get into
the business let's go lords bless our
sunday with your wisdoms no doubt shout
out to keyshawn johnson just checking in
i love it thank you
that we have gaming times patrick five
dollars i burned the rubber from retro
shopping to get home and not miss the
show i heard there was some news this
week oh you heard it
then we have her coordinator five dollar
super chat what is the new name added to
phil spencer we haven't discussed that
yet but yeah he's he's almost there
people who've been asking about that
that's i'm gonna address that too
then we have a spartan ghost 17 two
pound super chat did dominus turn
playstation into a trap house
wow
that was good that was good
then we got back to lazy otaku once
again five thousand chat now that's out
the way silence in the room the profit
of xbox is ready to speak
then we have atl 2 super chat this show
was heavily advertised by twitter no
doubt thank you twitter then we got
pixel with g 2 chat let there be slander
yes sir let there be slanders
uh shout out to lord road lovers
remember for three months put the crush
on the chat today is lord's day yes sir
then we have a new member who has put
the crust in the chat for mr basura head
[Laughter]
with something serious torn mcl and acl
he did the damn thing salute to the
heavyweight champ and i think moreno won
no doubt uh we got two more then we're
done
uh
jay boy on the run two dollars
jay boy
i got you i'm a giants fan we got two
with eli no doubt exactly right
member for four months that's door is on
game pass the game finally released for
king yes yeah i gotta first first i just
want to say something quick about that
um because i was playing at um scott
draco uh gifted me the game okay a week
before it came in game pass and he said
in the message he was like king i'm i'm
tired of you not playing this great game
you didn't come out and game pass and
then it came out a week later so scott
are you good
and then the final one is just uh
welcome to the realm lord bronze kj
keyshawn johnson kate johnson welcome to
the room
we're going to finish out with that
ladies and gentlemen yeah today
every super chat but it will be at the
end of the show so keep them coming but
and we appreciate it we love y'all but
we're gonna have to leave it to the end
of the show because today is crazy i do
want to shout out though because they're
here now uh chase and 3mg with their
super chats i don't know if we got them
yeah yeah no it wasn't yeah they came
out crazy for us like they were crazy
crazy i would be disrespectful to not
see the people who are actually on the
panel
brother that was tremendous i appreciate
you appreciate it guys again rules of
engagement y'all is going to be a lot of
traffic today so you know a lot of
people will be coming in coming out use
the um for the panel use that raised
hand if you want to get bars off in the
middle of something it's going to be
hard i know it's going to be a fun one
but we just want to set that up so look
i know what y'all here for as soft would
say
you know i said but at the end of the
day we got we got to do it right we got
to um set this up a little bit because
there's been a lot of events that kind
of happened right during ilp's mission
so it started innocently i would say on
monday with um shout out to lord ryan
mccaffrey speaking to phil dominus
maximus so really is spencer with the
addressing initial rumors which pointed
to uh the service uh codename spartacus
which is sony service to replace
playstation plus service phil stated
that he didn't see any sony's
willingness to he yet he doesn't see
sony's willingness to emulate xbox
approach as proof he was right to push
for game pass early but more than it's
proof that things were always going to
go this way in the games industry he
said i don't really look at it as
validation when i'm talking to our teams
i talk about it as an inevitability i
like it because i think
because i think the right answer is to
ship great games ship them on pc ship
them on console ship them on cloud and
make them available day one in the
subscription clearly phil was already
talking on monday knowing that he would
eventually shake up the gaming industry
forever the next day so now we get to
the main event we're going to set up the
great prophet xbox of apocrypha xbox law
king i need everyone to kind of come to
the front of the congregation it's fine
so we're going to read from the great
book of acts
you know today revelation chapter 1
verses 68 million
and the epi the epic scripture says
welcome to the incredible teams and
legendary franchises of activision
blizzard to microsoft gaming creators of
call of duty world of warcraft candy
crush tony hawk diablo overwatch spyro
hearthstone guitar hero crash bandicoot
starcraft and more join team xbox on to
chapter 2 verse 68 billion and it reads
it is incredibly exciting to announce
that microsoft has agreed to acquire
activision blizzard over many decades
the studios and teams that make up
activision blizzard have earned vast
wellsprings of joy and respect from
billions we are incredibly excited to
have the chance to work with amazing
talented dedicated people across
activision publishing blizzard
entertainment bdox demon wear digital
legends high moon studios infinity ward
king
major league gaming radical
entertainment raven software
sledgehammer games toys for bob treyarch
and every team across activision
blizzard until this transaction closes
activision blizzard and microsoft gaming
will continue to operate independently
once the deal is complete the activision
blizzard business will report to me as
ceo
microsoft gavin lyrics written and
produced by phil dominance maximus
aurelia spencer so king
the realm has demanded i shut up and be
quiet
well you get the great prophecy of your
bars off so kick the floor is yours what
do you have to say about this
game pass had a face
stick em up
i can't get back out of face
stuck up i can't i cannot do that you're
mine now
your mind crashes
now you're minecraft
god forbid i see any
rpi like any rp i like i can't it's much
it's so messy
spyro
i like you
world of warcraft i like you
you're mine
diablo i see you getting dressed
backstage
come on
king
this is a 100 percent we get it all king
how you feel about overwatch too
overwatch
we just having fun with overwatch
[Laughter]
it's a sticker it's everything is a goal
nothing's safe
you are not safe now hold on let me get
king back let's get kicked back
yeah see like there was a something
happened
something happened ladies and gentlemen
we got hacked there we go my mother
friendly could not help you there
yeah
we had to call the boys
i'm just stepping back and let him
i got to tell you dudes first of all and
foremost i saw a lot of dudes out there
capping this week
i saw a lot of frauds out there cap a
lot of you lukewarm dudes saw if i need
to green one of those so
you do dudes is
you know um
you know microsoft is gonna do their
thing you know it could happen it could
maybe not happen it could it maybe it
could be it maybe cannot be
i told you from the beginning
phil was the greatest oh
i told you that when he was shooting in
the gym you did
before he turned pro
i told you that
and and you do just like man shut up why
are you giving them names and stuff what
you know you the ones out here calling
them uncle phil and phil daddy i'm not
doing that
[Laughter]
i'm not doing that
keep it respectful
i'm giving them the names that are
attributed to great women emperors i
hate
super chat i have to read and i'm
breaking i apologize bro
one of your nemesis has has been away
he has returned we have not seen him for
months free r kelly five dollars he let
him on the pc man
gotta say it king was right sony dunphy
that is a huge super chat y'all this man
has been antagonizing king for months
thank you thank you i appreciate you
kelly and um get back to yourself
get back to yourself get back to
yourself
so so when i gave him dominus yes
because he was dominating
when i gave him maximus he was doing it
to the maximum something like the likes
we have never seen
when i gave him aurelius he became the
golden one oh
i understand that name is complete
phil dominance maximus are really a
swiss it's done there's it's no
it's not a parody
i say the name with the to the man with
reverence
because it was all fun and games when
microsoft was about to get out the game
right it was all fun and games when we
was at death door right
it was all cool and nice when when when
my platform that i loved was about to be
out the room
and playstation was sitting there
dancing around graves remember y'all's
putting those those gifts with the
tombstone dudes kind of thing yeah
i told you this is the last playstation
now a lot of dudes is gonna sit there
and say oh you know king you can't i'm
not you
i'm not you and you won't be remembered
the only reason why i'm sitting there
talking about me
i'm gonna be down with this dude right
here i'ma respect this dude because this
dude is the i'm the only one that sat
there when the slings and arrows were in
the hospital when the fight was hot when
spider-man was dropping when god of war
was dropping while horizon was dropping
i said y'all about to catch this work as
soon as my man gets that back y'all done
for and y'all didn't understand what i
was talking about when that zenimax deal
went through i said wait there's more
now there's no way in hell on this on
god's earth that i know it was going to
be activism no well gary i've got a
respectful gift solved that one
i thought it was going to be ubisoft
yeah because i knew the numbers that was
involved
this is this this is you reap what you
sow oh
so all you dudes out there smiling and
keep keying and giggling and thinking it
was all good when just a couple of weeks
ago y'all was all in your fields talking
about yeah you know we're gonna have
final fantasy lockdown microsoft ain't
gonna get no mainline final fantasies it
was nice then right um
don't call out oh we need call of duty
we need we don't need your money
we don't need a nickel from you you
understand we just
turn off the faucet as soon as the
contract's up
oh
war zone
but if you want that real call of duty
main vein
get yourself in game pass
now
game pass can live on your box
but then again is it your box or is it
our box then
i told you them size 13s is at the foot
of your bed
who's size 13 that's phil's
and then satya pulls up with the size
12s right next to him
it's a situation
you know what this is unprecedented
first of all phil is the greatest ceo in
xbox history bar none that's it that's
god all right
i think i have the better need and i'll
give that one to you because you've had
you know how much i love peanut butter
and he's only been on the job three days
he's like i got
companies
lock stock and barrel yeah yeah not not
exclusive deals for six months
not not nothing weak there's no week so
this is moves of strength and you know
what everybody thinks it's about sony no
it's about netflix it's about google
it's about
the trillion dollar boys
10 cents
looking at your playstation they about
to be acquired by somebody
they looking really cute over there yo
okay come on
it might be us
so so when y'all sit there and say that
and you goofy ghouls beyond my timeline
talking about oh well phil said that you
know they're gonna be nice all the way
listen he said the same thing about
bethesda how'd that happen for you
he was nice
to the contract
that that was multiplied yeah yeah he
was up in that contract up until the
contract said it's over then he said no
soup for you
no soup for you
i hope y'all feel good i hope y'all feel
fantastic next month to take these
slings and arrows out of you because
right now y'all wounded
but it ain't no coming back from this
womb
this is your last generation as a
console
we want you and i tell you we want your
games i don't want playstation to go
away i want you to turn into sega just
like y'all had that energy with my sega
my sega is a developer now come on sony
the water fine that's what sega's saying
you can make mad money over here too
over here so this is still for sega this
was the mission
this is always bad for sega i just want
to be clear you you know that's the end
game
the water's fine
actor strange this yeah yeah yeah let's
see what i see what it is like i see
what he doing
turn around is fair play fair enough so
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander and this work is being put on
you by a bigger stronger entity now you
got to eat this and it's about done you
about cook so all of them dudes and i
know y'all sometimes be like king don't
be talking that that that console war
stuff it ain't a war if you ain't got
enough money to go against me
it ain't a war this is not a war it's
it's about
getting rid of weak business
you've been doing weak business for
years locking out exclusives and doing
all this stuff to one side and then they
looked at as the good guys you're not
the good guys you're the bad guys you
must be removed and turned into what you
want to be a software developer you make
great software your hardware is holding
us back you're bringing back the
playstation 4 and that's holding back
the generation we need to move forward
you're holding us back we got to take
you out of here i'm done and so is sony
okay all right
shout out to the 1500s watching this
live it says
yeah we tried not to interrupt we knew
this was this is pent up for years we
had to let this off and we appreciate
you
for you this is for sega clearly that's
eight years of that right
all jokes aside you know that we get
with kings from from from his uh
prophecy standpoint because he has been
fearless during the dark times of xbox
with a few content creators have so i
want to give my man these flowers for
that but we do have a lot of people in
here i want to be respectful let's start
with the first our first initial guess
which is chase money and and then 3mg
and then we'll get to boom because i
know boom's on the looming limited time
and we'll get to mike and everybody but
we're going to do this right so let's
start chase money when the news drop
which i just want to focus on reactions
first no legal no cod exclusivity just
yet just the reactions the feel the
energy in the building what what what
was you thinking when you heard this
news
i thought it was a lie
i lost a lot right chase i got on my
discord
look at that i got a discord i'm in
there i'm scrolling down and i'm saying
somebody put
i'm thinking it's like one of those
what's that the site with all the fake
articles
um
your hard drive's the one for video
games okay i'm like ain't no way
so i you know go on google go on twitter
and and i'm like yo this is where i call
ricky mm-hmm
ricky's like oh yeah i said man you know
looking a little rough out here
it's looking a little rough out here um
and i so we said a lot of stuff on the
podcast okay um but but yeah i just i
was like
i couldn't i could not believe that it
was really less about the acquisition
and more about how much they spent yeah
16. on top of
the actual acquisition because
at no time did i ever think
that that would happen
um
really what was the bethesda deal
seven seven point five billion and keep
in mind chase that this is coming from a
company yeah that a few years ago was
debating on selling the brand yeah yeah
yeah we're talking about yeah but see
that's why i like y'all cause y'all
y'all know
the ups and downs yeah and you know
where stuff is instead of just
trying to sweep stuff under the rug you
know what i mean but that's the deal
seemed like it was just
yesterday
to get up basically what felt like the
next day and see that i was like oh man
i got a xbox though i'm good
[Laughter]
are you implying that you're a real
gamer that you're gonna go with the
games or i'm just saying i'll play a
game on the vcr for me let me get a good
experience okay
fair enough no doubt let's get a little
3mg man i'm curious you know because i'm
assuming let me ask you before chase one
quick you you guys i can see you guys
still play cld or you guys kind of
cooled off like where y'all at with
c.o.d just playing it as a mainline
franchise i was curious about that part
he's the ex-girlfriend i keep taking
back
okay all right i just want to make sure
but now let's get let's get to the 3mg
as far as just the reaction brother like
where were you what was the vibe what
was the energy what were you thinking
when you heard about microsoft acquiring
activision blizzard
when uh i woke up that morning i just
received a bunch of dms from like a
bunch of my followers that were like hey
yo this is crazy and i'm like what are
we talking about here i thought it was
like a fake tweet or a fake like post
and i've and then i ran into bed i
started crying when i was like
crying because
to be honest you know you know the
saying is nothing really affects you
until it happens to you right so being
someone who grew up playing cod
knowing how bad that game just had year
after year yeah actually was crying um
figuratively of tears of joy because if
there's a company i believe that could
possibly turn this game around
we said it before chase denied that it
would be xbox like it would be the only
company that would be the only company
that's the only company i would trust
can i ask why because there is a
trepidation there and uh that's a great
that's an interesting perspective so i
want to know why 3mg why because you got
that's why i love that you guys it just
worked out so perfect because i know how
much passion you guys have for it so
it's like why does it feel so good like
that
in in your case that they have the
ownership of a franchise you love
well it was the consistency of phil
throughout the years because we've we've
seen it the ups and downs and obviously
if he's going to be the face he's going
to take the hits he's going to take the
ls the w's even if it's not if it's not
his fault and normally uh anybody who
takes the floor to become ceo cfo
anything like that they don't last long
in this co in this climate yeah so
seeing that he's been here since the
initial xbox one release it was kind of
interesting to see how he was holding it
together when he acquired bethesda and
seeing all the perks that they were
trying to bring out he wasn't coming off
selfish he was trying to spread that
love across all the platforms still and
then bringing it over now with this huge
deal um i just feel like he's more so in
the in the in the business of making
business and making money and not more
so just we're just acquiring this title
it's going to be the popular title i
think he's looking forward to actually
fixing his game keeping it across all
the platforms you know you might have
some you know exclusivity uh leisure
towards it but i think i trust his
judgment on it i think he wants to fix
the game that initially brought the 360
to just like it's a fact it's it's it's
huge like you know a milestone so i
think i i put my trust in that i
initially thought it was going to be
ubisoft i think a lot of us yeah a lot
of us thought that yeah we saw the
initial yeah the thing with the ubisoft
thing um and i said at the end of the
year some form of fashion is being
inside game pass and you know i got the
buzzer beta at the fourth quarter
um
but
i still think that's on the table one
thing i just want to throw out to the
group
no money chains hands yet right it's a
it's an agreement in principle right
right so the agreement in principle is
once they vet everything and once
everything passed all right
stuff like that they still have 120
billion on deck for acquisitions
be careful
all that stuff y'all wish for
remember no money change hands that
money will change hands next year june
23rd
uh in 2023 i mean
up to 18 months it could happen that's
the latest i think again yeah that's the
latest
it can happen before then yeah i'm just
saying there's money for more purchasing
no doubt i won't ricky uh authorized
finishes bars and i got to get boom
because i know he's on limited time as
far as next up on his bar so any other
statements on the just the reaction are
you are you good 300 on the initial
reaction well i i know uh chase wells
myself uh he's the overwatch guy i am
the call of duty guy we both are
initially we're just trying to see these
games released
we're also happy that you remember that
initial that initial boom of news that
happened with that gentleman over at
activision and seeing everything that
happened
it's kind of
in in a marketing sense it's actually
great to see that phil's now kind of
honestly going to be like the face now
of like an activision in the near future
i'm hoping this deal lands
i actually have i don't know i have all
consoles dude i got nothing to worry
about
brother lord boom i'm gonna put you up
next because i know your time is limited
man um
crazy news i know i got a call from you
you're one of the calls that came
through early on on a tuesday morning so
i knew it had to be breaking but i got
the double call i knew it had to be
breaking but boy man now that you got a
chance to process again initial
reactions
where were you what was the vibe what's
the energy what do you feel about
microsoft acquiring activism
this is real folks uh i was i was
walking up with the wash that's what i
was doing and the phone rings and it's
chaosante and i missed the call so the
minute i get in i dropped the bag it
wasn't the money bag but it was a wash
bag
and uh i call him up and he goes hey
boom did you see the news and i said
what are you talking about i didn't see
anything he goes microsoft just bought
activision i just sent you filled a phil
dominus maximus of releases
tweet
so i looked at it and i'm like dude this
is a hack bro this is someone
because
this is this can't be true
so i walked around the apartment three
times and i don't remember doing it
because i was like what what do i do
first who do i call how do i set up on
an emergency podcast you know was going
up i did a podcast at 10 o'clock in the
morning
it was
this is something
that is so
it seems like a fable like like like
someone is telling you the most extreme
story right ever hear yeah yes because
if if if you look at what they've done
like we all sat back and said yo that
bethesda deal
bonkers
just straight up bonkers
because of the legendary ip that came
along with it the deal itself almost
eight eight a billion dollars we were
all still moved by it
and then you turn around and they
literally spend
almost 10 times that yeah on uh
two companies well two two entities
that are at the crux of every
conversation every year and
unfortunately
they've been in the news for a lot of
really bad stuff right and bobby carter
you know we knew uh the minute i saw
this the first thing i thought was
this is redemption for the people that
work there this is the human see this is
something i've taught this is something
i've talked about on my shows this out
this entire week
the call of duty thing is so
small-minded and it's so it's so tiny
in the conversation because it's not
just call of duty the mobile aspect with
king not king david we know he's money
i think king king got the deal done
it's it's pretty it's pretty ridiculous
like i almost expect game pass from
mobile to be announced next year when
this deal gets done to add another
aspect to more money for microsoft to
come in and offer that through mobile it
it almost seems like it's it's it's
already written in stone
but you know like i said the call duty
thing sure it's big
but
like tomorrow night on prime time gaming
i broke down the eight studios that were
in the salt mines of call of duty and if
that comes from ksanti he's like they
were basically
just stuck there making and churning out
i mean toys for bob they went from
making some of the greatest platformers
to just being a support studio that's a
travesty of gaming justice
and every one of these studios or now
are going to be given
a way to hey what do you want to work on
and they're going to say i want to work
on this could you imagine banjo-kazooie
from toys for bob wow yeah
i mean that almost seems like it's it's
it's like the it's the glass slipper
yeah kind of a situation and then you
look at treyarch and high moon studios
our transformers bro there you go the
two best transformers ever in the
history
and and what i'm actually hoping is that
microsoft who now will own these
companies will allow
um infinity ward to staff up and make a
call of duty once every three years
because they have war zone they don't
need a new call of duty every year and
if that if that same infinity war that
brought us modern warfare even though
the same people aren't there leading it
they could bring us you know a
three-year developed game would be what
we want from the old school call of
duties like that big epic popcorn movie
that didn't feel cheap right right
so i mean i i like i said i i
i like even today we're talking now this
is five or six days later and it still
doesn't even seem real yeah like
microsoft
just bought activision blizzard that is
bonkers to say out loud and on top of
what you see and that's the thing that's
even crazy they went from think about
this for a second guys and this is this
is the perspective aspect of it
pre e3 2018
right
microsoft was struggling bad yeah they
had five studios
right january 2022 they have 38.
that's
what could you say about phil other than
he has logistically
changed
gaming
in a matter of a couple of years yeah
microsoft gaming is the strongest it's
ever been and i got to be honest with
you to king's point i know he's very
funny with this
sony's in big trouble dude because they
bank on selling their consoles
even when spartacus releases
what are they offering because we know
that the first party is going to be
isn't in there right but definitely
so what what are they offering
microsoft has the industry on lock
especially when little man is being
dropped down to 250 by by christmas of
this year
there's there's going to be you're going
to see the the normies or the casual
gamers
that powered sony last gen move over to
xbox and we're already seeing it now
yeah a lot of potential man um we'll see
what happens again monstrous move i
don't know i know if your time is let me
let me know because i want to get you
right because i know things are going on
but um
yeah absolutely monstrous move oh let's
get lord boom boom boom killed it by the
way yeah i just wanna let y'all know
yeah was fine
first of all let me just say this uh
everyone i'm working with here chase and
i see ivan in there and ricky guys this
is this is a big deal for me because
i've seen you on the shows before
i love your work
i'm i'm very small i literally opened my
channel is but where's let's get this
boom stick to over 10k please y'all
and go subscribe to this channel because
mr boomstick xl help us uh bro we have
let's get up
1000 yeah
yeah it's it's
it's you know
for me uh you know when i started this
channel i went at him i i thought it was
incredibly important to
build it with community first in mind
and that's how i run my channel we don't
run it with hate we don't run it with uh
you know click bait titles or pictures
it's it's about people that's why this
deal was again i i want to just stress
one other thing and i'll out pastor mike
over
the human element factor here
is the most important part of this
entire conversation because of what
those poor people
that worked under the devil for years
are no longer going to be a part of got
to understand human resources is
supposed to be a place a safe spot that
if you have a problem whether you are
black white gay straight catholic or
jewish it doesn't matter you're supposed
to be able to go there and get the help
that you need and they couldn't do that
because bobby kotick
knew that he had that particular part of
activision
locked down and they worked for him
because phil spencer and because
microsoft is uh one of the best places
to work and has been
rated as the best place to work because
of their
incredible ideologies of inclusion
these folks are now going to be given
they they see the light at the end of
the tunnel and like i said i know that
you know this is a game show right and
we want to talk about the
gaming right that's what we're going to
talk about but we can't forget the human
element that literally they are this
microsoft right now is the superhero of
this story because those people get to
develop
gaming again and not worry and crying
closets and and go to human resources
and get fired because of it so that's
i just wanted to say that as for the
channel
we're officially 60 subs away from 10k
get them there and we're doing it in
record time i've only been doing youtube
for
four years and only live content for
three
i don't know if it's my tenacity for
doing live content or just
being retired that that certainly helps
but it's been a pleasure to work with so
many people and getting you guys to the
one thousand that's probably my favorite
favorite moment in in my career so great
for me i appreciate you thank you so
much
1900 people watching
i don't know who could argue with what
you just said yeah honestly much much
love much love let's get lord nlg the
original
lord of gaming here in the realm haven't
had him in a while so it's good to see
him and sneak them in on this
talk to me bro like what what was going
through your head when this news hit
your timeline
so
this this caught me um early in the
morning i usually get up you know i wake
up
i grab my phone i'm still in bed i grab
my phone i check my work email and then
i start checking you know my social
media see what's going on and
i started to see people i didn't even
see the actual news i saw people
going on my timeline going
what do you mean microsoft bought
activision i'm thinking
okay all right come on stop stop
then i started scrolling through the
next then i caught then i caught the uh
the xbox wire
link
and i'm reading
and i'm i'm usually you know me i could
talk
for days
i somehow i was frozen looking at that
at that article going
did this just happen right i mean it's
it's it's
almost the same
reaction i had when i saw zenimax
but
it it dawned on me that
i what we were what i was getting ready
to see what happened on my timeline was
going to be something epic
um and it was because
twitter really exploded and
um
i i
i it was hard to believe we also did
something that night so i know we you
know peter got with me and said mike we
got to go on tonight and i'm like
okay you don't want to wait till
thursday and he's like no
no no no no
he's like now
and chris said yep let's do this so
it took me all day to kind of
to kind of to to process this and and
and
boom same with with me man i'm still
trying to figure out how this happened
because
if you think about
everybody's talking about call of duty
right and and yet that's the big fish
yes but you got to remember what else is
in that portfolio pitfall
thank you oh wow oh geez that speaks to
our soul
that is that is one of the first things
i thought of was could that and if you
listen to what you feel said in one
mm-hmm
[Laughter]
i just want to say candy crush for one
reason because they have an active user
uh content of
250 million
the the micro transactions they make on
that i will is remember when when they
bought mo yang for for 2 billion and we
were like oh god that's a lot of money
yeah
there's a reason that they're gonna make
this an all-cash payout they cause
they're gonna make that back in thank
you for saying that a short amount of
merchandise
but but but pitfall and and when you
heard when you heard phil talk to one of
the on one of his interviews he brought
up guitar hero yeah he's been dying to
make a comeback
and for us old guys um and and you
that's why some of you guys are like who
are these people
oh let's see anybody remember sierra
entertainment
that king's quest that
re-release
by our gentleman yes was unbelievable
and captured the kind of magic that i
used to i grew up playing the old king's
quest they own king's quest
space quest police quest quest for
heroes
the things that if if phil really wants
to to do what he said which was i saw
all these ips and i said i got to have
them
that is where for me because i haven't
played and
i'm probably going to get some hate in
the chat
speak your truth i haven't played a call
of duty game honestly
since black ops won
i do not i don't like it
i mean
boom i don't like where
and i think i caught you you were you
know you were talking about getting back
to the old days of like world at war
right those are the kind of games you're
talking about
and i have no hate for treyarch treyarch
has made some great call of duty games
too so i'm okay with them but those are
not the games i'm looking at the games
i'm looking at are the rest of the
portfolio that now everybody's call
talking about about those and what
playstation is going to keep call of
duty fine right let them keep call of
duty i honestly don't care bring me
a new
sierra game bring me something new from
toys toys for bob that yeah like you
know um and and bring me those games
that i
can sit and and rolling game pass and
and yeah and go through
that are gonna be enjoyable to me be nox
make some great stuff and don't forget
microsoft owns diablo now that is not a
small thing that is huge all right that
is not a small thing
um
and and boom i'm glad you brought up the
um
kind of the internal pieces too because
there was a there's a there was a piece
to that
news article to the original xbox news
one that was not lost on me and that is
when he said once the deal is complete
the activision blizzard business will
report to me
[Music]
remember not
not to matt booty because remember matt
booty is the is the one
studios
to me as ceo of microsoft gaming that is
a that is a direct
shot
to let everybody know that the that the
bs
i agree and and that is something that
is very important as we go through this
and i i'll uh one more piece and then
i'll give it up to to i think ivan might
be yeah i see ivan what's up
people that have been on this monopoly
thing and i know you're going to get to
this but i got to case i'm not here when
you guys get to it
they now have 36 studios right with this
acquisition and this whole well they're
just buying up everybody
anybody know who embracer group is thank
you i do
you know how many do you know how many
studios they have right now 90 plus yep
86 fish
they have
they have thq nordic they've got koch
media who has deep silver they've got
saber they've got gearbox
they've got so before we get into this
microsoft is trying to destroy the
industry let's not forget that companies
like tencent are doing these little
deals where they're buying five percent
of those companies
right so they can get that they own 40
percent of epic embracer group is going
to continue to buy studios people have
to understand that the industry is
coalescing right
microsoft either has to get on the ball
with it
or they are going to get pushed out
and right now phil and i and i never do
this oh king i never do this uh-oh
because on nlg wheat we're a little more
you know this is probably why nobody
watches us a little more straight up
we're a little more buttoned up there
buddy
maximus aurelius spencer thank you
knows
that he has to do what he has to do
for the xbox brand
to survive they are still with this
acquisition only the third highest game
revenue generator behind
sony and tencent so i mean you know with
for all of the sony you know i i know
you i know you you play a lot on that
king and it and it's and it's awesome
but
but
sony is still the king of game revenue
and losing call of duty
is
it it might hurt him a little
but that's honestly not these days where
people are buying playstation for it's
not why i have my ps5 i got my ps5 for
ratchet and clank because in february
y'all ain't going to see me on xbox
and forbidden
the only
reason that's a flawed um logic
and and i'm i'm going to explain why
it's a flawed logic
right because let's go back to the old
uh playstation 4 let's go back to
heyday for them right 125 million they
don't have not one game on that console
that sold 125 million and i can tell you
that any given uh call of duty title
outsold their best title right so
that's a flawed logic a lot of people do
purchase for the exclusives but while
they're there
and while they're at the buffet people
go through
yeah they're gonna get french fries
they're gonna get everything else that's
there and what's very popular is the
french fries so
when somebody takes french fries off
your menu imagine you going to
mcdonald's and they said oh burger king
now got exclusive deal on french fries
damn i like french fries
i can't shop here no more so microsoft
just took the french fries off your
minion it's nice that you got a big mac
and people may show up and pick up your
big mac but if they get a big mac no
fries
i think i'm gonna have to go give me a
whopper so
for a little while i mean what if i hate
that
well listen it may not hurt now
but at the long run the more stuff taken
off your menu what no mcnuggets every
time you look and there's something less
off your menu that's so that's it that's
a hurt inside your wallet but right now
they're good though
that is a good analogy but i would take
it the other way too and just say that
and and i want to shout out my brother
my brother htk 360.
um peter he said something very profound
on twitter and and it honestly resonates
he said and this is his quote
buying exclusivity which is what sony
does right now final fantasy all this
other stuff buying exclusivity over and
over is like a poor man's acquisition
sony does have the ability
and this is why i think
they may not be as they as hurt
yet
they have the ability to counter by
going to square enix and saying hey
friend
final fantasy and that's a big mover
um so they're you know
that that has a
a an opposite because i know a lot of
xbox fans would love to play final
fantasy right but not having it draws
people over there as well
it's just it's a different it's a
different mindset and i think what phil
is doing
i think is going to work
great for them
um and i think that in the long run
um you're going to see
a lot more coalescing of studios and
you're going to be thankful i'm just
saying you're going to be thankful
that activision went to microsoft
and i wouldn't care if it went to sony
honestly if sony bought activision i
would uh same thing i got a ps5 i'm good
as well
you don't want you don't want 10 cent
embracer or some of these others owning
activision i'm just telling you i'll
feel that job
yeah
my sega brother the original
og you know 6360 days and going to e3
doing things and meeting the movers and
shakers in the industry want to give you
your flowers on that also i loved your
point on um those classic games the
sierra you know and like boomers talk
about the high moon only for the
standpoint as well just from a base
standpoint if they could even bring
those into the service for back compat
you know licensing and the marvel games
and all that stuff that would be cool
too to see just to kind of get the feel
back of why those games are beloved but
brother thank you so much i gotta get
inca he's been playing yeah absolutely
i'm out uh guys thank you hey uh south
stradamus thank you good caller
so and hey we'll we'll take 10k
subscribers oh yeah bro let's go bring
them all
what's the challenge what what's the
channel name tell the people
all right we are at the original next
level gaming you can put next level
gaming in your youtube search and
that'll show up um
uh we do
we're on thursday nights at 9 00 pm uh
eastern standard and i'm starting to get
back into doing some live streaming
myself and just for you guys lat
yesterday yesterday with some saturn
shmups oh we have some shadows
galactic attack okay serious guiding
okay little yeah little sky target
little import action case i'm putting
you're my gaming family love you guys
we're going to get you back on the show
king king listen
xbox
i just wanted to say a huge thank you uh
uh you gotta be over the hump uh i'm 10k
finally i've i've joined the podcast
xbox era all of our little circles uh i
i i i have to say you got you got me
over the hump and it's because of
this loving community i mean 1900 people
here is
just incredible and you know
listen
the reason why people come back is
because of how you guys these what you
see here ladies and gentlemen is who
they are this isn't a facade
and the i've never seen the king rob guy
show up before that's new i don't know
what happened
[Laughter]
but listen i just want to say thank you
guys for having me uh you got a huge
guest list yeah a real big shout out to
ricky and to uh you know to ivan and
chase and mike which i got to get on one
of my shows yes yeah youtube boom we got
to get you running
we gotta get you yeah we need to see
that we gotta get you that's what
100 but listen guys thank you so much
for helping me get in okay we finally
got there uh it was congratulations
thank you so much uh for this year uh
and we actually hit it earlier because i
was hoping first quarter and we got the
first month and um
thank you again thank you very much man
congrats man have a blessed day thank
you guys all right all right lord
anchorman and then uh you guys
move so let's start with lord anchorman
the og one of the finders of iron lord
podcast what is the the shadow broker of
iron
the man who put a lot of our faces to
the masses and really showed people hey
they got a good podcast he's yeah he's
reason there's
1922 people in here definitely not like
that we got to get it man
real quick
check me cause he's like y'all love to
be on and i almost got hollywood on the
phone but i was like i got to see if i
five wrote i said wait a minute [ __ ]
what are you doing
what are you doing this is acro v2 with
two twitter profiles
because he held down my book bag
and i left it fast we had to drive up
into the most sketchy neighborhood in
california that i've ever been through
you know the neighborhood is so sketchy
when you call over to take you there and
you call over to get you out and it's
the same uber
did you just just uh say you know i do
know that a lot of people are probably
coming here for the first time if you
guys enjoy the podcast definitely
subscribe to the channel
every sunday at 1pm no doubt so again 15
000 another console of your choice if
you want that last playstation 5
ridiculous that last place anyway hey
goodman
what's the vibe brother what's the vibe
talk to me
so when all this stuff went down i was
got you i got you i
i was i was at um
i just got snowed in at my girlfriend's
house
so
i was sleeping on the floor and i woke
up and it was about seven o'clock in the
morning
and i'm next up i'm next to a husky
i look down on my phone i don't even see
the tweet from phil i don't even see
that
i see jason schreier oh salute
i see
the the pre-damage control and i'm like
whatever this is is real
what is going on and i looked and i was
like oh
crap
[Music]
as i call you
oh yeah when i got the double anchorman
call i lose something happen
did i call you i called a couple other
people um was it i think the only person
who was able to pick up the phone was
fame
on the phone with fame like
look
this just happened he's like no
no no way
but
i'm going to be honest
this did not hit as hard as the bethesda
feel we know your team potentially
no that's not it's not i have to agree
with the thing because it was the
bethesda thing was like out of left
field like what okay
we're doing publishers now
i think what it is that was out of left
field but like this like we kind of we
didn't think a realm of possibility than
buying publishers existed before
bethesda but now it's just like they
bought activision yo
that makes sense but yo
we were all thinking about like ubisoft
warner brothers we're thinking small
potato publisher kind of deals and then
it's like activations of what
yeah
so it just was the surprise of who
it was
uh but
i'm gonna be honest here
if i were microsoft right now i need to
go out there and start making a
commercial crash bandicoot and spyro
immediately
because that
i i never sat right with me whenever
sony sold those two specifically to
activation that never sat right with me
it was like look you're not gonna do
anything with them you gotta sit on them
like just out of sheer respect
like that it'll be like this like
nintendo like not doing anything with
mario and then just selling mario to
somebody else okay like it just it's
it's rude
and rude
it's just rude
but
i
can't believe that now those are going
to be xbox properties yeah beautiful and
it's getting to the point where like now
and like i thought about this for a
little bit so i caught a glimpse of like
this uh an order like a like a 2020 like
a business 2020 kind of profile on sony
and
with a playstation
like this is from back like early 2000s
um and i watched this for a little bit
and i was like you know what this
actually makes a lot of sense
and this may just because of because of
last year specifically with microsoft
where they were like talking about their
legacy talking about like honoring their
older pro like all these older like
properties they've been working with for
years
and i don't get that from sony anymore
at all
jim don't care it's like
it's like yep it's all it's in the it's
in the bushes now we're done with it we
don't need it anymore we're done
and it's like
and i just sit back and i'm thinking
about i'm like
yeah that makes a lot of sense they sit
in the here and now if it makes the
money right now it's going to be their
their number one thing
and
it's just comparing it to microsoft
lately
all we keep seeing from microsoft is
look we got doomguy everywhere we got we
got master chiefs getting a brand new
game and
we keep seeing like all these like
smaller older franchises and them still
getting that love and respect
all the way through and microsoft
quickly is becoming the legacy box where
it's we respect
where all of our properties have come
and where they're going to go in the
future and that just blows me away i've
been thinking about that last few days
yeah it's it's and i'm sorry
yeah that's it no i just i was there the
last few days and i just that that
really hit home to me specifically yeah
no right let me ask you a question
really just got this
i know just just just specifically on
the spiral and and the crash right just
just specifically on it do you think
that uh as soon as the contract is done
and you know those things as inks do you
think that they put those games into
work on um on for you know for exclusive
and just bring them back to prominence
in your opinion because i'm real i'm a
crash dude i like crash and i love
spiral you know like for my son or
whatever but do you think they put them
back to the forefront because you're
talking about legacy that's just my
question
i don't know if they're gonna put them
back in the forefront per se but i
i bet they're gonna do uh you know you
know the 4k 60 fps treatment for them
whatever the reignited trilogy
i'm sorry i hope your work's not done
i have to be honest i hope they put you
back to work in the team i'm sorry
yeah you know
on the publisher level like they could
go back and do that specifically instead
of just doing it as a backwards
compatibility push right but
i think they at least giving them that
kind of treatment like what was it boom
talked about like banjo kazooie get toys
for bob to go do that and like you
basically update all of these great
games that just need that extra extra
level of polish just to bring them
forward and keep them relevant no doubt
and that that's what i would love and
like
i think the big thing for me and we kind
of like touched on this a little bit is
that now you have everybody
in the salt mines from call of duty now
available to work on projects they want
to work on and i know that i was i can't
find it now because all the stuff now
was about toys for bob and like the
acquisition deal but toys r was on
record saying they'd be interested in
working on a banjo-kazooie game
they've been on record saying that and
so i can't imagine things have changed
that much where they don't want to work
on that anymore no doubt said but like
also the other thing too and this is the
this thing i think they should do
specifically
because phil's talked about his love for
these types of games
tony hawk
[Music]
right because vicarious visions got put
in the call of duty salt mines
after pro skater 1 and 2 the the plus
thing came out and that was great one of
the best remasters i've ever played
and
having them be able to work on a new a
new tony hawk game like a real tony hawk
game
and just that'll blow my mind yeah like
there's so many possibilities here
so cool there's so many possibilities
yeah i'm sorry no i'm sorry i didn't
mean to cut you i didn't catch you
this is i said there's just so many
possibilities here i'm blown away by it
and i i'm excited for the future
literally me and you on the same page
there with the potential and i want to
get ricky before i'm moving because he
had his hand up and i want to respect
that we got to be quick uh lord 3mg and
then i got to get 14. no no no okay it
was it was just to give boom his flowers
at that oh okay
we'll make sure we miss you i appreciate
for everybody that's jumping in people
coming out use the hand on the zoom that
that'd be appreciated let's get gaming
forte a kid smooth what tell you there
brother
yo what's going on brother how you
feeling man what's the what's the energy
oh live
something must have really happened big
this week yeah something happened huh
man i know i got a phone call from my
best friend that
tuesday morning dropping my kid off at
school saying
yo did you see what happened and i was
like huh
and he said yo um
activation just got bought by microsoft
i list i i had to practice safe driving
i was like stop the car
pull it over it's like say that again he
told me i was like all right let me go
to twitter as soon as i pull twitter up
i didn't even get a chance to see any
articles or any tweets all i saw was six
spaces going on at one time
all the
every space it was like the spaces were
everything from celebration
to is this good for the community or for
gaming in general to like all of the
rejects like yo
they just cried it was just crazy so
look man
yeah it was crazy it was it was nuts but
i wasn't surprised i mean i was
surprised that the number i would say i
was surprised at 70 billion dollars
but um
it was something that i was that we've
been telling people for a while is like
microsoft if they want if they wanted to
if they wanted to open up that checkbook
they could do it right and people never
and that's the thing no one never knew
if that was a possibility if they were
100 bought in right as soon as the
bethesda thing went through everybody
was like oh microsoft's here to play
now we're like oh everybody's on the
table there's no
there's
there's no there's nothing that
microsoft wouldn't be willing to do and
they got this at a discount i'm i'm more
excited for the possibilities of what
this could do
outside of like i know a lot of people
talk about the call of duty side of it
and everything and that's cool i stopped
playing call of duty so long ago because
call of duty was just super saiyan
but um i'm just excited for
the pc side of it
if you stay in hole
cause i got i got it i got y'all my
experts stick around yeah please please
don't don't touch on the pc part cause
we won't
yeah i'm more excited for that side of
it because i feel like that's the side
that xbox has been struggling in when it
comes to
their play anywhere initiative in their
pc side of it with the microsoft store
but this also is a three-prong approach
because it opens up an avenue that they
didn't even have their foot into which
was the mobile side of it
mobile was gonna be huge for them they
literally acquired the third biggest
mobile publisher when it comes to
revenue
ever what's the name
[Laughter]
king boo-boo
oh my god we get it live while we get in
love
overall this was just it it was exciting
to see
how many people were just
enamored with this whole thing and it
was also cool to see a lot of people
just talking about it that didn't know
what the heck they were talking about i
was like
it was it was like the spectrum was like
zero to a hundred but
look man this is gonna be something that
a lot of people are gonna be talking
about for months and months on end until
the deal finally comes down i see you in
the topic list you got the word desire
we got we've got a special guest for
that
forte
hey forte has anybody came inside the
store today and said can i get a lock
hard please
[Music]
[Laughter]
the one funny thing was i was in a
meeting because i had to work on that
tuesday and i had my regional here and
they were talking it was like yeah man
that activision deal with right we're
calling with microsoft is big and there
was like are we gonna even sell call of
duty anymore
the ramifications
well because it's a gay passing if they
you know the possibilities of pulling it
off of playstation right you know
ultimate ultimately the biggest thing i
want people to take from just the
initial
foray of everything that happened was
if you have a playstation no one's
telling you to throw your playstation
away right that's the biggest thing
people need to realize your playstation
it's going to be a collector's item
might throw away mine
stop me i got you there
no no everybody ever keep keep your
system
i always told people last generation
microsoft did not give people that were
on the playstation platform a reason to
own an xbox that was the reason that was
the discrepancy between last generation
and the in the 360 or xbox one and ps4
generation now people are mad because
xbox is giving you a reason to buy a
system but they're not telling you to
throw your old system away they're just
saying hey yeah we just want you to if
we want you to come to our ecosystem now
if uh you know jim ryan wants to go
ahead and actually have to put game pass
on there that's a whole nother
conversation that's a whole another
thing he's complicit in doing it that's
fine too but ultimately
phil just wants you to be where he wants
you to be when it comes to that equal
system that they're playing
he wants you to play in game pass you
don't care if it's on the move playing a
game pass he doesn't care if it's on the
shuttle discovery playing on game pass
he just wants to play game pass and that
doesn't and i also see the conversation
around people saying
well why would they sell it in game pass
and not sell it to people on places is
that the only avenue i said that doesn't
mean they can't sell it at a 70 price
tag on playstation 2. they just give you
the option just like they do on that
spot so
oh lord bump it up to me they like
paying for quality right no savages
how about no you don't get it unless you
got game pass or you got an xbox no we
will get it
call of duty
war zone
oh well there it is we will get it
well this was a what i say this was a
good good this was really really good
microsoft needed to do this this goes
back to the last two years all the
initiatives that phil spencer put into
place and saying that
he's committed to xbox and this is the
direction they're going in i'm super
happy to see him do it no doubt kids
boom real quick rules of engagement has
to change for a little bit because we
are behind on time with certain guests
that may be appearing so what we're
going to do is lords
we will give our vibes at the end so you
know what i'm saying because we got to
get together
yeah lord we have to as we if we add on
with these topics it's going to go crazy
so i want to i want to definitely get
kids moved for the last of the first
topic which is the initial reaction how
did you feel kid talk to me
talk to me yeah
all right uh check the something i first
think i do this is bad habit when i wake
up in the morning
i check twitter just to try but i didn't
see anything no no i didn't check my
timeline i had some dms and it was dms
from people i don't really talk too
often we shared a few things here and
there there was like
let's go
like it's like a championship
what's up and then i was like
let me go on to the home page
and i started to see everything in order
i see first the rumor
and i'm like ah no no because it looked
like every other rumor right so i'm like
oh okay whatever i was like we'll see
did i see jason schreier did my eyebrows
be nice respect look
then i seen the xbox i was like
i was like dang i gotta go to work
so i'm like
oh man
i don't know what to do so i'm sitting
there pacing around
like in the garage and i'm like all
right
let me call attic call addict
[Laughter]
he doesn't pick up the phone i'm like
i'm calling him right back so i call her
right
he finally wakes up
and i was like yo are you awake and he
was like he's like
oh yeah what's up and i was like yeah
did you see did you see it he was like
he was like whoa i was like xboxing
activision
and he was like are you he's like hold
on and did he i don't know he checked
something and he was like i gotta go
such an accurate portrayal
like when he first called i picked like
i wrote over it was like it was early
man i i didn't get off work it was a day
it was my day off i hit that red button
man i was i'm going back to bed so i
rolled back over and then he called me
directly back i'm like all right let's
make sure he alive
so that he picked up and i was like i
the i didn't say i gotta go i was like
okay i guess i'm up the rest of it i'll
talk to you later
yeah so
i was just like
so my head locked in there now at this
point i got to be responsible but i'm
mad i'm like
i was at work
i can't go live i can't do nothing i'm
like and i gotta drive to work trying to
focus
i'm like
i'm thinking about things i'm going to
tweet thinking about videos i'm trying
to do but i can't because i got a whole
another eight hours of work
yeah like um
i would just i had to like soon as i got
into office i i checked everything and
then i was like all right let me just
lock myself away at like i got something
going on
and i'm just like reading everything i'm
like yo
this is real this i'm like and all i can
think of i know everybody's talking
about like king and stuff i don't care
about kings
it's stuff like that
i'm thinking about you
could it be full circle it is called
duty but to be exclusive and i'm like
ended up thinking about
hold up they didn't all right they
announced overwatch 2 and diablo 4 but
they haven't been like formally revealed
or anything like that i'm like dang they
can have this in the bag and i'm like oh
man a whole another year people ask him
is this coming to playstation is this
coming to this that in the third and
whatnot but um
right now um
even though i'm not going to front like
i'm the biggest you know activision fan
yeah like i am i am i am not there's
like activision publishes a lot of games
that i'm like man should i buy that
like i always wanted to buy crash he he
was paid to play overwatch by the way so
i was paid to play overwatch yes but i
ended i ended up enjoying it uh and um
and there's 120 frames on the xbox
series
um
thank you for the clarification
[Laughter]
let's flex that muscle sir
i'm thinking about all the kids
[Laughter]
position
that's gonna serve like
a whole lot of like because once i've
read that and they said as soon as the
bill they're gonna drop all those gaming
game pass something about all the
activision games i don't got and i'm
like
i didn't buy vanguard this year because
i i wanted to do the campaign but i just
wasn't willing to pay 70 to do that
campaign now i'm guaranteed to get that
thing in game pass sometime soon with
crash for like i'm i'm i'm happy because
now game pass my game passes
subscription it's just just went up in
crazy
crazy value now i don't mind playing
call of duty
for the because my only thing with call
of duty is that i suck at call of duty
i when i buy it like i've been got off
the multiplayer being wagon i'll play
the campaign
and and that and that's it like reason
why i got the last game last year is
because i got a review code so i was
able to play it and enjoy what not this
year no review code i know by halos
priorities
priorities
but i am still very much interested in
the campaign like i know i'm not going
to touch the multiplayer but i am
straight in the campaign and the fact
that all these ip you start thinking
about the ips that are dead that they
want to bring back you got guitar hero
you got oh i know they fought back
spiral and they're gonna do some new
games crash and then i'm thinking about
all these quality studios that's been
stuck making calls
that can now go back to like making
games you know they're gonna do this i
know i was like yo after this call of
duty don't need to be annual anymore it
does not need to be annual anymore and
so like i'll just give you what i i hope
i hope like yeah sure you keep infinity
war and treyarch
oncology make those things buy in you or
whatever put raven on whatever it they
want to do um
and as far as exclusives go um
yeah places you can you can hold on to
that war zone or whatever zombie mode
they drop but
the man
the mainline games but i don't i i'm
treating it like how they did with the
whole cinemax deal i don't like it does
it's like the the language is too vague
and we have a clear example when
everybody thought oh the cinemax deal
was too big to keep all those games
and now i'm like yo like
i'm i'm excited as the xbox man i'm i'm
really really um excited to have him and
see that they're like they're fighting
and then it doesn't
and i think this is one thing i want to
say a lot of people
and you guys mentioned it earlier about
monopolies and stuff like that this is
so far from a monopoly when you consider
how many publishers out there and then
how much more aggressive publisher
buyouts there has been between embracer
group tencent who who some of these
aren't even american companies who the
u.s government is going to want
microsoft to compete that's the point
the usa versus china aspect i don't even
think about that yeah so that that is a
thing to consider and so it's not and
then when you do consider
when microsoft acquires a publisher or
developer their games are still very
much accessible by multiple platforms
when you consider
console when you consider pc when you
consider multiple storefronts on pc i
mean now you consider cloud and then
eventually you gotta consider the tv so
you take that versus let's say a
nintendo or playstation making that same
acquisition there's more people locked
out at that point versus if xbox does it
you're still very much if even if you
play on playstation you still have means
to get access to those games right on
one of your devices at home so um but
yeah man it was just pure excitement i
just wanted to share my pieces thanks
for having me salute brothers we had to
get you man you've been rocking
bro we've been rapping
driving the car to pack ease you know
you're going to pack ease with us
we'll talk about that offline
i want to i want to move forward because
again hustle i got you but i want to get
pd next and also say that and hustle if
you don't mind if i include you in the
next cause you kind of a pc master race
god i thought you would fit perfect are
you okay with that as well i'm cool with
that all right appreciate you brother
appreciate you both because it's a big
show it's crazy today all right look
let's get into it so we we talked about
obviously the initial reaction you know
we talked about that but there's other
aspects to this deal right and we're
talking about the pc side you know we
kind of alleviated that let me mention
that kind of early hinted so there's
blizzard aspect all their ips a lot of
that stuff you know resides on pc are
kind of bigger in the pc space obviously
king with the mobile side but i want to
bring in two lords right we talked about
how we got lost now though dot tv one of
the original og lords man pc master race
proud
lord petey so look petey man i want you
to give us your perspective because you
primarily game on pc you know you are a
huge wow fan you stream wow you know
plug the channel by the way
and um you know what i'm saying so like
your perspective is very important to me
like what's the pc community feel what's
the wow community and then also i
believe battle net right we got to talk
about that so give me your perspective
on that yeah uh i'll do i'll try to do
this as uh as quick as possible because
i know you guys are super busy i know
ricky and chase are sitting here
patiently you know put their bars in two
so um
so i'll do this as quick as possible
we'll talk about battlenet first this is
probably the easiest thing to talk about
um
battlenet is the in-game launcher that
uh blizzard had put into effect before
activision actually bought them uh and
then when that's activision actually
bought them then um you know the now the
uh you know the battle
battle net launcher um and now it
includes all the activation games in
addition to all the blizzard games
now um
for all the launchers that i've actually
had to really deal with this is probably
one of the best deployment launchers for
any game that i've actually really had
to deal with um steam probably being the
next and everyone knows that steam
really isn't that great um but the
really interesting part is that when it
comes to this balance launcher it also
has a communication aspect so that you
also have the ability to communicate
with other people's in other games for
instance if i'm chilling playing
warcraft doing my thing addicts over
there and uh in diablo playing his game
over there oh we're going to say
overwatch
so you're over in overwatch i can
actually message him and go yo how long
do you got until you're done with that
game you know um i need you need some
help on this thing or you can message me
and be like yo these guys are kicking my
ass uh can you come over here and help
me you know
so um hey that's my line
[Laughter]
so like it really has this amazing
communication aspect which is really
really nice for the the pc space and i
think that
with the ability the ability that
microsoft has with their communication
uh voice communication portion it could
really enhance that and make that better
which i really feel that the battle
launcher and the blizzard
uh or activision blizzard um you know
community does not have this
verbal communication across games uh
whereas um
xbox live has so i think that that's
gonna be really really interesting to
see how they're gonna communicate in
bonds and also the deployment of the
games on how they can end up doing that
because when there's a game that goes
you know um
goes live in a game let's say
um the expansion for world of warcraft
is coming out on thursday you know it is
like
two weeks before on tuesday i log in and
it already starts downloading everything
getting it ready for that launch date so
it can fluidly go into the next
expansion and i don't have to worry
about you know any of that stuff so i
think that they do a lot of that stuff
correctly and right that i think that
microsoft can can very much take and uh
enhance a lot of their games uh for
instance like if
um halo infinite is going to start
dropping new maps you know you're not
even going to realize that but they're
going to drop your maps like three weeks
before and then you're going to be like
all of a sudden on on tuesday or
whatever your game is going to pop
you'll be like oh there's like four more
maps so i think that that's going to be
really really cool for them
as for
the
uh warcraft community um uh
i mean i've done a little bit of
communicating with my guilds and stuff
like that because we very much are
very progressive on the knowledge of
what's going on um and i would like to
say that these opinions are mine not
theirs fully but um
they
the thing with blizzard um
first of all mikey borrows you know
headed and lead in that thing which is
like
such a positive because
we all want bobby out of there like
nobody's business because that guy i'm
gonna keep it you know pc and just say
that guy just gotta go
um but
for
the wow community
we think that this is going to have some
good things that are going to happen and
possibly some bad things
because we don't know where microsoft is
going to sit
um
kind of like how call of duty has their
forced time frames of new call of duty's
warcraft has those same
um
you know criteria they need to make a
new expansion uh every like two and a
half years and
we've noticed over the past couple of
years there's been a decrease in the
player base
um
that the the game like the players will
play for a month or two and then it'll
just drop and it's because
they don't have the
the wants or the the
the feeling that they want to continue
to play in it
so
we're hoping that this gives them a
little bit of ability to free themselves
up because prior to activision's uh
merger they were able to make games
where they felt fully
um you know strong like they would
launch on on the expansion would launch
we would start playing and it would feel
great we'd be like all right this is
great there was not really
any bugs the um the the raids and
dungeons were fluid and there was great
things about them
but
ever since activision took over
there has been this drop after every two
or three months after expansion
so
with microsoft coming into play
we're hoping that it ends up fixing that
so that we don't have that huge
player-based drop-off where because now
we have like the pretty much the people
that are playing are the hardcore that
are the ones that really enjoy the game
and can play over and over again
but
we want like our friend a lot of our
other friends are playing other games so
we kind of missed that but that's one of
those things that we're kind of hoping
that that changes it will be but i know
how to get
the player count up throw that joint
game pass and let me get my fingers
that's the other question what are they
gonna do because we are right now
subscription based right so would you
tell me am i allowed to go on game pass
which is also subscription based and
then bypassing so is the track is the
trepidation what the the game pass
potential rolling or separate separation
of subscription is that okay
subscription now i got you at it go at
it go real quick
i think
they're going to merge
wow with game pass because to me
what you have more odds of someone
leaving while because they're just bored
with the game at that time until
something bigger happens
or keeping people wow
keep people like you know you you take a
break from from wow you go to game pass
you play that so you constantly keep
them in that ecosystem instead of
unsubbing until like the next expansion
happens or something
how about they just roll it in there and
if you don't have game pass you got to
pay that subscription how much you have
anybody
don't they give you the bare bones joint
um for free to to get you hooked and
then once you get hooked then they uh
hit you with after 50 level 50 then you
have to the opponent it's like after
level 20 and you have to yeah yeah so
15 above okay yeah okay
that's that thing is going to go inside
game 15. everybody's saying if you want
to get it outside of game pass you're
just gonna have to get knocked in ahead
for that 15 bucks keep in mind to
activision has been uh blizzard has been
having that's the people who make wild
blizzard right yeah they they've been
having that candy took away from them
ever since final fantasy 14 took off so
well
the reason why that we had the final
fantasy takeoff is and it's actually
something that we've spoken about was
because of the huge dip
because you have
this portion of this expansion where it
came to be that everyone was just
killing killing killing doing everything
they wanted and then it was just like
boom we have nothing we're like what are
we gonna do when's the next expansion
coming out when's the next patch coming
out and they're like hey the next the
next expansion is uh the next patch i
should say isn't coming out for another
eight months what are you gonna do right
so people are like
well i guess i'll play final fantasy 14
right and then they're realizing that
and a lot of those larger guilds and
communities are now going to be playing
you know
both games because they realize that
they have these dips in times where they
don't need anything which is great for
final fantasy 14 because the game is
fantastic i played it i love it and the
same thing with wow is that it's this
great game i love it but they have these
times and dips of like no content
content
so
maybe
with some with some luck they'll
actually figure out a way how to make
sure this content is
you know improved and continuous so some
forms of dlc
last question before i move move on from
your pd it's um
overall so is it is it cautious optimism
is is it skepticism is it or is it
negative like what what's the if you
have to put your finger on the pulse of
the wow community
what are they what's the overall the
majority field
the overall majority they feel that this
is a positive thing okay and and the
reason why this is positive is because
a lot of the developers are going to be
able to have a little bit more of their
freedom back
and like boom was saying before with the
whole thing with the with the hr and
stuff like that um i think that was
another huge issue
and that's the other reason why
diablo floor
diablo 4 and overwatch 2 keep getting
delayed because of all of these
underlying issues that are not discussed
and talked about right um and
i think that once that stuff gets
cleared up blizzard can be free again
to be able to do the things that are
great
they're great at diablo they're great at
overwatch they're great at warcraft you
know they're great greatest starcraft
they even said that they're no longer
making starcraft anymore
and now this gives them a light because
the starcraft story is so good the
campaign is amazing
but to have just killed it the way they
killed it
it's just it pains me to sit there and
be
uh um
i wouldn't even say i'm like a blizzard
fanboy but they make such good games
it's just gonna be like oh
it's just so crazy i feel you brother
okay okay it's off and i gotta call it
just real quick just real quick on the
consolidation thing of
of the battle net thing because i think
to me that's the most interesting part
about this um
i don't think when we start talking
about we're going to start talking about
the the monopoly stuff and whatever but
but
we have to be careful with the battle
net thing the obvious thing is to say
hey we just consolidated everything in
game pass and everything using xbox live
servers or whatever azure whatever and
that's it
the problem there is they're not sure
how they're going to be attacked when it
comes to this but this antitrust kind of
discussion right they're not they have
no idea how they're going to be attacked
right i looking at everything on the
surface it doesn't seem like anybody
there's no real argument when it comes
to the consolidation of companies
because of the stuff that kiss movements
and whatever like they're still the
third the third highest in revenue above
you know beyond tencent and sony when
you look at other independent publishers
i don't think that's a real argument
that they're gonna lose right
where they have to be careful is the
consolidation of online communities
if
the government starts looking at them as
an entity that is trying to eliminate
the the the ways in which people access
their games online and just kind of
consolidate it all into xbox and azure
or whatever
that could be a problem for them so for
me it's something that they really have
to so when we say hey just put an xbox
live
that's the obvious answer i think it's
more nuanced than that okay it's going
to be interesting to see what happens
because and on top of that
there's a lot of stuff the battle that
does super well that they would be it
would be in their best interest to try
to integrate in some way shape or form i
actually feel like they're going to take
everything to battle now like that's my
personal opinion that's it that's that's
what i think they're going to do that
makes sense
just going to throw it into the battle
system not fair enough man
like i see i see uh my boy 3mg and i
gotta get hustle and i got to bring
somebody in as well but you guys gotta
get your balls off quickly because we
we're getting the the next segment soon
so please yes no no
yeah thank you guys for letting up yeah
do your thing but thank you for
everybody
let people know where they could find
you
yeah uh
snaldo on twitch every monday to friday
uh youtube also how do you spell that
though how do you spell it
everyone's uh
l-y-d-o um you go ahead and do that you
can find me on twitter also or if you
look at me for twitter you know it's
peter over there
streaming that wow
yeah mostly mostly wow and you know
other games that uh i do for the channel
for reviews and stuff like that so and a
function you couldn't pay me to get on
wild man yeah
only thing i want to say before i i go
here is at least
talking about at least the monopolies um
that is a very good point that that may
be the one point they actually shoot for
because based on all the other
categories i can't see them stopping it
they may bring it up or talk about it
because it they're basically saying hey
with this merger you're going to be
third and no one cares about third
right so
that would be a thing there but
the one thing i want to leave on is
of all the people that could have done
this acquisition microsoft was the best
choice
i'm happy because
if anyone else did it
there will be problems like if because
we know ea was in talks to do it at one
point
and
if ea got call of duty
i could just imagine that medal of honor
that would turn out
they came
that happened
if we know that you know activision was
kind of waiting for sony to say
something about it and
look
if sony had bought activision
one thank god because it would have got
crash bandicoot spyro back and hopefully
they'd do something with it
but the
we wouldn't be having this discussion
about oh is this going to be available
on this platform anymore
because you know for a fact they would
make sure xbox would not have call of
duty anymore mm-hmm
no they would allow you interesting
interesting
and i just it's one of those things i
worry about but no doubt brother yeah
but microsoft is looked at as the bad
dude yeah y'all funny now i appreciate
you you you rolling all you got okay
brother tell the people wait hold on
hold on tell people where they can find
you what you got going on let's let's
let's plug with these people let them
know who you are
all right well i got my old twitter
account back after defeating twitter
after 10 months of being in twitter jail
so wow um so you can find me at
anchorman v2 across all platforms now
so
now finally back to normal there um you
guys we're we're starting up cheat code
radio chico we're gonna be in february
um we're doing uh we're flipping back
and forth between recorded shows and
live shows depending on the week uh
whether you're gonna do a live show on
thursday nights or you'll get the
recording on friday morning so nice nice
either one there we go put the late we
gotta bless my man salute lord inca man
the legendary og always been in our car
from
the shadow broker we call him
affectionately i'm gonna put his twitter
account in there so you can find all his
information the updated twitter account
which he fought
for tooth and nail to get back there it
is i wouldn't have never reported him if
i knew this would have happened
no no no no we got more royalty pulling
up i see but i gotta get hustle he's
been so patient hustle on the pc side
hustling motivation what are you
thinking man how are you feeling
i'm kind of glad that you know they have
blizzard now and they can use their
online service because as you all know
game pass on pc right now is is garbage
it's garbage um
if you go to my youtube channel you saw
the last time i tried to stream gears of
war and that joint kept crashing on me
so any any improvement
is a real good improvement um
i just want to give like quick thoughts
and reactions sure please i hit attic up
i hate addict up and i dm them i say son
i said blizzard yeah that's all he said
that's all he said you said i'm so
we got to talk blind when i saw that it
like it was just like i got it i still
can't believe it yeah i still can't
believe it and solve shout out to you
because
man i thought you was just reaching out
the sky though
what i'm gonna need
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'll be honest with you my only concern
with that acquisition
is you know microsoft they really they
were the first ones who tried to push
things like strictly digital y'all
remember back in 2013 xbox one i don't
know if y'all mentioned it something in
and out but they were the first ones to
do that and y'all know all of these
if you can see what they are i'm a
physical cat so
good point
i'm a physical dude so i'm more worried
about that um that's a good concern no
it's just stop it kid
stop it with the pauses he'd want to say
he physical
stop it but no no that's that's a i
don't want to minimize what hustle just
said like that is a valid concern for
physical media we have i know we people
got pompoms out but that is that is true
so continue on your point also yeah
cause we talk about game preservation
maybe not ten years from now maybe not
twenty years from now maybe thirty years
from now when you know we raising
uh possibly our grandchildren at that
point like hey you check out what uh
check out what uncle
hooked up to some type of new machine
trying to get new legs
continuously i'm gonna be 11 kicking
look uh all i'm saying is i'm more
concerned about
that that aspect of it but now this is a
super good deal and i'm not sure if you
guys mentioned it but activision with
the microsoft which is the biggest story
for me i heard finding duke a little
earlier this week and when i think
maddie might have been you know yeah
well maddie pulled it from um games beat
and uh shout out to lord jeff grubbs his
article you know so that was that source
so for people that did ask
my man knocked on the door was like yo
help me he said help me he said pleased
by this because like he knew because uh
uh body cod knew first of all he knew he
was getting fired and he knew the stock
you know the company was losing like
it's one of those situations the way
like he'll become even more rich and
probably won't nothing happen to him
either and i don't want to get off the
go no the golden parachute situation is
real right
it's valid
yeah yeah he's he's still going to come
up but no this is this is a really good
acquisition man um is this going to be
exclusive is all the stuff going to be
exclusive to microsoft uh let's just put
it this way if but but that's the stuff
from the cinemax still all the future
games are going to be exclusive then you
better believe all this stuff gonna be
exclusive though like you you might get
like the multiplayer stuff that's segue
i get like good segue
well look at me kyle good segue brother
cause we got we have some heavy hitters
that have arrived
in the realm and i hate to cut you also
because i i it's so
cut for time right now and um first
let's start off with the legendary lord
of legality virtual's own virtual
illegals
the mind that everyone goes to let's
just say
for everything illegal let's start off
with hogan law of the hogan business
firm law firm how are you doing sir
i'm doing okay is is my mic working i
didn't i even get to check that you're
getting invested in this conversation
you are good and then second up someone
who is uh very explosive on twitter
lately for some
but the legendary california ceo of last
damn media and uh co-founder of lily mo
games how are you doing sir
good man good to be here thanks for
having me good you guys are well oh
we're doing well we're doing good to
have you here because we want balance we
want the legal perspective but we want
balance also with other perspectives
can't just be all pom-poms sunshine's
and rainbows so let's call it what's
funny this whole show i've seen people
say are they gonna talk about college
response college just particularly you
bring that up
exactly so let's respond let's let's
let's give hogg his flowers first so
let's start with the first issue and
affectionately we call it the desire
section
so the desire for cod on playstation so
obviously the um you know phil mentioned
initially in the press statement that he
didn't give details of microsoft plans
active activision blizzard games are
enjoyed on a variety of platforms we
plan to continue to support these
communities moving forward then that led
to the original i believe the wall
street journal's article in tokyo and it
said sony group corp said that thursday
that they expected microsoft corp to
ensure that games from activision
blizzard are available on
non-microsoft video game platforms if
microsoft completes its proposed
acquisition acquisition of activision we
expect that microsoft will abide by
contractual agreements and continue to
ensure activision games are
multi-platform sony spokesman said then
we got the statement from phil and
that's the one that came the day after
it pretty much looks like many content
creators gonna be analyzing this
statement for about 18 months depending
on when this deal finalizes that phil
says and i quote had good calls this
week with the leaders at sony it
confirmed our intent to honor all
existing agreements upon acquisition of
activision blizzard and our desire
to keep call of duty on playstation sony
is an important part of our industry and
we value our relationship so lord hold
man you got an amazing video up on your
youtube channel discussing this right
now you know now that you've had time to
kind of parse and even digest it even
further you know what do you take from
these series of events and that
statement
i'm sorry really quick yes um
guys in the chat mm-hmm let's behave
yeah let's be honest get out of if you
get out of line yeah
yeah and i know y'all see colin in here
he is welcome
exactly exactly so let's get it hulk
let's start up man what you feel about
these statements twitter is breaking
this statement down a thousand times
yeah well i mean my first feeling is
obviously the entire internet is more
cynical than a corporate transactions
layer
right uh so i i saw this tweet go out
there and i immediately did a video
because i think it's an important step
for microsoft and phil spencer
to go out there with a very specific
very positive statement that says he
wants to see call of duty on playstation
in the future and i think the the vacuum
the framework that this all takes place
in is important to understand there's
there's two or three things happening
here one of which is that this
acquisition which all been talking about
for a while now
isn't done
that these things are not finished
activision is not owned by xbox or
microsoft as of today there's a number
of hoops to jump through one of which is
government regulatory approval
and one of the things that everybody
should read into every microsoft
communication for now into the
foreseeable future is that they want to
look like good guys they are the white
nightiest of white knights
to alleviate a problematic situation and
a publisher that's getting sued by every
agency under the sun and microsoft and
phil they just want people to have fun
they just want people to play games
and so they have a desire
to see call
the biggest game on earth appear on the
sony playstation infrastructure of
course they do they are playstation fans
and so
there are a number of statements that
phil has made that xbox has made it not
just about call of duty that can all be
put into the bucket of hey ftc hey eu we
know you're watching and we want you to
know we're not going to over consolidate
we're keeping everybody in charge here
there's another statement that phil made
that said i'm not even worried about
nintendo and sony right we're all on the
game boat we're all rolling down gaining
lane who i'm worried about
you should be worried about ftc who the
politicians should be worried about and
that's of course jeff bezos nobody likes
amazon
[Music]
when you're evaluating this transaction
don't limit it just to evaluating
whether it's about cloud services cloud
infrastructure sure we got a lot of that
maybe we're the only major game
subscription service of our type don't
worry about that ftc what you need to
worry about is those big tech giants i
think every republican and every
democrat can agree
big tech sucks am i right don't think of
microsoft that way
so we have a desire to put call of duty
on the playstation and i looked at that
very positively i'm an optimistic guy i
said you don't have to go out with that
statement right now in this fashion you
can be more neutral than that in fact we
saw phil spencer essentially trip all
over himself saying what much more vague
things when the zenimax deal went
through
so this is closer to something that
people should take positively but
understand
he can't sign checks for sony you can't
make contracts in the future so desire
is important there he can't make a
promise because he doesn't know what
agreement will be entered into and yes
you can better believe that xbox is
going to use its 70 billion purchase to
try to talk about terms
we understand that your people want call
of duty on there we're open to it we
like money you like money what if that
30 percent cut were 10
hey what if it yeah
game pass included instead and so those
conversations will undoubtedly happen
they could fall apart in the future but
i think the people that are parsing it
more closely than that suggesting that
xbox is just putting up a smoke screen
are wrong because the one thing that
would happen here in a regulatory
environment is that if he spun around
and went backwards shortly after the
closing or something along those lines
is that you do get a letter from the ftc
yes
an agency looking at facebook and
whatsapp and instagram and saying you
know what
we know we allowed this deal a decade
ago right but we're not cool with it
anymore and that can create problems
down the line so everything he says take
with a grain of salt because it's in a
regulated environment but also when
there's anything that sounds like a
remote commitment do assume that there
is a political price to be paid for
walking back that even if the strict
legalese here doesn't bind him in any
capacity there are optics in politics at
play
so i'm an optimist i look at that and
say i for the first time since that
tweet went out think that call of duty
including its annual or non-annual
however it winds up in the future
iterations are going to wind up on the
sony ecosystem why
because a multi-player action game
that's premised on microtransactions and
engagement makes a hell of a lot more
sense than a single-player role-playing
game and it affords microsoft and xbox
the ability to test their own data and
analytics as to whether or not the
zenimax deal is driving people to game
pass whether it makes more sense to sell
70 or god forbid a hundred dollar
versions of a game that they otherwise
make available on game pass on their
competing system and you're gonna get a
lot of information which is of value in
and of itself so i look at it very
positively i think an optimist can look
at it and say i think call of duty is
going to live on playstation
but those two crazy kids do have to sign
a contract eventually and yeah
i got one question for you all before i
uh pass it to colin i was a patient um
in reference to those who say right yes
like this the language could be taken
either way right and for those who say
you know what
i think it's definitely going to be
multi-plat right based on that language
and i understand what you're saying in
reference to look there's regulatory
bodies everyone's watching you now's not
the time but i guess my question you
hulk is what's
the disadvantage of saying
right now if truly the intention is for
it to be multiple what is the
disadvantage of publicly saying you know
what instead of saying i desire saying
hey we definitively plan on keeping
these games on playstation and multiply
what's the discipline break that down
you can't make a promise to that user
base like so playstation fans and xbox
fans are ostensibly distinct but they're
also not we're all gaming industry fans
right so phil spencer can't go out just
from a political perspective and i mean
politics as in actually talking to
people not just you know republicans and
democrats here just from that
perspective say we plan on we will
promise it will be on playstation
because you don't control that deal and
if you make that kind of statement you
lose the leverage in those negotiations
so if you promised that to sony fans and
now they have a certain feeling about
you and your reputation and your
goodwill sony sits back at their table
and says well phil
seems like you put yourself in a bit of
a pickle
things to some people
let's talk terms
and now that becomes a different
leverage play so phil says look
plan is to keep gaming and what what's
the phrase they use the joy of gaming in
the hands of as many people as possible
if we have to make a lot of money on
that well he's bob ross
bill shouldn't make that promise if the
lawyers of the pr people were vetting
that kind of tweet and it was a big
tweet so you can bet that they were then
they're saying okay here's the line you
walk up to you say we have a desire to
do it a lot of things can happen between
now and then people can read into it we
need to get views for iron lords
and then that tweet goes out the door
hey hey hogue yeah um
with desire that word right because i i
mean it's a good word
that's a nice word
do y'all guys remember you know you
desired a lot of things in life until
you didn't
you know um there could be a desire
until it's not
so i just it's just not working
all right guarantee at all and his
desire i'm sure premised on something
that is uh you know untowards from sony
it could be an indecent proposal
you don't know what that looks like but
we do know that there's a commitment out
socially in the public now yeah and so
there isn't a certain expectation of
most people that aren't reading it and
parsing it like a lot of folks on social
media that says in the back of my head
sounds like xbox wants call of duty on
playstation if that doesn't happen where
do i ascribe blame and that might be on
xbox as well in terms of goodwill and
reputation so there was a step forward
in that tweet people should not
undersell that fair enough now i want to
combine this again because i have to
respect lord collins time yeah you gotta
bring colin on i could talk for 40
minutes i love it no bro you're on fire
you're on fight thank you so much for
that insight um i want to be fair in the
realm here one thing about iop we strive
to be fair and probably the most vocal
opposing
uh tweet i would say of our opinion on
twitter as far as the acquisition i
would say as far as the health of the
industry what's good for the industry
was lord colin i want to read his tweet
um in reference to that so he said in
purchasing activision microsoft
microsoft has undoubtedly set off a new
round of mergers and acquisitions that
will coalesce entities it's bad for
creativity bad for devs and bad for
players three and a half uh our sacred
symbols awaits uh again salute to the
patreon success out here killing it sir
so thank you salute to that and of
course the law defining duke stand up
respect but um let's get into that man
and i want to get into that aspect that
we uh about your initial feeling and
then also you know on sacred symbols you
had some comments in reference to you
know your concern for sony right and and
making this an arms race and and them
feeling the need to have to respond in a
way that you don't necessarily agree
with so let's let's get your thoughts on
this whole thing man sure uh thanks for
having me um so
my concern about this first of all i
called myself neo i kept calling myself
neo on the show and matrix reference
because
the bullets that are coming out as far
as the acquisitions of sony or the
acquisitions microsoft are making are
not affecting me yes because i don't
really play activision games i don't
really play bethesda games i actually
went and looked at what the last
activision games uh i played were and it
was uh modern warfare remastered i
believe was the last one and it was
great but you know if you go and get
them square enix and all the indie [ __ ]
all the weird stuff i like and that
would hurt me a lot more so from a
myopic standpoint i'm like okay like it
is what it is it could have been way
worse for me as a player a playstation
gamer but
what i've started to see were a couple
of things
first of all this real corporate
celebratory stuff going on that i don't
understand at all and anyone who listens
to sacred symbols knows that i don't
yeah we don't celebrate sony on sacred
symbols anyone who acts like we do is
lying uh because it's the exact opposite
of what we do we hold them to the fire
more than anything that's part of what
we feel is
uh part of what we do even though we
love the brand and we love the games we
try to hold them to account as a
corporation
and
i saw this corporate warship going on
with microsoft with a company that three
or four days ago everyone hated now
suddenly everyone loves them again this
this company that had this complete
malignancy going through all of its
developers and all of its marketing
teams and in-house and all of this
suddenly everyone loves them and i think
from a playstation point of view my
biggest
concern or the biggest thing that i took
away from is that i'm surprised by how
few people understand how playstation
built their first party
and there are just no comparisons to
what playstation does what nintendo does
which is much more like playstation and
what microsoft has done since the very
beginning and to that
i say it makes the brand seem a little
hollow to me and it's hard for me to
celebrate just the sheer acquisition of
assets as opposed to the more deliberate
nature of building a team and that's
what sony has done and the reason that
i'm afraid of that is because i feel
like this can put them in a position
where they feel like they need to play
with the big boys as it were and i don't
want them to do that i don't want sony
to buy anything that doesn't make sense
i certainly don't want sony to buy
square enix i certainly don't want them
to buy capcom or konami or any of these
companies that are being banned around i
think that would be awful be awful for
the industry it'd be awful for player
choice it would be awful for sony's
first party
because they have a
they have a feel they have a culture a
very high quality culture that they've
built brick by brick
and i challenge anyone to tell me
any acquisition sony has ever made that
is like that but that's their activision
deal the answer is that they haven't in
fact sony has acquired all their teams
for what is probably less than a billion
dollars yeah
and that's that's so that's a a big
difference and that's the only thing
i'll say about you know right so those
are the things that come to mind sorry
i'm rambling no no no you're good
you have a great opinion of it um and as
a
corporate worshiper um
i'm i'm i'm gonna step into this boot
right so um yeah i held microsoft to the
fire when i felt what they were doing
was absolutely horrible right but again
at the same time um
no people was praising sony just a
couple of weeks ago when uh the news
came out that they would be purchasing
uh uh or in talks to make sure that the
xbox ecosystem doesn't get a main line
final fantasy
me as an xbox player and a sony uh
playstation owner
i i used them for exclusives right um
then that means that that fine because
i'm still waiting for that final fantasy
remake to make its way to
the ecosystem that i enjoy
hasn't made it there yet for whatever
reasons right um at the same time are
they looked at as the good guys so when
they do their practices and they
get timed exclusive and you gotta move
in this corporate business the way you
can yes sony has changed from the brick
by brick like you said in the past and
and it kind of changed and i think the
times dictate that
microsoft isn't afforded the same amount
of time that sony is afforded so what
you do is you acquire a ton of assets
you have a ton of stuff that you can put
out but at the same time you build
you start to build that quality they
weren't afforded the same amount of time
as sony but they do have cash
and they are passionate in this space so
as a a corporate worshiper
i like this space that microsoft is in
and i like the the ips that they have i
like the uh
the feel with certain games i'm happy in
this space and i didn't want it to go
away so when it was threatened not too
long ago in actually going away
i i kind of felt threatened in my gaming
space as for me so now the fact that
they turn that part around and it seems
like they're going to be around for the
duration that's where you get my elation
from oh sorry i wanted to add sony i'm
sorry back to sony part hold on back to
sony's part
yeah it's it's been eight years of beat
down colin let's be real
right eight years of watching
quality titles being produced by uh sony
platforms and hoping that same quality
can be produced over here so it's hope
that you were seeing that these quality
titles will finally start to manifest
their self and we started to see
fruits of that labor in certain quality
titles that were released this year
i understand that you want it
traditionally and you feel that
acquisitions in its sense will uh
destroy
our fabric of gaming in a sense
i don't think so um but i i also like i
said am
a fan of this ecosystem i do want the
playstation brand games
to be in this ecosystem i do champion
them making the transition over to a
full developer
that's my opinion of it but i understand
what you're talking about and i'm just
giving you the aspect of me probably
tweeting so hard talking about microsoft
is moving
i should by the way i i just want to say
real quick i know as far as the i don't
really see anything on twitter because i
just post out my videos
i stopped posting personally in the fall
so i know people are mad there but i
don't really see it
we just put out the content and then
kind of let it sit but yeah i just
wanted to say that so i i don't really
quite know how upset everyone is oh
they're furious
right there that might be an
understatement
i'm like no no we one thing we love to
do here is we love to have opposing
views and we can do it respectfully and
have great discussion and break
engagement but i wanted to ask you was
um okay so in reference to that you know
about the creativity i guess my question
that i've seen on twitter and some of
the pushback has been
the alternative especially with a
company a publishing arm which has been
kind of going through the turmoil that
they've been going through internally
activision blizzard where you're seeing
people again initial reports again not
all we can say but initial reports are
saying hey
we are happy that we may not have to
annualize something like call of duty we
are happy that you know whether it be
treyarch infinity water whoever
sledgehammer that trifecta that produces
these games consistently over and over
and maybe not allowed to work on their
own titles that they had prior to this
model that call of duty seemed to be
pushing for this annual revenue it must
come out and we're starting to see some
of that and then the second part in
reference to obviously that we're also
hearing about okay
the bigger players
right and you start hearing about okay
well
if microsoft wasn't to get it
would we be comfortable with an apple or
a 10 cent or embrace a group or any
other thing so i guess my question to
you colin is for for that group you know
what do you say as far as microsoft's
acquisition of it be of activision being
a better alternative
it is a better alternative we you and i
had said on the finding duke ultimate i
had said it was ironically before this
all happened where i was like i'd much
rather microsoft consolidate then tends
it did um
and
i think it's you know at microsoft as a
company is very interesting i use
microsoft products i have no problem
with microsoft but it's important to
bring up embracer because i actually
think microsoft and embracer are pretty
similar in which they just buy assets
and then they worry about them later
there doesn't seem to be much of a
strategy to it they just seem to get
things and then they'll figure it out
and they're big enough they can model
and do all those things and get it all
to work later
but that's my whole point is that it's
that's fine for money and capitalism is
the pursuit of it but from a creative
standpoint i don't really have any
respect you know for that
mantra as opposed to like you know
especially the very steady work nintendo
has done right for a really long time
but we were talking earlier about third
like third-party game third-party
exclusives and
sony's always done third-party
exclusives right
it's the it's when you get into the
second party exclusives that sony starts
to deliberately try to acquire
time date sometimes calling honestly no
of course no they but they've always
done this i'm saying when you look at
the business the least risky financial
move is to do a third party exclusive
yes and ironically i would say also that
the industry was getting away from those
until microsoft was the one that revived
it with titanfall
and others yeah roger the tomb raider
actually wasn't doing that sonia was
doing more second party exclusives so
that's the whole thing is it's just that
if people want to call apples and
oranges apples and oranges that's fine
but
i just like the more deliberate nature
of acquiring teams that make sense
because it keeps the first party
whatever first party you're talking
about somehow coherent you know when
sony founded polyphony with the old
remnants of polly's digital they're like
we need a racing team that makes sense
for us we'll do that we've already made
gran turismo together we did that before
we owned you now we're gonna acquire you
and one in the next step and that kind
of thing has happened over and over
again and so my fear as a fan of
playstation first party is simply that
they will feel like they need to play
a bigger thing and i don't want that for
anyone i would really hate i really
it would be awful to wake up and for
square enix to be under sony i would
[ __ ] i would think that that would be
and you've been consistent with that you
i had let's give you your flowers you
have been i hate to interrupt you i'm
sorry i'm in the place but i want to be
consistent that
the reason why i respect an opposing
opinion like yours on this is because
you have been consistent unlike some
that even on the sony side you don't
want that for the industry because some
people again we would talk about that
arms race right and people like well you
know i got all the toy and you've been
like no i don't want sony to do that
that that's your fear continue i'm sorry
i just wanted to get clear with that
because that suggests that there is a
finite amount of resources but there
isn't
sony to their credit i i made fun of
them for doing this earlier in the year
they've done it multiple times or 2021
is that now they're setting seeds with
new second parties right like um
firewalk and all these different teams
the the uh jade raymond team where
they're gonna own the ip they are
funding the team they don't own the team
so you can see that they're setting the
seeds of new sucker punch new whatever
and just the same exact way that they
used to do it but no because
acquisitions while seemingly inevitable
suggest that the resources are finite
and
i would rather that money just go into
new things
and that's the other thing because
people are like sony would take this
away and sony would take that away and
there's no doubt third-party exclusives
certainly the second party exclusives of
the ips they own
but i would argue that when they make an
acquisition they're acquiring a team
that doesn't do anything for anyone else
anyway or hasn't for a really long time
right so it almost seems like the most
net neutral acquisitions as well for
instance insomniac made 15 games for
playstation before they were acquired 15
including 12 in a row
right so and when they left sony and
tried to do other things they found that
they couldn't find the same success
so that seems to me like a very natural
acquisition and people might look at it
differently but
i see an acquisition like oh we get
gorilla well gorilla made killzone then
we bought them right you know from
sony's and no one can tell you what
gorilla made before that no one
the game is shell shock and no one
played it right the point is is that
they nothing was taken away there wasn't
even the specter of that so the third
party exclusive is interesting i think
the square enix deals are interesting
that they're building but i would have
expected to see final fantasy 7 on xbox
already i think that's really
disappointing that that has happened and
my hope and prayer is that if sony
responds they continue to say listen
let's found 10 new teams right and do 10
new ip that is always going to be my
preference over them saying [ __ ] it
let's just grab konami right let's just
grab them
i don't want language language
too far a quick question because i try
to maximize colin's time all right so
the first thing is in reference to you
know the whole consolidation emergency
acquisition but like from a standpoint
of
what do you say to say hey like
a lot of you call them but like this is
where the industry is going right yeah
like like for i'll use the sports
analogy which is like you know
i come from the era where michael jordan
in my opinion is the goat right
so when i look at nba this generation
this series i'll be like i know king
don't get mad at me but lebron you know
i look at him with less respect i look
at his championships as hollow because
i'm like you teamed up
with dwyane wade you teamed up you know
what i'm saying with kyrie
so it's like i kind of as an old head
right because i'm like yo it was defense
it was real defense it was hand checking
it was the eastern conference knicks
like it was real you guys are teaming up
and doing it the easy way right
is it
could you think that there's a part of
you that maybe just hold it on to the
older way of doing things when it was
you know you nurture studio its culture
is in house as opposed to the
acquisition where maybe this was where
the the industry is going do you think
that plant that seed there in your head
a little bit no definitely man we all
come from the same place where
where i think things were smaller and we
come from the pre cool video games era
and it's and it's fun to hold on to
those days there's no doubt i want to
hold on to that that's why i'm trying to
remove the myopia of my own point of
view because the way i interact with
games for instance i don't think i'm
going to be interested even in spartacus
unless they do day one games because i
just don't interact with games like that
like i love
people go look at my trophies like i
like playing one game at a time get
really into it do whatever i can and i
move on to the next game and it's funny
i uh i played halo combat evolved um
last week for knockback we actually just
recorded the episode
and uh and uh something with my brother
right and uh
we i went on xbox my you know my
girlfriend micah thank you guys you guys
had her on the show she was awesome she
was awesome absolutely and uh she's a
big xbox head so i i signed in and i was
finding my way around and i was like
yeah i'll just go buy halo i'm very
happy to buy halo and then it was like
39.99
or one dollar with gamepad
and i was like the conundrum you can't
not get the impact yeah that's right
and so
and so i went and canceled it later
because i just feel like i didn't want
to get charged again i'm not going to
use it for a
but i was i succumbed to your point i'm
succumbing myself
to this
uh modern model but as a developer of
games you know we're about to put out
we're about to announce our fifth games
and our games are on all platforms
we
are interested we're we're talking to
microsoft about game pass we want to
know how it works and how it can benefit
us we are very skeptical and i will say
a lot of people behind the scenes in a
lot of different places are not only
skeptical of that model but also
skeptical of what microsoft is doing
because it's going to force everyone
into this very narrow bucket it's
exactly what apple did on their own
platform people will recall very early
on on iphone you were paying 9.99 19.99
29.99 for things eventually the bottom
came out to where you couldn't charge
anything on that platform people had
expectations of either 99 cents or
nothing that's my fear with subscription
models and how that might marginalize
games and developers people that are not
in people that don't have the ability to
get their ideas out there and are
training a market to just not buy games
we all know that people say we'll wait
for it to be on game pass maybe that
will be that's valid
that's me that's a huge this is a huge
fear amongst developers i'm telling you
i am one and so so it's we have to
figure it out but am i resisting change
almost certainly you know that's
honestly and and so i'll be interested
to see what sony does with spartacus i
think it will be more backwards
compatible related than
forward what what would be what besides
the tv
yeah okay yeah please guys yeah i'm
sorry
um
the spartacus proposition right and you
you mentioned dayton day will be a main
motivating factor for you right that's
that's the main motivating factor for me
in game pass now
do you feel that they look at the
numbers and and the huge amounts of
money or whatever game passes uh making
because they get the metrics uh um mlb
the show was there day one
all right so
to sonia
we had you that was when you were your
first one
that was with the new job yeah whatever
yeah i just bring them up um
but again
to keep to to compete
and understand where that fear may lie
to compete and they have to feed that
beast which will become spartacus which
whatever name they use later on
uh is is your fear that they start to do
acquisitions just to put stuff inside uh
that beast to keep the machine going
because right now
game pass is a machine
all right and we're looking every month
to see what new games is going to drop
inside game pass at what date and stuff
like that it actually dictates your
playing cycle because right now i'm
playing hitman i had no thoughts of
playing hitman right so
do you fear that the playstation
ecosystem turns into that and moves far
away from
uh the five-year or four-year cycle does
it takes to to make a quality game that
you're looking for because if they have
enough studios
they can keep churning out good games at
a different uh cadence but
if they don't have the studios and they
have to start acquiring does that water
down the product is that the fear that
that's definitely that's definitely the
fear yeah i would say that's the fear
for most playstation fans because i
think
i don't i mean i don't know i don't want
to
it's hard to dispute that playstation
has a very high quality first party
diluting that with
with anything would be a shame because
it's not only the acquisitions that
would bother me as far as the dilution
of what the brand means playstation
studios and the quality
but it creates this vacuum i think for a
games which i love a game so think about
like embracer kind of games but those
games take shorter amounts of time let's
say two or three years to make for let's
say 40 million dollars and
you can get them out and just go and
keep going and it's gonna
just like netflix and amazon prime and
all those demand that kind of glut so
too are these game pass games and so
it's not only the acquisitions but sony
seeing projects and saying instead of
investing in the usual 200 million
dollar last of us type game we're gonna
have to invest in five different games
for 40 or 50 million dollars each none
of them are going to be as good but
that's going to be the new expectation
that's why i'm trying to hammer into
people's heads it's not about what this
does to playstation or what this does to
microsoft it's what it does to
everything around it as it creates a new
set of rules and
i just i don't want that to become what
sony is because
um i don't think it's true to the brand
and i think that it's kind of puts them
in a position where the only advantage
they've ever really had is quality and
if they don't have that advantage then
they don't have any advantage and uh
they should get used to
you know second or third place in that
in that situation and the other thing i
have to say by the way you guys haven't
mentioned is i also think sony has to
get
used to the idea of maybe being
purchased itself
um
yeah that's big
um
what do you mean by that by the way like
they need to get purchased by like
another bigger company no i don't want
them to do that either but i think it's
i think it's just as likely that a
company comes in and takes sony as a
company as sony goes in and takes a
swear annex and i actually think now
since they see microsoft willingly
spending money in the industry it might
not have been a thought process but now
it might be a thought process where it's
like look like
we were doing fine now we're doing fine
we're doing fine
then we're doing fine now
but are we gonna do fine in the future
without someone bankrolling the kind of
money to compete with something such as
google such as microsoft solve i want to
get you in because i'm sorry i missed
you a couple times yeah
you made it soft you're muted you're
muted you've been you've been really
[Laughter]
um
i guess my
my question for colin here is
if we
let's say game pass is not part of the
equation and the same the same amount of
acquisitions are happening
do you still see that as better as what
we have now because i think from from
what you're saying it feels like the big
fear is
the overarching change that game pass
brings into like you said how people
people's willingness and how they per
how they purchase games uh
so i i wonder because it just sort of
feels like regardless to what and i go
back to something that uh sean layton
said before before we left sony was like
the status quo at this point is
unsustainable and we're we are as gamers
because of what we want from from those
quality games those aaa games kind of in
part at fault for that right the change
in the status quo so my question is
do you think
if you remove game pass from the
equation which obviously it's a reality
that's not what it is
are we still in a better place
um
because it's it's still the same rat
race i think right i think you see you
see so many purchasing that here you see
microsoft purchasing there
the currency to me though is time
and i think this is what was being
brought up um
before
was
sony used to be able to take the time
for deliberate purchases right they
never purchased the studio sony is i
want to repeat that sony has never
purchased a studio it didn't work with
first
um
for only example of them doing that was
knicks's and ironically they acquired
mixes in order to make their games more
available right for pc which king loves
gig loves that
so so that position is okay so that
acquisition was the only acquisition
sony ever made where they didn't work
with the team usually multiple times
first to create that sort of cadence and
i think the removal of time is the key
element because
they no longer have time to make to see
right right when they bought gorilla
they had already made killzone so they
knew what they were getting and they're
like all right we're interested in
getting in the bed with you now when
they bought bend ben had already made
seifen filter so they were like all
right now we're going to get into bed
with you or when they bought you know
san diego well they founded san diego
studio that was the remnants of 989 of
course then they already knew what they
were getting
i feel like the removal of that time
means that they have to get into these
more hazardous relationships it's what i
said before like microsoft definitely
doesn't have a plan for activision like
they're figuring it out they're building
the plane in the air right now
um sony never operated like that and i
think
my biggest fear is is interrupting that
status quo because i i like where
they're at right now and i'm also not
opposed to just buying my games
individually i know a lot of people um
have a problem with that but again just
the way i play games i'm not so sure i'm
saving very much money on a subscription
service unless like we were saying
earlier with king that um you know
unless we have the day and date because
then you can't really if i'm gonna go
play
last of us three i'm how am i not gonna
have that right subscription model it's
just that's just stupid but otherwise i
don't know so i think there's a little
myopia in there for me like we were
saying
but also i think just kind of reality of
of the time being removal it feels the
rat race is increased it feels so much
more urgent and um i don't think that
translates well to what sony does
oh sorry i wanted to i'll raise my hand
i'm sorry i didn't i got it
all the time yeah
oh so guys no no no no please please go
down go down so
so colin so i i've been listening to con
this whole time because it's interesting
i understand his position i respect his
position i respect his point of view so
i'm trying to figure out how i'm going
to say this in in the perspective of
myself and everybody here who just plays
these games and we kind of grew up in in
this environment so i look at it like
two of the lesser evils and you know i
used to be i used to subscribe to that
idea where i didn't want sony buying
certain studios or microsoft i don't
even agree with the whole time exclusive
thing if you want to bring it to that
point but i will say
seeing over the years we've seen
some of the games that we like get swept
under the rug we stopped seeing them
release then we started seeing the
release of certain genres of games and
our favorite games subscribed to that
genre like open world
and if it means
that someone has to secure a type of
change
and
it could have been sony who bought
activision i would have celebrated the
idea that we would get some of the
titles that deserve to be brought back
from development right that was where i
was standing with that point you know it
didn't have to just be
microsoft but they initiated something
which i call is a reset so i hope it
kind of like i hope it goes through the
whole deal um listening to colin's point
you know is the first time you know we
i'm hearing him i understand where he's
coming from i get it i understand but we
are also in a cycle where
it sony can no longer be in that initial
lane and they kind of have to subscribe
to these different kind of uh
subscription based uh type of theories
where you need to buy out a company or
you need to buy out this kind of uh
studio or you know whatever and i just
feel like you know
yeah people weren't really like praising
microsoft the last couple of months but
you know what this was a big buy because
like i said i know i brought up call of
duty being one of the favorites of mines
that oh they might fix this game but
there's so much more behind it where
we've seen nothing but just clutter
after clutter after clutter being
released that's where i'm looking at the
w in this like where i see the wind you
know
what
i'm sorry
attic
i just wanted to hang and i got after
you after you add hogs
i just want to respond to what
what uh
ricky's saying like i agree and this is
the reason i agree because
all right look at maybe you know i cuz i
personally feel like xenomax is a little
bit more microsoft buying a studio that
they have closely worked with for years
but with the activision i feel like
there's multiple layers to why they
bought them
i think one of the layers is
if we're not going to go over there and
handle stuff over there when it comes to
all this stuff that's going on that you
know we don't really have to go into
then we don't really necessarily think
that might not neces that might get
fixed i also feel like as far as a gamer
it's like what ricky was saying
activision has been the downfall of
their own self
and like to my know to to my perspective
like we've given them plenty of chances
to integrate their own titles to do
something over there
and they not only have they were like
okay look you know call of duty's
popping let's you're not doing anything
else you're making call of duty you're
support studio for all the other call of
duty's and you're making call of duty
everyone's making call of duty so like
me pers to that perspective you know i
don't know what they're going to do when
it comes to call of duty
but i do know that if we kept it on the
same railing that the train's been going
we know where that was going right call
call of duty next year call of duty the
year after that uh then pretty much you
know making all their studios do what
they want that you know call of duty's a
big brand they might still go on that
route but then i want to like point
towards like the sony part of it like
i do feel like just like ricky said like
we've been kind of in a still
industry for a while now in terms of
like creativity i don't think no one's
willing to try anything and he needed
something big to change stuff up like
sony was getting real comfortable
with yo let's let call of duty to be our
multiplayer we'll worry about everything
else and now you probably have sony
doing emergency meetings is like
in a realm where we lose call of duty
what can we do to replace it to give
our fan base some form of multiplayer
experience on the platform that's what
i'm looking at because at the end of the
day
i'm right there with you calling i'm
getting tired of the same repeat
everything everyone's if if one
company's not doing another company's
stealing the idea when they're doing
something similar and it's just like
i've said it multiple times like the
only real big innovation i've seen in in
a while is something like the nemesis
engine
and it's just like i feel like if these
studios and these publishers continue to
play it safe constantly 100 of the time
nothing's ever going to change
and and and i can't really get on the
whole you know i'm more against timed
exclusives that i am about a company
buying a company because i feel like the
difference between like the embracer
stuff is like they're getting uh uh the
embracer thq nor they're getting a lot
of smaller well-known titles that's been
dormant for years and to me the the only
difference is is one has bigger ip's
than the other
and it's just like you know i'm looking
at it i'm a huge final fantasy fan i i
was starting to get comfortable with
buying final fantasy on the xbox
platform
and then sony i do feel like they got to
a point where they were feeling
uncomfortable what was going on they're
like yo someone hit square enix uh we
getting all this stuff in like to me
their western stuff's a little bit more
multi bullet but a lot of the easter
stuff the stuff i care about
a lot of it is pretty much only theirs
you know look what bethesda they tried
to get starfield
they got two of the other ips like
that's three other games that they they
got away from the xbox platform and like
my mindsets like i can't really
go against one and not the other because
it's like timed exclusives
they're going they're literally paying
someone to keep something off another
platform like sure
you're buying a whole company you're
kind of doing the same thing but at
least you're actually paying that
company price to determine where those
go instead of paying yo
we're getting this game so you can't
play and that's that's where i stand on
that because it's like you know we might
get uh
knights of the old republic
love that game gotta get i gotta use
this playstation to play right you know
uh first uh for spoken got to use the
playstation play final fantasy 16
playstation play every final fantasy 7
remake playstation to play it uh it is
that's just where i stand with it it's
just like one can't do it without the
other and when it comes to that
standpoint
because that microsoft you know
obviously like hulk said they haven't
bought them they've pretty much said
they're gonna buy them if they do go
through with that sony might actually
bring a resistance back because up until
now they've not needed it but right now
they're in this they're in that
viewpoint where it's like if we lose
call of duty and we lose
overwatch we're going to have to do
something to to to convince people
you need this playstation
plus because that's what a lot of people
don't talk about without call of duty
without overwatch there are stuff that
you would use playstation plus on but is
it uh is it enough to validate people
going out and subscribing to that
service anymore i got i got to get
hustle i got to get whole hustle i don't
know oh you oh
okay hold on hold on okay hold because i
know his time he's limited family sunday
football whole continue
oh well i you know i i've got a number
of responses i should have made a list
for for like 100 comments i mean the
very first one for colin i would say
is you know one of the things that i
think really focused my attention on the
tweet and the the video that you did
which i unfortunately haven't gotten a
chance to check out in substance yet was
referring to microsoft as a malign
influence referring to the acquisition
itself as a negative but i've heard your
comments here but i there's a number of
things that i don't agree with there
now folks need to understand my tilt i'm
a merger and acquisition server
salute
transactions this is where i get
energized it's a big day
but
you know when you talk about hey i wish
they spent 70 billion dollars making 10
more things or getting other teams
together
that's kind of throwing the money at the
problem kind of hypothetical right you
can't manifest developers you can't
manifest
video game creation capability no matter
how much money you wind up throwing at
it and frankly if you're starting a new
company whether it's the coalition or
the initiative or whatever other random
one word title that microsoft gives to a
new group of people making video games
it's taking development power from
somewhere else it's it's taking
experience from somewhere and so
i you know i think that the 70 billion
dollars spent on on this particular deal
is
overall a good thing i think the video
game industry should look at this as a
titan that had been essentially sitting
on its cash deck for 20 years where they
let their kid kind of play around with
putting a plastic box under a tv and
seeing if anything could ever come out
of it and had a green
martian alien guy and the board didn't
understand what was happening and three
years ago phil spencer goes and
convinces them to spend 100 billion
dollars in three years taking what was
four companies and making it 34
companies and overall if we don't get
sony eliminated if we don't lose
nintendo and all these other things the
video game consumer is advantaged by
some big giant gorilla deciding to hurl
a 100 billion dollars of sunk cost
investment into trying to make more
content for more players better
acquisitions can bother you
consolidation can bother you you can
worry about losing possibilities in the
future but i'm an optimist and what i
hear from colin what i hear from some
other quarters online is a concern that
the future doesn't look the same and it
won't
but assuming that that future is worse
than the one we have now is just not
something i ascribe to sony is going to
have a fire lit under it whether you
think that causes them to die and do bad
things or become more focused on doing
what they can do better more efficiently
and be a better competitor now with this
gorilla swinging his big money bag
around then
i personally think that sony's gonna
find its way but understand nobody can
fight this money cannon when phil
spencer goes and says hey we're talking
about amazon and google in 10 cent
that's because sony and nintendo and
ubisoft and ea and everybody else is a
minuscule ant compared to these trillion
dollar companies and nobody wants to get
into a hot war with that money gun so
how does nintendo survive and nintendo
has thrived this generation how they do
weird-ass [ __ ]
nice
they come up with a product that nobody
understands whether there's a market for
and it blows everybody away they also
release cardboard vr helmets from time
to time you don't know what they're
gonna do
but nintendo survives that way and sony
in my opinion is yes
gonna have to get a little weird gonna
have to get a little freakier than
they're used to
but that can be a good thing you say you
believe in that playstation 2 era and
that variety and the weird stuff that
came out of sony proper
i say we're going to get an invitation
to that if their board is paying
attention they know they can't compete
on acquisitions i don't know whether
they're going to buy square enix frankly
the only other major third party player
that makes sense for any of these
companies is ubisoft but we could talk
about that another time
i don't know whether someone's going to
make that move they're leveraged up to
hell they don't have the cash position
that xbox does they don't want to get
into that fight if i'm sony and they're
bored i say look what do we do to get
weirder what do we do to diversify what
do we do to differentiate because
they're going to be the big old
technology
maybe they're hollow
you say hollow and i tend to agree with
the overall thesis which is they're
bought and paid for which means here in
2022 we have very little to go on as to
what phil spencer ceo microsoft gaming
wants out of his end line products we
have a psychonauts 2 that is a success
but was largely made before microsoft
put them over and we have limited other
data points so i don't blame anybody for
looking at that and saying
i'm not sure yeah the skepticism is live
going to produce yeah but i like to
believe that it's going to go well and
i'd like to believe that essentially
hurling resources and letting the
creatives do what they want is going to
work it works for tim schafer zygonz 2
is a triumph
but
whether it'll work in the future i don't
know what i do know is that sony's gonna
have to react competition is good
and gamers should like that there's a
player in the industry that wants to
throw this money around all right and i
know i had others but i don't hold on i
got to be respectful because collins
time is limited so one i want to allow
him the ability to respond and then two
we i didn't really effectively get um
because we went a bunch of places which
was great but i really want to get the
sony response and what he what he wants
like in detail as well
yeah i mean first of all
always good to hear from ho ho i think
we'll just do a show together sure next
week or two so i'll just sign up i'll
just keep everything dry for then i
don't actually agree with a lot of what
you said because it really is
um
well first of all i think the the
overwhelming aura of it is just like it
could be it could be way worse right and
i agree with that i do think there's
just a lot of hypocrisy about the way
people felt about activision and call of
duty like one week
now everyone has that
um okay and by the way we're gonna by
the way we're gonna punish them with uh
by making multiple you know the board
and everyone billionaires um so that's
their that's their comeuppance
okay golden parachutes but my but my
response that's whatever that's
capitalism my response
and i'll be quick because i do have to i
know i know you've got to make sure you
guys haven't i got you bro is um
what my ideal would be is for sony to do
a little bit of what hogue is saying and
i think they're going to do that with um
they're an old enough brand now to kind
of rely on their old games yeah i think
backwards compatibility is a big thing
that they can do
and so i think that that is something
they'll do with sparks or whatever
they'll call it they'll probably end up
calling it playstation plus um and
i feel like there's that and they're
gonna figure that out i also think the
playstation plus collection which we
bring up a lot on our show is an
interesting quality oriented thing that
just needs to be
um reset more often i would argue that
there are multiple games on
on gamepad on a playstation plus
collection that are better than anything
on game pass and i think if sony can
leverage that i think that that would be
interesting but my biggest my biggest
response is the student the second party
studios that they were cultivating that
clearly that they didn't end up wanting
to get into bed with like quantic dream
supermassive and a few others those are
gone to the wind and some of their
partners are
in terms of development resources are
leveraged they had a pretty good
relationship with remedy for instance on
control but they're working with five
different publishers now
because i have been bad with epic
right they're deep in bed with epic and
i think it's gonna get deeper um i also
think maybe they'll leverage things like
discord and stuff into a social realm
that will make playstation more and more
um
readily interesting to people but i feel
like what i would love for them to do is
to continue to announce these small
deals these mysterious deals
uh and we by the way there are a couple
studios that are working on that are not
even announced yet including one in san
diego that's working you know um
alongside the show team on something big
so they have some things to to respond
with but my hope is that they just
they focus on the boutique nature of
playstation which is what i think makes
it special and even after the activision
deal the reality is this playstation
still makes way more money than the xbox
brand but the problem is is that their
relationship with activision and with
microsoft and maybe even with the vesa
in the future um will come at a cost and
we were talking about that on the show
it's really interesting keep call of
duty on playstation at 70 30.
every game that's sold is just okay fine
seven three seven three seven three and
before you know it it's just you're just
making all this money they're really in
between a rock and a hard place and um
i'm really interested to see what it's
going to be all about but we should have
known after what happened with the show
that it was going to be a bad a year of
getting kicked in the balls for
playstation but it's happening all
aboveboard because the reality is the
console's still selling you can't find
it it's outselling xbox and i don't know
if that's gonna change game pass is five
years old now right like has it really
changed everything it's really
tantalizing but is it going to affect
that for playstation i don't know
there's a lot of open questions but i
hope they keep it small and i'm going to
be so i look on my phone every morning
now and i'm like what
horrible move did they announce
people are going to expect me to defend
you know that's not going to happen so
um but i appreciate you guys having me
it's it's good to talk to you and always
i'm wishing you guys the very best in
cog i'll see you on edu and indeed
william brother i wish you i'm not sure
i'll see you again we'll see you again
now
i i just want to say before you guys
you know i loved you came on i love
these discussions brother i love it we
could we can all agree to disagree or
have different viewpoints but be
respectful and and it's great man and i
appreciate i know your time live but i
really appreciate you addict say what
you got to say because i don't call him
i do agree with you on on on the thing
like people keep saying
sony needs to buy this by that i
actually feel like that would make it
worse if sony tries to respond like a
square enix
that might get microsoft thinking
you know other companies might buy other
stuff and then they might that might be
a catalyst for them just to buy
something else uh so you know i do agree
with you and i i don't want to act like
there isn't a fear of consolidation
whatsoever because i do have a fear
because i feel like i feel like
activision isn't the catalyst to my
fear i can i jump in i'm so sorry to
interrupt because whilst colin is here i
just wanted to is he still here colin
are you there yeah i really have to go
so you have to go
i'm sorry i'm like 15 minutes late to
what i was talking about
[Music]
i love you guys so much i didn't
interrupt but i wanted to laser colin so
but i love him as well but i didn't want
to say anything right now we got to be
respectful and you know that's also here
i i know i know there are uh differing
opinions that's why we want all the
spectrum right we want it all right so
where's
the red background that's me yeah yeah
on zoom is weird your face pops up there
it doesn't oh yeah
by the way
because you as an m a lawyer no
and the industry this is either it was
microsoft or someone else you kind of
smashed it and i can't wait for your
conversation with them but cog smash him
as well
i know you feel brother
if you want more of cog be honest you're
gonna have to get the defining dude
because at the end of the day i have to
look at all these great personalities
yeah i do that yeah
check check this out real quick uh and i
look
colin's point of view
comes from a valid point it's a it's a
very valid point because the thing is
we're us as older gamers right i'm
speaking about cog myself king the guys
always make this about
no no no no but by far the oldest
exactly
and hogue as well right
in general as human beings change is
difficult change is destructive right
the thing about this change
is that
it could not have happened in any other
way when you think about the options
right and when you think about the
realities of where our industry is this
is the thing a lot of the arguments that
were happening during the course of the
week that were sort of uh kind of like
on a moral soapbox about this is bad for
them
my problem with those arguments is
they're not acknowledging the reality of
where we are as an industry
and the reality is that all of this was
going to happen regardless of microsoft
happening and we go back to the
arguments of who would have done it
right
do we have a 10 cent jumping and doing
what
the issue is that i just
i guess i know where you're coming from
right i know that you're saying like
colin's point of view is is
very much based on the way he consumes
games and the way he wants to continue
to consume games and we got to keep in
mind he was in the industry he knows how
it forms right like that's his mindset
he seemed more personal
definitely more personal like but he's a
developer
any specifics let's not personalize it
let's just talk about it
what i'm saying when i'm saying that
he's a developer he's looking at it from
a different perspective like he's
telling you the bottoming out of apple
he's explaining to you that the fair uh
from a developer standpoint uh you know
this what's the bottom
on the game pass you know type of thing
and people are not purchasing games and
they're all gonna ask you just don't
personalize it but just say the point
just say the point but get your balls
off get your balls get your balls get
your bar get your boss i want you to get
your boss please
me yes yeah okay so
i'm not going to personalize that i'm
not going to do that on your show i
appreciate that this is
a
i appreciate that
what i was going to say is he when you
and colin's points he talks about it
being corrosive he talks about
consolidation prima facie being bad but
he doesn't what the argument the
argument the argument
the argument doesn't tackle the point
about the specifics of activision
blizzard studio or publishing out
in turmoil with two games their biggest
games overwatch two and diablo iv pushed
away because of talent migrating out i
feel that they could not retain that
talent
microsoft saved them it was a pitch to
save that publisher if it wasn't for
them do you want 10 cent what's the
alternative
and colin's argument has been
poised to defend timed exclusivity
multiple times celebrating timed
exclusivity which has a history of
actually being corrosive to the industry
to the point where the sega state of
saturn's demise was hyper accelerated by
tomb raiders timed exclusivity by
playstation where we saw playstation
playstation now
playstation in its last gen knowing that
the xbox was at its weakest point double
down on its times exclusivity to in an
attempt to outstand the market
i just don't understand how you can on
the one hand be
i get it consolidation is bad but i
don't see any substance in the argument
in in the in light of the industry now
in light of 10 cent and all this
consolidation going forward because
sony's poor we need to be feeling sorry
for playstation no
i don't think that's let me finish that
finish let gas finish let's not even
talk about it in the sense that it's a
calling thing because it's not it's just
an argument yeah i don't know i think
that's finished
let gas finish please
well okay
my adhd is kicked off the interruption
i'm gonna say so no no go go ahead but
what i want to say to what i wanted to
tackle with from colin just get a tip
for tat on how is it there's such a
disparity in your energy in in that but
you're going to ignore everything around
the deal the substance around the deal
the people the controversies he made a
point to say oh i like how everyone al
collins argument was this point about
uh people are now double standards and
loving up activision hold on
the this is a positive boon the for the
publishing outfit the staff have been
celebrating because they can finally see
a light at the end of the tunnel we're
not saying oh we love activision we love
the eyepiece and we love the prospect of
positive things
that's really fair i believe the core of
his argument look is there a little bit
personal bias in there when it comes to
playstation yes
but we can't act like
that consolidation in the future if this
is continued doesn't stand right because
look like i i said it a couple days ago
right now you only really got four
places to play consoles any kind of game
you got like unless you got like mobile
devices you got the pc that i'm on now
the playstation that's on now or the
xbox or the switch like i feel like them
buying each other would be more
consolidation than publishers buying
each other but if there's only two three
publishers and microsoft owns the rest
or one publisher in microsoft owns the
rest there is a form of worry going on
there that microsoft literally owns the
whole industry and i do get that point
of his argument look sure i disagree
with his stance on on time exclusion
that's fine but i don't think he's
coming from a point of malice where he
he wants you know my he just wants
the point of where
two or three people don't own everything
yeah and i think that's the that's the
key point here i do know tracy has his
hand up for a minute i'm sorry chase
that i i jumped in
chase i know chase i gotta get him but i
got whole house to leave then check
yeah whole gotta leave then chase and
then dutch yes hey i just want to say
thank you for having me uh you know i
could do an hour here but uh i really
appreciate the conversation i've been
doing great stuff here
and uh i'm sure i'll be on again but
there's gonna be a lot to talk about for
now into the long future on this deal so
keep going on and thank you again for
inviting me much love man thank you
brother a lot of insight you are
absolutely hilarious you've been you're
talking legalese i can listen to it for
days brother you
look i will start timing people out in
this chat yeah i get it some people
don't agree with anything at the end of
the day you come to this podcast because
you know we're still going to give
people voices exactly if you just wanted
literally if we didn't get calling on we
would have comments in the comments
section saying oh it's only one-sided
conversation yeah exactly
[Laughter]
thank you brother i appreciate you man
enjoy your sunday and thank you for
rooting for my 49ers i appreciate that
energy that was done hey like i said
anybody that can get rid of aaron
rodgers for me i'm a lion forever oh man
i'm a lions fan forever i don't get joy
except from schadenfreude
thank you very much go niners see you
later love chase
all right so
i think i think everybody in general
needs to relax a little bit because we
don't really know what's going to happen
a year from now a year and a half from
now in general
um
like we don't know if this is the new
normal
where uh studios is going to keep
getting by left and right the the
circumstances around the activision deal
lined up so that that deal could happen
i don't know if you remember this king
last year when i was on the podcast yeah
i said
in order to be bot you have to want to
be bought he was like naw man we could
just stronghold everybody throw back
no wait wait i said no i wanted your
strong arm
yeah right matt you got the mask on
that's what he had to mask
there's been attempts to
consolidate one way or another that have
not worked out we've seen because warner
brothers would you be soft is always
under attack right uh warner brothers
was talking about trying to sell um
possibly their gaming division yeah
sometimes i think xbox was trying to get
that that didn't that didn't work out we
uh this isn't gaming necessarily but uh
discord was looking to do something yeah
microsoft couldn't get that you have to
want to be but there's things that we
all have or we love that you can't put a
price on
so some of these studios and publishing
companies may feel the same way they may
not be interested in being part of the
consolidation so for people to think
that you could just toss your money
around and if you had the right price
everybody's gonna go with it i don't
think that's true but if that's the deal
that made sense both of the deals make
sense to the bethesda deal really made
sense um for you know because at a
relationship they had with them the
active vision deal is more so about like
they said saving the cup and all that
people are concerned with the quality of
games the quality of the game's been
diminished for like 10 years that's
that's what i was saying because are you
playing
i swear as a cod player i feel that pain
i feel that faith
double a indie games
more often
if you're really waiting on them they i
feel like they've been carrying a lot of
the industry for a couple years anyway
because our triple a games
are super hit or miss i
a lot of the games we love we've seen
the downfall of and we see the
conditions that the games come out in
and uh people are not talking about that
they're we're worried about the quality
of games
um and the other thing is a lot of the
business practices that we've seen i
don't know who's responsible for some of
these things but i would prefer a
company that would uh
be more
um careful of of how they treat our our
wallets would take up somebody's company
so microsoft picking up active vision i
think microsoft's been a lot more fair
through their uh customer base the
active vision activision's responsible
for a lot of bad business practices and
the way we get our game stuff
same thing goes for take two and other
games like that because what we now have
is games reboots remakes scared to put
out new ips because you want to make
episode or yeah or the 15th iteration of
the
beginning
we keep getting the same and then we are
getting a uh
way too many
open world 150 hours of talk about it i
i don't think the problem is
microsoft getting activision it could be
it could be we don't know what if we
don't know effects that the that game
pass will have long term because what
you want to have a hard time
convincing somebody who's only been
paying a subscription
to if if changes happen and that quality
is lower or a service like that goes
away which i'm not saying it will right
you're going to have a hard time
convincing people like that to now start
paying 60 70 or whatever right true
shame the devil now look we don't
swallow our grades
there's too much that we don't know for
people to be getting all right oh
everything's getting by so bad is but
for what yeah we don't know there's
still a lot to be determined yeah i
understand i understand the the concern
but i understand that things have not
played out and we still have to see it
microsoft still has a lot to prove
valid playstation i got to be respectful
i'm going to ask a favor because i know
you jumped in first but i got fonz i
know has a show
fawns can i if you dodge would you mind
if i get fawns but put him ahead of you
for a second for this one i just thought
you hanging right
oh i'm honking all right
my brother and i got we got the
legendary lord jess corden pull it up
he's be after that but man we got a lot
to talk about this is a very powerful
moment in gaming so lord fox
gaming gaming
yeah smoothest voice nice hat sir nice
great hat nice hat yourself man oh yeah
whoa you know how we outside baby yeah
that's a beanie that's not a hat
it's a hat bro your feelings no google
that beanie a hat stop it you've been
very vocal on twitter as well um we've
got a lot to say about this acquisition
in short you know overall feelings and
then you know whatever you want to talk
okay
first of all i'll say overall this is
the best thing that could have happened
to activision blizzard
flat out
uh you know what because i you know i'm
hearing a lot of doom and gloom from
some outlets and some people
and i just don't see it especially the
turmoil that activision blizzard was in
especially the fact that bobby kotick
did not want to step down the fact that
his investors wanted him to step down
the fact that people were pushing him
gamers everybody developers wanted him
to step down he was unwilling to do so
and even at this point he's still acting
arrogant and smug out there and kind of
acting like hey i didn't do anything
wrong uh sort of thing and i don't know
if i'm gonna be here after the merger
blah blah blah no you're gone bobby
you're gone
um and that is a good thing that is a
great thing for this industry i'm sorry
golden parachute or not i'm glad he's
going to be booted out okay
that for is first and foremost
the alternatives the alternatives were
people like 10 cent facebook gaming you
know
do you really want to see amazon step in
and swoop them up for luna you know
things like that people there was
alternatives out there because either
this company was going to be sold or
this company would have been going down
in flames
okay it already started the fire was
there
so
that has to be said
um aside from that
uh i you know
not to point fingers at anybody in
particular because i know we're not
about that here on on the lord's show
but uh i i do have to say the lord's
show
you know it's it's the lord's day
um
the thing is i have to just say the
people out there that are saying stuff
like
sony is different though because they're
not going after big publishers they're
not going doing this and that
if they had the capital they would
if they had the capital
they would
the facts are this they've taken away so
much in gaming from the other side from
xbox that it makes no sense for anybody
on a big platform and say hey
you know
sony wouldn't do that
they have
they have sir
they've bought companies that have
basically stripped away things like big
franchises like spider-man
okay
they've they've taken things away from
uh
they're continuing to take exclusives
away final fantasy franchise gone
you might not see final fantasy remake
on xbox period
we're not hearing nothing about it
anymore
and people and gamers out there want to
play it on xbox hold on hold on follow
us hang on a
but is that square just doing that
because or is that playstation making
about that
playstation playstation money talks
hustle money talks
and this is the thing at the end of the
day
playstation is putting the bills out
there for these companies to keep games
off of other consoles so what is the
difference at the end of the day if
whole franchises are taken away you talk
about the principle of it that your
argument the principle principle is the
same okay okay
this is a big thing like for people to
have the audacity to say that this is
totally different
and you know call of duty is being taken
away from me when you don't even really
care about call of duty is just weird
it's weird because i don't care about
call of duty i don't care if they keep
it multi-plat or they or they go
exclusive with it i don't personally
care but at the end of the day i saw a
company that was in turmoil and call of
duty is a huge franchise to other people
yes
i think as a business strategy it makes
more sense for them to keep it exclusive
and it would be the right thing to do
because of the fact that this is about
competing in a space where your
competitors are competing with you yeah
this there there is no i i i'm i'm you
know i'm thinking about your feelings in
business thank you
so this is not this is not what they're
doing here
and i i realized that you know boom hit
it on the head early on when he said
that these developers that are working
within the company that was going down
in flames how the some of them are
really happy about this acquisition
that's a great thing
that is that is a big thing to think
about as well and i was going to touch
on that as well but so many good things
were said today about this situation but
i had to
put a cap on some of that and also bring
in some of what my thoughts are i
appreciate you and i i honestly think
that at the end of the day it's a good
thing it's a good thing
um we're going to see more of this kind
of stuff in gaming because
they're competing all right at the end
of the day they're competing with each
other
sony's going to keep doing these
exclusive exclusivity deals and taking
away games from other consoles they've
been doing it i don't understand why
people glance over that and think that's
okay
but if microsoft does it shame on you
it's it's really crazy i gotta get dutch
that's what i wanted to say brother i
appreciate you always passionate no
problem man no problem don't don't get
into the twitter wars too much but i
know you're passionate oh no no no you
know i have not been doing that lately
you've been nice you've been i've been
watching you you've been behaving you
haven't been i respected
thank you thank you so much i know
obviously you know it's a lot of
opinions on on twitter that you saw that
you disagree with you were very vocal
you know and i hit you offline because
you know i i got to mentor the dutch
sometimes like that get in this deal
right quick bro let's talk about this
you know what's there you have these
great discussions and i love to bring it
here on this panel so brother what's
your thoughts man you feel very strongly
about it i want to get with you what you
feel about the state
yeah well overall overall i have to also
agree the
the whole first of all
consolidation is not happening in this
instance there is consolidation in the
gaming sector would have to be
absolutely ginormous in order to swallow
up even a
small percentile of the entire gaming
sector um consolidation would be to have
a vast majority if you were to see xbox
then oh sorry microsoft then swallow up
the likes of
um take two or then embrace a group
and then 10 cents that would be
consolidation it would have the vast
majority of the of the gaming sector
then built in
um
but we have to remember just within the
us alone there was almost 2
300 gaming development studios and 525
publishers that's just in the us
that's not including
asian markets or european markets
so including worldwide studios
developers etc publishers you're looking
more towards the three to four thousand
development studios worldwide uh almost
four million developers worldwide
consolidation in the gaming sector would
have to be absolutely
massive um to to get anywhere near that
um and
in terms of monopolistic behaviors
that's another one i've heard on on
twitter
uh monopoly's not even anywhere close
once this acquisition's complete they're
going on towards essentially something
like 15 to 17 percent of the entire
sector
um
in the grand scheme that's not monopoly
[Laughter]
it's not it's not a monopoly it's not
no
[Laughter]
messy that's you i'm just saying this
let us get our messy or behaved bars
after the guests because the guests are
limited time so continue dutch i got to
get yes
no worries no worries um
secondly in terms of it being good for
gaming
it's good on so many aspects
um you can talk about the exclusivity of
call of duty all you like but um there
is no court of law that's going to stop
a an acquisition because of a singular
ip
in my opinion um that has been
always brought up by court of law over
in the us as being the cause or root
cause
of
gun violence um or the cause of
shootings etc earth throughout the u.s
um
something that's been always taught as
the devil
by lawmakers
in countless cases
around the world specifically
um not just call of duty but first
person shooters etc to then say that
they're going to block an acquisition
due to the exclusivity of a singular ip
furthermore being a
violent gun game um is
is ridiculous it's not going to happen
because of an ip it's never going to
happen because of an ip the only thing
that would ever stop an acquisition like
this would be the staff treatment
the the retention of staff
how that company's going to be looked
after going forward if they're not
content that the current issues are
going to be
um
corrected at activision blizzard in
terms of the staff treatment if that
wasn't going to be corrected and the the
department of justice and and all of
those aren't content with
the plans going forward to correct it i
can see them saying no this acquisition
isn't going through we don't believe
that this is going to be the
the best course of action for this
particular transaction and this merger
won't
benefit
um the the company or the sector
um i think that being said um microsoft
of course historically aren't
um they're not squeaky clean they've had
their bad moments in terms of the world
stuff historically oh yeah um but
they've went a long way in correcting
that um over the recent years um and
they are furthermore now championing
inclusivity um perfect well obviously
staff treatment the way staff are looked
after um and uh the way that their
studios respect their staff
um and they've they've made that
statement within the the press release
of course on xbox wire saying that they
they kind of adhere or at least believe
that all staff working for them will
adhere to their guidelines on
staff treatment
from top to bottom not from anybody at
the lower ranks all the way up to the
the team managers the managers the
directors the
and everybody in between have to adhere
by this or essentially be out the door
and that should be the way it is
put a rough stance on it
because let's face it activation
blizzard haven't put a rough stance on
it i haven't done enough right the only
person that came out in recent times
after the acquisition to mention
anything to do with that has been mike
ibarra from blizzard and have softened
this statement it was powerful i mean i
mean i i respected it we got to see it
in the action i'm sorry
no it's all right but that's
that in itself is absolutely it's it's
massive and the one the one thing that
i've seen from blizzard um employees um
prior to mikey borah's statement was
that they weren't aware and i have to
say it shout out to any anybody that's
working at
um blizzard um or activision who've
never worked for a plc that's been taken
over before um
that were confused as to why they hadn't
heard anything or etc um large
organizations when it goes through like
that a merger of that size you don't
hear anything unfortunately because of
regulations and legalities it has to be
public knowledge prior to it being staff
knowledge they have to report it to the
city shareholders investors etc and
because of the way that it goes um they
are the last to find out i've been party
to it before i actually i'm an
ambassador ambassador for a company who
has been swallowed by embracer group oh
wow
do i know what that is in terms of how
that works
um
so
i've also worked for a company that's
been plc and swallowed up other people
and they've advised the city firsthand
so
um
it is what it is unfortunately for the
staff you weren't going to find out
beforehand due to legalities but you can
be rest assured
that going forward microsoft have the
best interests at heart when it comes to
how the staff are going to be treated
going forward and in turn the staff
wellness um both mentally physically and
and everything in between is only then
going to further the creativity the
happiness and the output of these staff
going forwards for their games and ips
um
if you're going to continue with with
all of the issues that you had at
activision blizzard you're going to see
a rapid and steady decline of all of the
ips studios
it's going to be an absolute mess and
and with this in mind i think the vast
majority of staff upon seeing that news
would have been a sigh of relief
and more so just wishing it was sooner
rather than later right they've still
unfortunately got a grin and babe bobby
kordick for the next 12 to 18 months
which you wouldn't wish on anybody like
the golden parachute
yeah shout out to the 290 million in
your bank action shout out to get paid
but yes
in terms of creativity it's it's only
going to rejuvenate these these staff
going forwards
um
furthermore the statement on
on
straight after the that announcement was
we want to bring back all these ips we
want to explore all these other ips and
get these studios working again
there's five out of the seven studios at
activision blizzard working on call of
duty
at the peak of call of duty development
six of the seven studios were pulled in
including toys for bob which was insane
um having six full studios and even then
canning blizzard's two games essentially
two other games in overwatch um
and diablo for a little bit and and and
moving on into forcing them doing little
bits for for call of duty it's just
insane um considering you've got a game
that's getting churned out once a year
um and and the qualities rapid decline
of of that franchise as well that needs
to be put to bed
um
the overall
the
because of the acquisition because of
the investment
because of the way microsoft now treat
their staff and have further implemented
their guidelines on inclusivity
and working practices it's going to
increase creativity right it's going to
uh expand the the ips um call of duty is
going to be put to rest for a couple of
years upon exclusivity agreements
finishing with tony um then it's going
to come back bigger and better than it
ever was
um whether or not that stay is exclusive
it means nothing there's there's there's
ways and means around um that
exclusivity and the wording itself i'm
not going to get into
the wording in that could be portrayed
in either way you can go on we'll talk
about desires only
because that is a call of duty and
therefore that ideas to call of duty
staying on the platform
um or it could mean that um they're
going to get a much smaller slice of the
call of duty revenue profit going
forward
just to have it there i don't foresee
them ever putting game pass on the
platform primarily because there would
be too much
um
potential issues surrounding how the
uh
micro transactions purchasing of game um
items from game pass etc would work out
on a sony platform that have to in
essentially
bring in an online platform for
microsoft within the sony platform which
i don't think they'd ever allow
and that is kind of the drawback there
um of course you can have game pass you
can play the games but then when you
purchase things for those games on game
pass on the platform how would that work
if so it would have to be some form of a
curated list but yeah even there there's
a lot of complications involved yeah i
hate the country because we i got
there's another wave and i'm trying to
be respectful of times
jazz i don't know how long he's got but
um i'm sorry that's just if you could
conclude your point quickly yeah and
then i can get just i don't want to be
rude
easy easy way to wrap this up it isn't
it's calm the nerves from sony you've
got an absolute abundance of
unbelievable ips both past and present
that sony can still explore
the quality of sony studios and all of
all of those developments are second to
none you've there is no reason to be
worried um in terms of card in the what
that that shouldn't affect you you know
either neither here nor there
the quality of of of playstation isn't
going to degradate because of this
acquisition it's not going to harm them
in any way shape or form outside of
whatever happens with call of duty and
even then
um that's just a minor inconvenience
they've got their own big first person
franchises they should be focusing on
rejuvenating in socom etc
um studio itself in terms of the
benefits massively massively positive
for all the staff at activision blizzard
their creativity um consolidation's not
happening um it's again it's just great
i think it's great for the for the
gaming sector in general and for the
consumer at the end of the day consumer
wallets are going to be really happy
with this no more one pin 90 to 100
for a call of duty launch you're going
to be able to get it
as part of a subscription service yeah
this is another great thing some people
will value that for sure man i
some valid points i respect what you're
saying you know your opinion on on on
the future of the industry and where
it's going and you know you you have
first-hand knowledge as far as you know
people with being acquired and kind of
the temperature in the building so i
really respected your insight there i
want to get jazz in because he was a
late ad and i wasn't sure i was going to
get him and he good friend of mine and i
really want to hark on a couple points
he made that i thought was very
important to the discussion and i'm kind
of done with the sony's i can take that
sony part off but um yeah so pretty much
jazz you
had a fun week on twitter i said
and uh i'm not gonna get to all the i'm
not gonna get to the best of the towers
and all that aspect of twitter we're
gonna talk about that every towel oh
yeah we're gonna talk about ivory towers
and all that salaries but what we're
gonna talk about
is you know one part that i dm'd you
offline and and we had a conversation
and it resonated with me so i want to
repeat this aspect of your tweet if you
don't mind which is um you said do you
care about activision blizzard staff
getting a much needed change in
leadership i'm not going to say the
names but would you prefer lord zee or
lord
do you want to preserve the status of
quo with lord k in charge forever
this is the best outcome in our current
economic economic system would you
rather microsoft's capital sit in a bank
doing nothing i don't know the only real
argument against all of this when you
boil it down is capitalism bad microsoft
bad which is fine but be honest you
don't care about the staff and you don't
care about consumers i thought it was a
powerful powerful tweet so let's talk
about it culture you know consolidation
just your overall thoughts for as long
as i have yeah i know time's limited
they hated him for he spoke with the
truth
[Laughter]
[Music]
rand was in the xbox era discord
laughing the whole thing
leave randomly continue
man it's like
the thing that the things that i think a
lot of people are mad about
they're not mad at microsoft some people
are mad at microsoft some people are
salty they might lose call of duty some
people are salty their favorite platform
might get damaged but i think a lot of
the establishment what they're really
mad at is capitalism
and um they see capitalism as as this
sort of
evil being that has caused a lot of our
economic problems you know people of our
age and younger and slightly older have
lived through
several once in a lifetime economic
crashes we have politicians who conduct
insider trading
like like it's nothing and they inflate
their wealth by millions year in year
out
and it's all a mess
but me i don't care
am i getting a better world of warcraft
out of this
that's all i care about
that's honest that's honest you about
the games continue
now i mean
we would need to dismantle the entire
economic system to solve the issues that
are being presented
and i don't see people presenting any
alternative solutions it becomes when
you really get down into it if you get
into the reductionism of it
you arrive at a point where it's like
we have to dismantle the whole system
i don't want to
i don't want to dismantle the whole
system
because i like having running water and
i like having you know at the mcdonald's
around the corner and stuff like that
you know i'm just one guy i'm just a
simple guy and i just want some games
i want games to be good but the the
thing that really matters out of all
this is positive outcomes for the
employees we don't know
if microsoft is gonna
deliver on all its promises but that's
what
we as xbox fans whatever we need to hold
microsoft accountable
because
yep
all the people who are just sort of like
ignoring the possible benefits and you
know using it as a as an ideal a
platform to be ideological or whatever
um
they forget that there are thousands of
human beings who have been put put
through the ringer this year
with non-stop scandals even before this
year i've been writing about kotik and
his [ __ ] for the last million yeah
we're trying to please the children
i i know when i suppose children are
sleeping by now
sorry
i hate the guy i hate the guys i'll be
dropping f-bombs left right and center
if i didn't have so much respect for you
mr cognition thank you and i'm with you
jazz i'm with you thank you bro i
appreciate all y'all for responsible
ricky too
i've watched kotick suck the life at a
franchise after franchise i've watched
him live hundreds and hundreds of people
arbitrarily to meet arbitrary quarterly
shareholder goals only to then gradually
hire the people back because they
actually needed those employees i've
watched the customer service departments
at the blizzard in europe shrink and
grow as
bobby looks like where can we make a
saving this quarter let's just fire all
these people and then once the filings
been listed let's start hiring them back
because the guy is a scumbag he is a
scumbag
unfortunately in our current economic
system we can't fire him out of a cannon
we can't we can't put him in jail
because in our current economic system
which is a hell prison we all live in
we have to take what we could get right
there's a lot of cfds going on here
continue
what we can take in our current economic
economic system is microsoft taking some
of its capital out of the bank rather
than just letting it sit there losing
value with inflation that can take some
of that capital out of the bank
potentially put it back into the economy
and a lot of that money will get
reinvested in new studios new ventures a
lot of venture capital flowing around
the new studios crop up left right
center um i think um
jeff strain from microsoft went off to
make a video game venture capital firm
with the money he got from selling uh
undead labs so you know he's reinvesting
the money he got from selling his
business back into the video game
business
that's the
the the supposed benefits of capitalism
okay is there is there it's about the
flow of money consolidation means that
every one company owns everything you
know microsoft pretty much has like
something like 80 of the pc market with
windows but we never really hear people
complaining about windows being a
monopoly anymore because it's an open
platform because you can build your
businesses on it a lot of
a lot of businesses are built on windows
and and it's openness dell has his whole
business built on windows and all these
other companies have built their
business build on built on the monopoly
that is windows microsoft has shown
itself to be pretty good
at managing its platforms for the social
good and it's um i think it was funds or
it was dutch who said
that they're not squeaky clean
and even now they're not squeaky clean
they're they're pulling some [ __ ]
with microsoft edge right now trying to
force people to download things
sorry sorry sorry you're good they're
pulling some
some malarkey
[Laughter]
every time they're pulling some
shenanigans
microsoft edge yes and
you know which is like microsoft this is
this is the monopoly
stuff
[Music]
they've been through all this in the 90s
with their monopolies they got slammed
by antitrust laws before and since then
they've been like
they've been
better about managing monopolies they
know how to manipulate
politicians and america's politicians
are very easily manipulated oh my god
oh my god let's
there are genuine things to be concerned
about with our entire economic system
but you know there has to be sort of a
point where it's like
what what are the things we can take
from this that are positive
games and game pass which is better for
consumers changing leadership for the
staff at activision blizzard so they can
get a better working environment
freedom from the the ball and chain that
is call of duty switch it to a two-year
cycle and let creativity flourish
because
i don't think a lot of game devs get
into the industry with the mindset of i
want to be working on candy crush
forever i want to be working on
a good point but they they pay the bills
you know yeah but under microsoft these
studios are shielded from shareholders
because under activision their
shareholders have a direct interest in
the you know the growth of these games
right but under microsoft microsoft
shareholders they only care about azure
really
you know is azure growing
you know and
and that's where a lot of their
shareholder mentality comes from is like
how are they doing in their competition
with amazon amazon web services how are
they how are they doing in their
competition with ibm how are they doing
in their competition with business to
business deals you know
and xbox is going to become an
increasing part of that business
proposition but it's going to be through
azure it's going to be like i think one
day we'll see the the id tech engine as
a licensed property i think we'll see
microsoft included tech engine and game
stack and be like you know to try and
compete with 10 cents on real engine
because 10 cent owns 49 of unreal engine
you know
and um
that's what that's what microsoft's
thinking with this they're thinking like
you know we can
make the shareholders happy with our
business to business operations and then
we can make the gamers happy by making
games and it's no it's no like it's no
coincidence that phil name checked
guitar hero and it's not it's no
coincidence that starcraft was in the
banner he wants to bring these games
back because game passes they need
diversity they need every niche
and if you'll if you look at what sony's
been doing with its strategy it's been
going after niches it's basically been
like if you're a fighting game fan you
have to buy a playstation
and increasingly they're like if you're
a jrpg fan you have to buy a playstation
and they do these they do these
hilarious things where they're like oh
yeah it's um it's covering xbox in a
year
but
where's
foreign yeah we're talking about the
behind the behind the scenes extension
this is what you mean okay it casts this
shadow of doubt it's almost like
guerrilla warfare it's like this
chilling effect
on on the whole idea of of are we ever
to get any of these jrpgs are we ever
going to get finalized seven and like
all these sort of mysterious vagaries
you know it casts doubt on the xbox
platform and that's sony being sony
doing business things so that's fine
they're doing what they can do with the
money they have available which is
nowhere near as much as microsoft and
microsoft
has to compete by opening their
pocketbook
and the fact that they've done this
truly does show that they're all in on
gaming like oh for sure last summer when
satya was like like oh yeah we're all
gay remember that
yeah yeah we're all in the gaming i'm
sitting there thinking like how much do
i believe this guy you know he said they
were all in on nokia and then they
killed my windows phone i killed it
i killed
[Music]
i'm sorry if they do nail this deal
i will forgive them for windows first
hear that yeah i appreciate it if you if
you land this deal and make world of
warcraft great again i will forgive you
personally for what you did to my phone
okay
just with the ball i appreciate you
brother thank you so much man that's my
only type fantastic thanks man for taser
take it i appreciate your time we got i
got to keep the thing moving cause we're
getting towards the end and i gotta get
it by the way uh yeah before you keep it
moving here i just want to say i gotta
go yes um i'm gonna get ready for my
show yes it's fun to just hang out wait
wait wait wait guys
yeah i need to ask you yeah what's up
the hell's that sign thing in in your
background yeah i was gonna ask the same
thing the what what is that the size
there's a sign with a little gif on it
this
keep talking this thing right here
this is the uh this is a davoom pixel
something it's it's it's just a little
thing i found online and i just picked
it up yeah fine
what you got it looks awesome thank you
sorry to introduce
them anyways anyways yeah i will
definitely send you a link uh yeah so
anyways i just want to let people know
that um yeah your show is going to go
along here but my show will start in
about 20 minutes but um me and gaz we
have a lot more to say on this topic
trust us please but uh we'll be over
there doing that so when this show ends
guys
you can look up fonz gaming you'll find
my channel and uh we'll be live and uh
doing my thing thank you thank you yeah
we're gonna have a lot of fun there and
i want to leave you with something
because everybody's asking you know will
it be exclusive call of duty will it not
here i'm going to leave you guys with
this as i leave this is about delivering
great exclusive games for you that ship
on platforms where game pass exists and
that's the
truth later guys
thank you got it from bringing phil
[ __ ] for his words absolutely
salute let's get i got to get the order
i'm uh i'm gonna have to take off
get your balls off then get your balls
off
i i can't i'd have to leave like right
now all right there on time i will speak
to you offline i'm bailing two yeah yeah
thanks ever so much appreciate it i
appreciate your brother i got it i'm
sorry guys no sorry i don't know
the rings it's all good
this is the show uh so i'm gonna get
that thank you so much for all thank you
let me know guys before you leave
remember what you told me about filling
the club and remember what i told you
about filling the club
i will never forget the analogy guys
thank you thank you thank you for being
in the sauce controlled
that was a good sauce control sauce i
like that
you love the sauce
um tell colin not to take the sauce
personally i do respect it and people in
chat he's entitled to his view thank you
for saying that thank you for saying
that
thank you and please tell him and tell
him yeah
i wasn't even like that trust me you're
good
probably don't even stress none of that
stuff yeah
trust
so we got to get it so quote eastwood
more than game play
massive news this week
what you feeling man quickly like your
thoughts this whole thing uh i want to
talk to you guys about something called
ownership uh-oh because that's one of
the biggest
uh complaints that i see with this
activision blizzard merger uh a lot of
people are trying to use like a value
judgment about how
things are grown organically or they
built them from the ground up or they've
worked with these studios for years
right
and so one of the things that people
continually say is sony builds their
games and they don't buy them
and i want to remind people that what
does it matter
where your games come from as long as
they're really good
and
when
i sat on the xbox platform before i
bought a ps4 for like two years i was
playing with five studios you had a
couple fords of studios a gear studio
and a halo studio and then another
studio that wasn't doing anything right
and so we all asked for xbox to bring
more games and they had to move
leadership around so what they've done
is they've invested a bunch of money
into the platform
and xbox is letting you play your games
everybody everybody can play their games
as long as you have anything but a
playstation and that's part of the
competition and so i i hear all these
complaints that uh you know playstation
you know they grow theirs organically
like house mark is amazing and house
mark was something a studio they've
worked with forever and they've created
games just for playstation and they
bought them and they consider that an
organic purchase
but playstation also buys
two to four
major exclusives on their platform every
single year from studios they don't own
and ips they don't own
and everyone's just kind of looked the
other way and i just think there's a
different way to spend your money xbox
did something for activision blizzard
which we
all know is better for the industry to
get them in a better place and get them
cultivated i'm working on a video right
now it's gonna take a couple days
breaking down what these teams can do
once they're actually
uh inspired and supported to do the
right thing
you know i think like 10 000 plus
probably almost 12 000 employees
are working under microsoft when this
all comes forward yeah and
this is the industry you live in if you
want to grow your platform you need
bigger games you need better games and
i'm glad i'm so glad that xbox doing it
and i'm also glad because it's pushing
playstation to go out and buy
studios they bought six and they bought
crunchyroll they you know they spent a
lot just last year so it's good to see
them
stepping up and both of them are going
to compete to make more games and i
don't care i have both consoles and a pc
here make whatever you want i'll play it
wherever i want no doubt i respect your
opinion w statement
let's get uh lord italian clowns then we
get brap quickly because i'll get i'll
go ahead and check your check your
twitter dude okay
god she got you um
something about the links about that
that joint no just twitter damn yeah
okay i gotcha i got it from yeah yeah so
um yeah so let's get brother lord
italian clients you want to jump in
really quick i hate to be accelerate but
we're getting towards the end so if you
could quickly say what you got to say
and then i can get brap in and then we
get towards the end because we get we
hit america
yeah no no no worries man this has been
the greatest episode i have ever seen on
our lawyers and chad is on fire first
off king let's just get this out of the
way king's always right he's never wrong
all right
getting past one dollar just hop in you
get everything right so uh there's a lot
uh there's two things that i think a lot
of people are missing here with this
whole acquisition deal and i think it's
important because um i've had execs drop
in my chat and they've said this
publicly so this is a very important
thing it's called the microsoft
metaverse right it's going to be huge
now saya said this five times during the
call about the deal the microsoft
metaverse bobby kotec said it four times
about the deal that this is about the
microsoft metaverse and phil spencer
said it twice during the call this is
about the microsoft metaverse and what
this means for microsoft is it's no
longer just
a situation of games right this is the
interaction of storylines universes uh
stories interacting with each other
we're talking movies tvs comics yes
video games we're talking cloud gaming
we're talking wherever game pass is all
this is going to be it's going to be one
whole entertainment thing everybody's
missing this on the second thing that i
wanted to say on this as well is that on
thursday this past week a lot of people
skip this news
but uh congress is working on a new
anti-trust bill against big tech every
company was mentioned except for
microsoft they mentioned apple google
amazon 10 cent and tick tock never once
did they mention microsoft but what does
that tell you it says that microsoft
knows what they're doing
there's no worries for an anti-trusting
against microsoft and this deal is
bigger than we think and microsoft's not
done this is just start of 2022
i've heard hints
possibly of batman so we'll see what
that means i don't know a hundred
percent if that means wb games but i
know that dc comics is in a lot of
trouble financially
and they need some help they need a lot
of help
so i just want to put that out there as
food for thought guys i respect it i
respect it you know
i hear what you're saying on acquisition
and perspective respect all that candy
crush background salute to you on that
but um
look let's get oh brad he's been patient
you know i got to get back in here man
last week supposed to be earlier but
we're still actually i gotta do it
all right bro he's talking about brother
i can't bro
i'm surprised y'all still like the fact
that chase and 3mg still in the trenches
chase
tell the people where they can find you
what's going on yeah i'm gonna grab some
of y'all for for uh some of our stuff so
let's do it let's just work let's check
out dms i appreciate y'all as always you
already know brother chase money salute
thank you thank you all for being
understanding technically on your day
yeah you know what i'm saying no problem
you know what i mean because i know and
we will make this right with y'all do
you know them cog intros and you know
what i'm saying we're gonna have you
coming through right yes it's just a
monumental day but brother thank you so
much man yes yes
brother
lord brad of the basement radio arcade
man who talks to me often we always
exchange thoughts
we agree with this great i love it i
love it no you know what that's that's
what's great about it like i saw the
chat earlier and that stuff's not cool
you know like we could all have a
difference between you but but
dialogue's great like having dialogue
learning different things different
perspectives you may have not had you
know look i had a tcl at one point
that wasn't it
if i
didn't have that dialogue
i'll never forget that would you buy a
series x for your kids
you can't do that right
look this is this is exciting news i
think um i think just across the board i
understand some of the concerns and some
really good points that colin brought up
and hogue and everyone on the panel here
um i think what's fascinating for me is
is the long game here from microsoft
clearly this is bigger than just xbox
right
they are looking to position position
themselves globally
in markets where they really haven't had
any luck japan asia the south pacific
and those are territories typically
where like
primarily people are gaming on pc
and mobile in those territories this
gives microsoft an avenue to penetrate
those territories and get into that
mobile pc space and it's something we
talked about um
uh the launchers earlier uh battlenet
yes uh battle that's a big a big win for
them because look
uh i think it was uh hustle we said
earlier like i was streaming using game
pass kept crashing i could never
understand how master chief collection
didn't work well on game pass but it
worked flawlessly on steam like that
just boggles my mind right yeah so maybe
this is an area for improvement but
what's fascinating is that microsoft's
pivoting and i hear about phil get a lot
of credit but this is not just phil
though think about this sacha yeah the
ceo microsoft he is all in i really
think microsoft looks at this as a once
in a lifetime opportunity
to kind of be the market leader in the
subscription based space creating this
new business model in the gaming
industry because let's face it they kind
of missed the boat the boat with mobile
os yes yeah you guys remember uh what's
steve
oh it doesn't have it doesn't have a
keyboard
steve you you were you were a little
short-sighted there so microsoft's not
gonna make that
uh the mistake again and this feeds
azure and that's what this is all about
and i'm interested to see
i think the silver lining in all this
too from a development standpoint is
what are they going to do with some of
these other studio like like raven
studios right are they going to be are
they going to finally let raven do other
stuff
um
yeah right um i heard you guys talk
about guitar hero yeah um i don't i'm
okay if if cod isn't a yearly release we
have warzone
warzone could be the platform i know you
about that war zone like you know you're
a move
so it's really gonna be interesting how
how they do these things and
obviously this is a big monumental
change in the industry i really don't
think sony has to respond um in an arms
race because look they're not going to
win an arms race against a trillion
dollar company i think they stayed the
course and i used nintendo as an example
uh when i was in an xbox fanboy many
many years ago you may have heard me
talk about this on brad you've told us
many times you were the first yes yeah
you've told us many times
yes yes but uh yes but uh i used to
predict the demise of nintendo i would
say oh nintendo does have an ethernet
port we just got an ethernet port on a
nintendo product this year think about
that we've got ethernet ports on
consoles for 20 years right but i for
years i said oh nintendo's not adapting
the industry's changing so much and
they're gonna die they're gonna be third
party i used to say this 20 years ago
look at nintendo now market leader they
and and the key the reason is they're
good at creating content quality content
content that's kind of exclusive they're
almost like column mentions they're kind
of like a boutique you mentioned that
the playstation yeah it's so they can
survive in that just doing what they do
in terms of creating great quality
content building you know continuing the
relationships they have with third-party
developers locking down content so i
think at the end of the day we'll look
back at this and we'll see
you know at this point i don't think
sony's gonna totally pivot the direction
of microsoft they'll probably at some
point incorporate
uh subscription like a subscription
service like game pass phil actually
this was kind of interesting phil
predicted this a week before that
announcement of the acquisition of of
activision he said i think sony's going
to have
a uh subscription service where they'll
put their games day and date and that
could be actually a way for them to kind
of respond to this yeah and build value
for whatever it is they're trying to
build but i don't think they're going to
go exactly the same path i think this is
the point where you see these companies
kind of diverge at different paths and
i'm kind of believing what phil said now
where he looked he said you know so he's
not really my competitor per se it's
more amazon i wouldn't even say google
wants any of this google's i think
google's they wash their hands with the
gaming space i understand the financial
investment it takes i think on the back
and then google's probably gonna try to
leverage their technology out to other
companies who might be interested in
getting into streaming or cloud or
whatever the case is but this is the
point i think where we kind of see these
two companies diverge maybe slightly
different directions
salute salute good take good take man we
gotta go niners by the way oh you
already know thank you bro appreciate
you though we got you so happy
real quick by the way my tv was
delivered
it wasn't off the floor
yeah you i didn't get it i i didn't pick
it up when you walk into the front of
the store
you're from game plan listen man we go
we get towards the end but i i know what
the last couple of topics is is it
wasn't but it got to be brief but i
would be remiss if i didn't get these
two brothers on and let's start i know
he might not be talking to me after last
sunday's nfl matchup but he's still my
level one brother he's still my love his
fix his face is twisted right now but
he's still my level one texas brother
vomit little fave entertainment
i'm so proud of you brother you're
starting to i know you're blowing up
because you're starting to get that good
hatred now on twitter that's what i know
you're doing your thing so brother i
need your opinion briefly just overall
what's your feeling man this thing this
is one of those moments right in gaming
listen i'm gonna be brief but yeah um i
hope y'all lose in the worst possible
way
i respect that yeah
i'm gonna be quick for all the lint
lickers because i got to watch my
language
wow
thank you sir
all the lint lickers on the underwear
upset about this
this is what you wanted
this is what we asked for we asked for
years of microsoft to be competitive
xbox fight back
xbox got no games right that was that's
been the narrative and we understand
that even though they might not
participate in it
these people microsoft they hear these
things right right
money rules the world
it rules the world there is no logical
sense when you say all right microsoft
go out and build from the ground up 15
studios that's not logical
it's not
now you can be upset that they maybe got
these big publishers but at the end of
the day
that's what money does
if i got the money i'm not going to go
and buy dr thunder i'm about dr pepper i
want i want i want the
i think this is the best thing microsoft
could have done
um i know people are saying sony could
counteract and that they should go bible
studio i don't think that's necessarily
the case and even if then
somebody that's got to be willing to say
i keep running rumors about oh they can
go by take two now if if activation was
70 billion you're looking at 150 plus
billion for for take two okay that's not
happening okay but at the end of the day
this is a dub i think people need to
realize and i uh shout out to fonz for
putting that uh that snippety put up
there these games are gonna be exclusive
i'm sorry i do understand what phil
spencer said but we have to read between
the lines you hear things like call of
duty you got to think warzone we hear
things like design i i desire to have as
many followers and subs
podcasts i don't i desire them
you know what i'm saying desire and have
two different things what we want and
what we get are two different things i
desire a lot of things you know i want
to win a super bowl this year it's not
happening i love that dave he's so
straight shooting bro
i'm just keeping it above 50. you know
what i'm saying so i i think
i think this might it might be a while
for anything else for microsoft but do
you really want to you really want to
impact the industry
and i'm going to wrap this up really
quick call of duty over the last 10
years
has been
one of the if not the highest selling
game right because the casuals love a
couple of games call of duty madden 2k
now if i tell a casual gamer hey you
can't get call of duty on playstation
he's going to go buy xbox simply for
that game now not every game has that
power but a game that is the highest
selling game no matter how much we crap
on no matter how broken it may be how
many issues we think it may have
it's still the highest selling game
every single year so little timmy big
rob neyman they all gonna go by xbox
simple because
they got madden they got 2k and they got
call of duty and for the most part you
look at madden it typically goes with ea
access a little bit a little bit past
half the seeds so that's free 2k goes in
there at some point so that's free and i
say free you guys know what i mean i
want to run up this thing oh game fast
ain't free you know what i mean and for
the most and then you can call of duty
every year for free that's a good
they'll get you a series this because we
know the pc market right now is screwed
up you're not gonna get no pc right now
good luck but you get you a series s for
the low low it might be 250 by next year
you never know and it's a win this is a
smart move by microsoft and this is
microsoft was being the monster we knew
they could be in the game industry we
wanted xbox that's what we wanted from
xbox one era yeah
we wanted this right we all asked for it
so again for the lint lickers on the
planet who are upset
that microsoft window activation it'll
be okay baby because the end of the day
if you want to play these games
on our platforms because most most
hardcore gamers we are on in in the end
but hey man i'm not going to hold your
time brother ricky
how much how much you paying for coming
to that music park you got a house back
there
you guys are awesome crap i've never
seen your camera before bro you cool
king last time i was on the show
together yeah almost at my house so we
got to make sure we look back up again
all the way that's good yeah fame before
you leave little
invite to the show i'll be there fam
before you leave what's that amazing
website and channel that you uh oh
listen you know uh i i i desire to have
as many followers
but
my design let you guys know that
lv1gamer.com is the site black on black
run uh and the youtubers uh lv one
gaming yeah look at the bird you see us
flying that's us we we're small we're
growing we just over a thousand uh to
start the year up and we're just trying
to do our thing man absolutely y'all
want to come and rock with us you're
more than welcome also i see you brother
man hey hey fam you already know what it
is pam you know we like family anyway
everybody in the chat right now i just
put the love of one game yeah do you do
your favorite castle
i want you to hit italian clowns put
your info out there
put
podcast that can have all these dudes on
it all mess with each other let's go
all right all right all right i'm back i
had to go get my phone okay
this is going
it was originally frozen
they call it this avengers end game
i got my brother i got my brother man
from speaking of ownership bx stand up
his famous state statement what is it
for the watch
and i want to thank i want to thank bull
who we got to 10k today everybody's in
here
oh yeah but everborn i i love you but we
we got to put sober straight because you
know we coming towards that final
stretch
so brother
tell me moment in time in gaming this is
one of those moments right we got to get
everyone's thoughts here
where are you at with this just in
general man microsoft the acquisition
so i i i think it was uh like thanos
inevitable right like we
we we knew this was coming we knew we
saw all these things going on with
activision we've all done shows about
the craziness going on in in in in uh
activision and and i think that uh the
only unfortunate thing about this thing
to me is that most of the oxygen is
getting sucked up talking about uh call
of duty where i i have i think that's
the least interesting part of this deal
what's more interesting is how they
integrate this thing or how they will
how they plan to integrate this thing
and i i
fundamentally disagree with any takes
that say um this is sort of cheating or
buying your way to the top because this
is not a slam dunk right in in
bethesda's case microsoft buys them
leaves them alone do what you do
bethesda be great here they are gonna
have to go in fundamentally sort of
restructure the culture of that company
and
green light projects that may not have
been greenlit before and in terms of
stifling creativity
do
we call game pass the netflix of gaming
has netflix stifled creativity in terms
of content or have they or have they
allowed uh mainstream creators to go and
create things that the normal studio uh
machine would not green light before
right so these are the things that that
that can happen and and uh uh level one
brought up that by the time this deal
closes the um
the series s may end up being 249 249
with call of duty on the box now before
i i just want to end on two questions
that i don't need anybody to answer this
is just for the audience to answer and i
said this to you guys in the dm yes
two questions
does sony
still want the marketing i know they
want the game but do they still want the
marketing rights where they remember
it's a co-marketing deal right right so
they would market alongside activision
but now activision is owned by microsoft
which means microsoft can also advertise
it and at the end of every commercial
say uh
day one and game pass for free right
right does sony want to spend tens of
millions of dollars to advertise a game
that everyone will associate with xbox
and being free and game pass that's
question number one and question two
that i will leave everybody with because
i know we don't have time to answer it
do we still think
uh
phil
spencer
or or
uh still
wants game pass on playstation see we
know that he approached them before
but that was from a position of weakness
when the the service was fledgling
right we're we're going to enter a new
period where competition is more stiff
and the benefits of game pass are the
ancillary purchases that people make and
they have data to show this what's there
they didn't have that data before
so i don't know that
microsoft still wants it on playstation
because they want the they they want all
the other purchases that people make in
that system to be in their ecosystem and
when if if that's an if if they're in a
position of dominance market share wise
maybe they don't want or need the
playstation thing right and the last
thing if anybody is afraid to remember
you got last of us two goes to sashimi
got a war in spider-man 2018 when sony
had no competition
now
some people say they're fighting they're
gonna be fighting for their lives i
don't think so but now what do you think
you're going to get from sony when they
actually creativity
and all right so i think this is a net
win all around that's it
bars
the part that i love that you said was
the second the last part too because you
know as a person who loves the sony
ecosystem and i don't feel like there's
enough more i always kill xbox for
hashtag just one
but hashtag kind of just two or three
for multiplayer you know that maybe this
pushes them in that space a little bit
in reference to now if if call of duty
whatever even if it's just in gay past
or multiplied or not but at great points
all right we have to we're coming
towards the final chef this is the
lord's you know anybody who has to go
you you can go if you if you have to i'm
not kicking anybody out um but the
lord's got to get their bars to finish
this this up right yeah i gotta i gotta
write bro but i i just wanna say real
quick
uh if we all agree that everything's
going towards subscription services at
some point in the industry yeah i just
want to say something future
future proof yourself go get a pc
that's all i gotta say it's gonna be the
best place ever board yeah let me have
that 3080 ti by the way you're not using
it
you talking that pc i respect it
uh catch me on uh wrap this wednesday
basically radio okay basement radio
podcast on youtube uh this wednesday
nine pm each time we're gonna have tim
dawg joining us
oh gee
yeah tim dog
that's what's up
brother have a go and have a go brother
you already know let's wrap it up with
the law
i'm sorry crown yeah
i gotta go too no doubt thank you for
letting me on and just remember one
thing
king is always right never doubt the
king
oh he'll kill the king clouds
we're not making shirts like that
before you go but wait did he leave damn
he left
oh man
he's still there
yeah promotion show bro where can they
find what's going on with clowns
oh man um you can find us at 4gq tv we
just made a deal with facebook oh so now
we yeah we got some stuff coming up
there
um and we have another marvel interview
dropping soon and i got to get you lords
on some of these moderators
thank you again and much love shout out
great episode thank you brother thank
you for coming through for your
perspective let's get the lawyers to to
wrap up attic you're back
it's been been it's been something man
it's been a show there but overall we've
hit every topic you know i didn't get a
lot of your thoughts on it and we got to
close this with the laws man so overall
where yet man any aspect
first off i want to point out so some of
these people in the chat when they're uh
they they trying to mutual my girl there
don't think i don't see that who's going
to be talking my friends in the chat oh
i see something
get your hands on hey be respectful be
respectful
[Laughter]
watch your chat game
[Laughter]
it's like i said like i do agree in some
instances that like colin and you know
that camp fare
i think i'm more on the the the road i
really liked what 3mg said i love the
three
i i i really like because i i'm i'm
right there with them and i've been
saying it
we have been on this path too long we
needed to change it up
and there was clearly nothing changing
and leave it to microsoft to come in
there not only with
the the aspect to
game pass that changed stuff up now they
buying pla uh they buying publishers and
they're changing the console scene up
where it's like now people don't feel
comfortable with stuff you know
mike uh sony's like i said sony's been
focusing and relying too much on call of
duty for the multiple for the
multiplayer scene and how many times
have we sat there famous bgc how many
times we sat there and you asked where's
the multiplayer for someone and they're
like go play multiplayer games about
that
you know there's no longer one of those
scenarios where
sony can feel comfortable not tackling
that genre because they can rely on the
third party because at any time
big buck microsoft could pull up and
just snatch that whole publishing unit
out so now i feel like you know there is
i i do feel like sony is going to be
looking at that a little bit more
they're not going to rely a hundred
percent on third-party stuff and i kind
of like how microsoft shouldn't rely on
third-party play people to get that just
one like you gotta have diversity in
your lineup regardless because you know
microsoft don't got to necessarily worry
about that when it comes to sony but at
any time someone like google could show
up and be like this company's gone
and then microsoft would have to worry
about that stuff you know facebook
reached out to
to activision first facebook could have
reached out plugged activision and call
of duty could have been away from
microsoft and sony
so it's just like look like we we live
it around where these multi-billion
trillion dollar corporations exist
you got to keep them in mind you got to
be able to realize that look you got to
move with the times sony had a very big
emphasis on
i'm a worry worry about my stuff and i'm
a
time exclusive out everything else
and
let's be real microsoft got tired of
that
they're like oh you you you don't you
trying over there you're trying to get
star filled not happening you try
obviously they couldn't get some of this
stuff are we tired of call of duty being
a thorn the moment they had a chance
snatch not happening you know uh the
resolution wars snatch not happening
with the xbox one x like microsoft has
literally been taking chess pieces away
from sony for years and i feel like this
is one of those things i look it's like
i told cognito
in a realm of worst case scenario for
microsoft call of duty's on game pass
day and date and on playstation yeah and
i think in some ways that actually works
better for them than making it exclusive
because
there's a real world like the 70 30 no
it's not even a 70 30. called imagine a
realm where me and uh jabari are paying
to say wow i don't play card but let's
say i played cards me and carl me and uh
jabari are playing the same game
but i'm paying 15
for a subscription and jabari over there
paying 70 dollars how many years do you
think jabari get tired of that type of
scene like all i'm saying is like when
you come across every year where it's
like it's not the best place to play
call of duty it's not the best place to
play the big third parties they're
losing a lot of performance issues are
around the clock like
sony has the response and
it sucks because at the same time that's
where i feel like mike that's where i
feel like colin's issue is because he
knows that sony has to respond and
that's gonna lead to more responses more
publishers being bought and before you
know three to four people do own
everything i do think we live in a realm
like that you know where we see it right
now we see it in the tv realm disney was
everything that was a good point but but
at the end of the day
has that led disney making worse movies
it hasn't that's good i feel like
it's an argument that you can make to
the more consolidation that happened in
the movie industry led to a better
product in the end okay because we saw
the marvel universe come out the way it
is we're seeing the star wars units
regardless whatever born likes coming
out the way it is like
sure i do think
my personal self it has hurt some things
in the movie aspect
but now i get more excited for movies
for more tv shows and for years
especially in the tv scene
these networks that you guys watch on
you know whoever owns like you know
cable tv and satellite they're all owned
by like eight people
there's not a lot of competition there
that you may see just because there's
individual channels i think it's good
and i think we're gonna see a lot of
good responses you know i i myself are
getting tired of the yearly call of duty
installments it's up in the air we can't
act like that's going to get changed off
the bat we don't know
we don't even know if the deal is going
to go through i think it's going to go
through but we don't even know if that's
going to go through but you know when
you're releasing some of these studios
and you're not letting them be too much
force you're giving them creativity
sony's have to respond in their own way
so if it is exclusive non-exclusive
they're going out there in a realm where
microsoft isn't being aggressive you're
not getting these studios making
multiplayer games from x destiny devs
you're not getting sony even really
going into the multiplayer scene
whatsoever
you want competition this is competition
good for the bad it's still competition
and that's all i got probably the
biggest deal too okay no
i hear it's also it should also be noted
that the mcu is kind of saving the
theater industry which we thought a lot
of people thought were going to die
um so
something to think about
in terms of that analogy let's get
started you've been patient so
after all the the points and the topics
and your overall assessment
let me point out let's hold it real
quick let me point out the restraint
that we've had y'all
and all the lords that kept it together
to you know
obviously because we had the respect
that we got you know what i'm saying i
this is a lot of discipline for all the
lord god
shout out to you for juggling all of
this except for me i've been
like king get his bars off
the realm demanded it
so uh first off uh
thank god everybody's gone now now the
podcast can start all right now we're
ready
yeah
no no no no but but thank thanks to
everyone who came through uh this was
amazing yeah yeah um
so
my take because i i interjected we've
been working on that all week we've been
highly working on that all yeah
so
their moments i'm gonna be long-winded
so that's oh this is you this is you
there are moments
that we live through in history that
sometimes you don't realize they're
historical in the moment you just don't
you don't see it until it's ten years
down the line or whatever
as people who pay attention to the
gaming industry
we know how monumental this has the
potential to be right
and when you look at the landscape of
gaming as it stands now
there's no one else who could have done
this
in the way that they did it simply
because
and this is me being 100
selfish
i don't want the future
that google has in store for us in the
gaming space i don't want the future
that amazon has in store for us in the
gaming space i'm selfish
i want the big three players that we
have now in the space that we know and
love to be able to thrive
and for that sort of thing to happen
this type of this type of sort of
consolidation if you want to call it
that has to happen in my opinion
with
microsoft and xbox
playstation
and nintendo to me
everyone else is only in it
to push technology
thinking they can make games right we
already saw what happened with google
and stadia yeah
they just they jumped into it face-first
like all this great tech did not
understand and which is weird because
they got a bunch of gaming people to
sort of helmet and they still couldn't
figure it out
luminous all right
i know you should take a shot at me
but it is true it it is right
they failed to understand the work that
goes into it and that it's not a quick
and easy book it's not that
right luna by all accounts
better better but at the same time i
don't know that that is the future that
i want these three have been in the
space
they've grown contrary to what other
people believe microsoft has taken bumps
on the chin and knows full well what it
is to try to adhere to the status quo
and try to
beat sony at their own game and it not
work so i say all this to say
this after 20 years of getting punched
in the face
as xbox
what did you think was going to happen
what shout out to that dude that made
the phone call
what you sent us that link called what
what did you think was going to happen
microsoft played the game right they
played the game and a lot in a lot of
ways because through their own fault
they stumbled and fell right
and they but at the end of the day even
in the generation even in the generation
where they basically had it in the back
they came out a year before the
playstation 3 with the 360. they had all
the best third-party exclusives
xbox live was on and popping in a way
that playstation couldn't hope or dream
to do and forget about where nintendo
was at that time
and at the end of it they still couldn't
overcome it for gay forget about the
fact that you had a red ring of death
and all that it couldn't
so they played the game
and they realize why am i gonna continue
to adhere to the status quo
if i'm not going to be number one you
always play to win you never play to be
in third place you don't play the
winning
play to win the game and they had to
change the rules in order to win that's
a fact they realized that so the moment
the moment satya came out and put his
arm around fell and said we we in this
together that was big
that is the moment you should have known
merch yeah we're in halo merch that has
been remembered we remember the terry
myerson things exactly exactly where it
was like you're over here we're over
here yeah i didn't believe it in the
building
now
microsoft's way forward is xbox's way
forward they go hand in hand
so
now
the talk around oh this is bad for
gaming this is i understand colin's
point because i'm oftentimes the old man
yelling at the clouds i am you know i
don't like i don't like change i love
what i love right
this is not
if there is anybody who is going to come
in
and now be the stewards and caretakers
of i don't know god knows how many
classic franchises it's microsoft
right if there was anybody who was going
to come in and be able to in one fell
swoop
attempt to fix
the s show that is going on at
activision blizzard it is microsoft
right
and the thing about it that people
haven't talked about is the fact that
phil spencer has put an absolute cross
hair on his head oh for sure
he has to come through with this right
that's the beauty of it though right
soft because to me the pressure's on for
you to perfor you got to do the right
thing to perform you have to be like
hogue said like i said they went out and
they want to look the greatest in this
they want to look like they're the white
knights of all of this but at the end of
the day if that stuff doesn't come
through and the actions you're taking
fire
exactly you bet the farm on this you
really did bet the farm on this and
that's what people aren't seeing
so
when you look at
everything that's going to happen there
that i believe is going to happen there
in terms of change all right activision
blizzard will have
all of the leeway in the world to make
the games that they want to make right
they're going to have that
we're going to see classic franchises
come back in a way whether it be in back
compat
or whether it be new installments the
fact that i can get a remake of a legacy
title that they don't own tend to they
don't own attention
bro
but you can remake tinju
you could do that it's bonkers to me the
fact that i can see these sierra games
all the freaking
on in game pass is crazy to me the fact
that
the remnants of the teams that made
metropolis street racer and project
gotham racing could possibly make some
sort of arcade racer in the future is
bonkers to me this is all stuff that is
gamers we should care about we i've seen
a whole lot of white knighting soapbox
uh about
the the integrity of this move
and the fact of the matter is that the
industry that we are in in this today is
not the one you're talking about in
theory i can i could i could oppose this
a hundred percent i get it i would
in an in an ideal world
i would like everybody to be able to
make money hand over fist and not have
to adhere to anybody else's rules and be
independent and everybody live in
harmony i would desire that too exactly
100
is that the world that we live in no
that is a hundred percent not the world
that we live in any more
there is no other company
in a better position
to
take
this acquisition and make the very best
of it that we can expect
than microsoft and there is just there
is just no other there is the
alternatives are tencent the
alternatives are netease the
alternatives on amazon alternatives or
google there is a number of different
ways where this all goes left for gamers
i
uh 100
it it's good to question everything
right that's the question everything 100
but at the end of the day
this is a net positive
[Music]
there
we've seen it
i know it's hyperbole but this is a
paradigm shift
that we're only seeing beginning to see
the trickle effects of when this
actually goes through and we see what's
going to happen again we're assuming all
this great stuff is going to happen of
course
this is awful
my desire is all of this
as well
but i absolutely think the discourse
online about where this can go
is is is amazing and i love to see it
yeah
but i'm sorry
but a lot of the fear around it i think
is 100 unfounded and you're not looking
at the realities of where we are today
as an industry if you do that
i i think there is no other way this
goes because again let's real quick
there's no reality where activision
blizzard fixes their problems from
within and
that was my ball when it was gonna be my
point because i was gonna say is
even if you're opposed on every
fundamental level and you don't like
consolidation and you don't like where
the industry is going
what's the alternative what is your
would you destiny leave blizzard or
something yeah like bro i was gonna give
you some dusty balls you just set me up
like yeah because i think yeah yeah i
was gonna say because at the end of the
day destiny my favorite game which was
under that umbrella
made arguably in gamers eyes one of the
best dlc since taking king which was
forsaken right that dlc was beloved it
was high quality content from them
activision up top
said we are not happy
we are not happy with the success of
that we expected more also as a destiny
fan i'm from the day where they were
forcing not forcing but encouraging them
to make destiny 2 way earlier than it
was supposed to people attic knows
rise of iron was technically when
destiny 2 was supposed to come out they
had to fight in the ballroom and say
look for the health of the studio
we need to push this back we need to we
need to be able to make another deal a
smaller content and then we can do that
so again it goes to show you with luke
smith the head of bungie
after the board meeting with activision
disrespects them and says look this was
a disappointment even though it was a
colossal i mean it was a great success
it maybe it wasn't call of duty success
let's just say right
and he says
luke smith on twitter publicly says i
stand behind forsaken i do not look at
it as a disappointment that was a direct
challenge to the brass
that's when i said oh this is about to
get this about to go it's about to get
ugly it's about to get ugly and i'm
electrification but i do want to say
that because at the end of the day you
know we have a situation where that
building is on fire
that you've got discrimination
you've got racial things going on you've
got rooms you've got someone that lost
their life
yeah because their pictures were shared
around corporate totally disgusting
right you have all these things going on
and and
you have a situation where said leader
tried to buy media influence whether it
be a pc gamer or a kotaku to twelve
the building right so my thing is if you
don't like what's the alternative yeah
well
yeah
bobby coltic is the archetypical villain
like and he leans into it in a way
that's almost comical i'm like i cannot
believe he really tried to do that when
you think about the influence this man
has on this company
this man went and he decided he said
okay i own all of these ip
what am i going to do i'm going to try
to find a way to commodify
these ip
into yearly franchises that you purchase
like you're purchasing toilet paper
like it literally he turned it into
a freaking it's a sweatshirt an assembly
line an assembly line
yeah and it and the thing about it is
that was never going to change let's
make this point abundantly clear if
someone doesn't step in to fix this
activision blizzard was going to crash
and burn right yeah
and for some people maybe that is what
they want maybe if you say okay i like
the status quo and gaming i want to keep
it that way
you know what darwin's law survival of
the fittest they weren't fit enough to
survive let them crash that's it let
them get chewed exactly or or
as a gamer who doesn't want to see these
franchises completely die and go away
you look at what microsoft is doing and
the thing is and when you speak to it i
think when we when we look at the xbox
platform right and we think about what
the plan for game pass has always been
this is much bigger than an xbox console
this is much bigger than
game pass is their way to to achieving
ubiquity of the xbox brand throughout
all of gaming this is much bigger than
that so when you look at it
a lot of the arguments i saw it felt
like they were they were very small
arguments in in in terms of the bubble
that is nintendo playstation
exactly exactly whereas microsoft is is
saying i'm eliminating war
this is what we're doing we're
eliminating war and
in 10 years we'll find out we'll find
out
that's what i would say let's just see
what i'm king i gotta i got to get you
yeah
all right um
i'm glad that he said darwin's law
i'm glad that you said that because um
survival of the fittest
i was so sick and tired of microsoft
acting like a point guard when they're a
center
you know um just because you see allen
iverson as shooting guard uh slash point
guard or steph curry and you get down
with the flash and you get that
substance that sony's given in
you you are the big gorilla in the room
stop operating in that same manner that
they operating
make them change the rules for you
they changed the rules for shaq
they they changed everything and and be
that disrupted that you that we know
that you can be
and for a long time microsoft was trying
to figure out that i i
the identity
and it took somebody
that that's from the essence of the of
the corporation
of of of
the blue collared worker
it took that person that had pride and
was looking at everything that was going
on and was like i could fix that it took
that kid that had that gleam in his eye
that dream in his head
i can be the best
there's always somebody in that
basketball court that's shooting
and saying i could be better than mike
that has that belief and it takes one
person to see that and believe in you
and and give you that that push that
that that knows who you're gonna be
feel dominance maximus are really
expensive i say it to say this and i say
it all the time man you give that man
his reverence because it was a point in
time we was at dep's door yeah don't
ever forget that part where they were
talking about selling off the brand
because the brand was tarnishing what
microsoft is had to she had to prove
value
them in that team had
i told you guys before when they when
they purchased with there's the
zenimax i gotta stop saying but that's
the because that wasn't it they went
inside they didn't go buy a pair of
jeans they went and brought the store
all right so i told you how my man shop
bruce wayne style yeah
and it's
i like it in all those colors as i look
good in his style he's that dude
right so when i go in and and you you
can you you can
see
that when real recognized real like when
you see it
i didn't believe in the dude until i met
him
but i can look into your eyes and
understand the conviction when you grab
my hand see it's a different way you
grab a person's hand you give a grab a
hard firm handshake
you could tell a lot from a man's
handshake he give you that wet noodle
he gave you that firm handshake and he
pulled you close like i really want to
know what you think about this
i said man these dudes are in good hands
mm-hmm
he's going to die trying he's going to
get richer dodgers
so so that's seven i told you all the
stuff i said the next thing they're
gonna do i mean they're gonna get a
publisher and it's gonna be big
i'm thinking ea yeah that's the last
thing i'm thinking it's in the game
you hear me cause i'm like everything
leads to this
because i know
madden
2k
or call of duty
moves the needle
every year every year so
y'all remember when we had call of duty
we had the marketing rights when it left
a lot of dudes left too
right
that's when the rise of the playstation
4 started happening and dudes is like oh
my god
now they talk about the playstation 4
because remember
360 had him on smash right
we lost that marking deal
so every time we lose something phil
phil fixes it
we lost power
it comes the one x
fix that like attic said chess moves off
the board people didn't want to connect
but that's why what error was get it out
of the box interesting yeah
get it out the box we don't need it shut
it off like oh it won't work get it out
the box can it work can we get this to
work without this thing yeah we good get
back those resources that we wasted for
no reason
just built the whole movie studio shut
it down shut it down get rid of it it's
not worth it right
he did it
for the health of the xbox brand because
he believed in the brand
now we got power they took that call of
duty he saw that and said you know what
i want y'all to remember this because
this is this is the part where it comes
back to bite you you took the marketing
deal you took those games you locked us
out of that that content that we were
enjoying for that period of time and now
you won't have the game i don't care
what happens when your contract runs out
so does your water so it's over you
better get another resource you better
go back to your room yo what's that
resistance you better get something
going because it's done for you and if
you want to play that game then you're
gonna have to worry about getting
yourself some uh uh oh the world at war
some just just play something else but
that that game for cog
that hashtag just won for cod oh oh yeah
starcraft ghost
let's go baby let's bring that back hey
one other one what what about pitfall
what about marvel ultimate alliance what
about your fault
possibilities oh my god the
possibilities are crazy i want starcraft
ghosts i feel that
i want that game that i was promised
they got put in the bushes
i want that and when i s when i said i
said let's go
this is it i am so happy
at this moment and you know dudes call
you a corporate shill and all this other
stuff
i game in the microsoft ecospace because
they make it great for me
right and i have a playstation here and
i can play over there yeah and i don't
turn it on until the exclusive shows up
so how about this how about i just do
this right how about y'all just go away
and we just get your games i like that
idea i like i like your exclusive games
the stuff that you do best because i
don't want you to become hollow and
soulless oh here we go yeah i don't i
don't
i don't want y'all to be
trying to keep up with the joneses i
want y'all to take your time make your
games and put it inside the microsoft
ecosystem you too can be part of game
pass or
if you don't play nice we buy
your things
so king real quick there's one there's
one thing
i disagree with a little bit
is is the call of duty situation right
because i think that i we live in the
matrix anything's possible now
in my mind anything's possible now yeah
i don't see
right the game pass argument on on that
platform i don't see just because i
would think sony would want those to be
downloadable games like
you're getting in theory you're getting
an inferior product just being able to
stream the xbox games not play them
locally right so let's say phil's like
okay cool so you want to keep cod okay
cool you keep cod we'll make a version
of cod specifically for playstation this
is a special again we live in the matrix
anything's possible
but he says
i want the marvel games
it's possible no it's not it's not
impossible they work with them jim ryan
is a money man and he's down with all of
this i mean hog laid it out right a lot
of this is the basis for negotiation
also as well so and and the thing is
anything that we consider to be the norm
is out it's not the question yeah
let me get my balls on it we gotta go
look man this is the moment this is yeah
it's crazy um this is a moment this we
we cannot
lose sight of this is definitely a
moment what regardless of what happens
in the future we don't know but i think
we for the most part are in agreement
that like what's off said this is a net
positive considered what the alternative
is i got to give king his flowers in
reference to phil you know not that i
didn't believe it phil at all but
the the reference that you had that they
see that he be as influential to turn
the situation around because let's be
honest i in my mind
peter moore was the goat and i'm saying
it was you know saying only because
you know we understood his thing with
the sega and we understood being
aggressive and really taking it to sony
and being competitive to space with xbox
360. but in this infancy stage already
right the xbox series x and s consoles
are maybe one year old to have let's be
they positioned themselves after the
xbox one error they've positioned
themselves in such a consumer
friendly
position right you want to talk about
the power okay fine you want to talk
about back compat you want to talk about
smart delivery you want to talk about
all these features then let's be honest
even uh some of us were questions like
are these buzzwords or are these really
providing value auto hdr
all these things we've had json we've
had these people on and what you see is
when we saw the opposition right
what would they do oh there is no back
compat that oh we're going to charge you
for this or you know the things start to
come out and then with the transparency
right no they're all corporations we
understand that but we understood the
transparency with the generation talk
and them saying oh no we're going to be
here for about a year and then we're
going to transition i say all that to
say this they then package it with let's
be honest is one of the best deals in
gaming period you can't dispute it you
just you cannot dispute gameplay like it
is literally now whether you choose not
to indulge because hey you're a physical
games lover or you have your personal
reason that you want ownership or out of
fear that it may leave the service that
is valid but from a pure value
proposition
one company is giving you a lot of value
that you can't dispute so the thing that
i get upset with
is you got to look at yourself as a
gamer first and how is this benefiting
you
see people are looking at i understand
the long term and i understand concern
but i'm selfish i don't know about y'all
it's this fake moral grandstanding is
like listen
come on i listen microsoft could run
themselves into the group that's their
business that's not my problem
if they go out doing this that's their
business but my point is as a gamer
what does the value bring to you what
does it bring to you right i understand
looking down the road but the reality is
that's why i use an analogy of sports i
could sit here and scream till i'm blue
in the face lebron did this he bought
this he bought that it does not negate
the championship
it does not negate the ring
it that's the game that's been playing i
could hold on for dear life you know
saying and just say hey
i'm out the game i don't like where the
game is going right now that's fine too
it's you know what i'm saying but i got
it
it's got to the point
where
it's not a matter of
what i i just
phil spencer is definitely the best xbox
yeah is that
that's why
and and it's not even a debate on that
anymore you know what the debate is is
he the best ce like gaming influencing
executive that's ever been the key right
now
is the deliverable
of the games and the quality down of
acquisition because the problem with the
xbox one era is they had all these
second party third-party deals but they
didn't have ownership
they didn't have they didn't control
anything they would there was nothing
pumping from them and i am of the firm
belief i don't believe me personally i
don't believe in this purity talk
because to me at the end of it even if
that is the k even if they know nothing
about games let's just take it face back
let's say they don't
isn't a sign of intelligence working on
your weakness
isn't a sign of intelligence saying you
know what i am deficient here let me get
some creators and some people that know
how to do this and guess what we're
going to give you creative crow law
podcast has had every one of these damn
studios on this podcast for most part
343 obsidian ninja theory
compulsion you name it we've had it
we've given them the tough questions yo
are they really letting you in the
building do what you want are they
really
is it because
let's be honest we hear things like the
corporate overlord the tendrils whatever
whatever that's what goes back to my
point we're hearing it from the ground
level we're in the streets we go to
these shows we go to these packs we
speak to people offline
undead we speak to all these people
they tell us no cog it is what they say
it is
so who am i to question that when i see
the resurrection we had on that we had
um
obsidian all we literally
you know what i'm saying now it's up to
microsoft to continue operating as that
but my thing is what's the alternative
we want 10 cent coming in here censoring
games
yeah no no trans people no gay people no
black john villega removed from disney
on the journey what do we want
what are we doing so it's like at the
end of the day i'll take this
alternative any day of the week now it's
up to us to put their feet to the fire
and make sure they follow through with
everything they say absolutely it's okay
to criticize it's okay to be critical
but what i'm trying to say if i look at
the whole
what activision and all that stuff was
going to be
after prior
and without anyone jumping in yes i'm
taking microsoft seven days of the week
so that's where i'm at and the last
thing i just say is look man you know at
the end of the day
i think the last thing i like and i'm
not even a cod guy like that i used to
be like i used to be that dude but i
know the importance i know the
generation that comes before me that
that's the game they buy every year they
don't care they get in that car i
understand the casual influence i know
that the power of it but what i like is
where they lost me was the annualization
i'm like nah y'all just throwing a
little skin here oh now you're just
doing this you know what i'm saying
there's no as well cog yeah much to your
point much to your point call of duty
itself the reason we all
simmered down and stopped playing it was
because not only the annualization but
there wasn't any
there wasn't any real um change nothing
yeah it was so much they all sort of
look the same they all sort of feel the
same yeah it was just like you're not
innovating that's why i i gravitated i
went to a titanfall one year i went to a
battlefield one year because i'm like
okay at least they were trying something
different you know what i'm saying but
it was just so hard and i understand the
financial aspect that it's such a
moneymaker for them to analyze but for
me when i when i at least hear the
discussion internally what we're seeing
yo
we're thinking about not annualizing
this thing we're thinking about you know
raven and all these guys and sledging
like allowing them sometimes maybe to
buy annual and then make those classic
games that we used to love to me that's
a net positive y'all i don't understand
how that's a bad thing those are the
games these are beloved friendship when
you hear this where it feel really
resonated with me when you hear him say
yo i want to see these franchises that
come back i have a personal connection
that's that's real that's that it's
about games at the end of the day so
look
i hear everybody
this is a fantastic show
my love y'all
man this is y'all made me cry because it
was like man i can't believe what we did
today but this is for the culture this
is for the culture and we're going to
have people we agree
disagree we're going to be respectful
but um yeah man i i want to thank y'all
we got super chats the real one but um
dodge
ricky he's still here
awesome i love y'all man i love y'all
and this is why i love gaming man i love
this stuff bro this is this is this is
good discussion so hey this is just like
two seconds right a lot of the moral
grandstanding that you are seeing is is
because people
look at these things through the frame
or through the lens of
uh of you know the
the playstation way of doing things
is correct so when you say when you when
you've decided which which is your
favorite platform and a lot of us do
that and then say well what they do is
the right way
and anything that is not that i agree is
wrong wrong and i think that's where a
lot of this comes from and we we are in
this world right now and i i hate to say
it but this is what sony built sony
locked microsoft out of content they
needed content and this is the only way
they could get in sony used their
position in the market we've seen what
they did in the epic trial we've seen
what they did to sort of lock out to
make deals more expensive for xbox to
make they use their position in what
they had just like the ownership right
or the whatever licensing's right they
have with disney for spider-man they've
used what they have they use what they
got to get what they want we know what
that means yeah right and so now
microsoft has done the same thing and
the only thing to be afraid of is
whether sony revenue wise will be in
second or third place right that's the
only thing that's on right that's on the
line here other than that i think i
think um it is good and i think
microsoft has officially they have an
identity now right they they called him
the shooter box before that was a joke
it's real now oh yeah and and rpg box
now
exactly the moral grandstanding is
because you have a lens that the way
sony does things is the right way
i don't even think it's that too i just
think part of i mean i think part of it
is that i stand corrected i agree part
of that is that but i also think part of
it that's why i use the jordan lebron
thing it's just
this is where it's going
yeah this is where it's going you know
i'm saying i can hold on as much as i
want
but this is where it's going i'm still
listening king teases me i still listen
to hillmatic
king is like yo little such-and-such is
out i'm like
these kids
it's like it's new to me i don't relate
to this new stuff and maybe that's a
sign for certain people not you know
what i'm saying but that it's just not
for them if you don't like where it's
going
wake up call this where it's going
it like that's that's good yeah it's
like you in or you out and that's a lot
we could talk forever you know what you
know what i'd you know what i had from
uh a point of view and i always loved to
get point of views from the casual
players and i've got a lot i've got a
lot of friends a lot of friends just
from working in general
that are very much casual players and
the only thing that they said on the
acquisition of acquisition of activision
by by microsoft
was well hopefully they can make a
decent card yeah they weren't concerned
that it wasn't on a playstation or
anything like that
the concerns that we hear from the loud
majority are just
like it was at the beginning of the
generation and like it is every time
when something like this happens
is it's just trying to justify
themselves why they spent their money on
a plastic box and the fear of that
plastic box that they've invested in not
having something because it's part of
their identity yeah
that's the fear yeah i wanted to
tag in with that one just to say like
and that was the importance of this
whole situation like remember like it
was disgusting how to remove myself from
all those like twitter yeah back and
forth but it used to be about which
console was more important we kind of
like lost where games were just under
performing and releasing terribly and to
where even they were still blaming a
console for the game not being not real
and we got everybody got soul loss
including myself when removing yourself
from that i feel like the the more
important thing now is in this whole
cast here and as well as everybody
watching is like not one person here
gloated about
anything particularly being exclusive to
a platform but more so because it
started affecting the games that we like
yeah it's like dude we just want our we
put our trust in this particular you
know business or corporation that just
fix
the 10 years of a lot of missed
opportunities that's all i'm looking for
man absolutely brothers well i thank
y'all
so we got work to do yeah we still got
work
we still got work
no no bro i just wanted to say how proud
i am
of everybody this that was on this
planet
my the team like this is incredible the
fact that we basically kept everything
as simple as possible i can understand
people sort of you know we have we have
people in our chat who are just straight
up xbox fans and they were not trying to
hear what colin was saying um and i get
that
but at the end of the day colin came
here to talk to to give his point of
view and for us to sort of bounce off of
that it was never going to be an attack
on him on what he said
exactly so not exactly so and and the
fact of the matter is that he made a lot
of great points and he's coming from a
he's coming from a position of
thinking the way that i think it's like
change is hard
i know he admitted that he admitted that
he admitted that he said he specifically
said myopic so yeah what i want to say
is like
to to all the admins hustle
thank you slow all y'all
slow you guys lg thank y'all today yeah
you guys are superstars
today was an absolutely
as special as this moment is this
podcast is a special moment in and of
itself i am so proud i'm so proud of
everybody i was so proud for show for
sure let's get the joint on uh what you
call it um
yeah it definitely was that i just
wanted to say shout out to the mods and
thank you to the chat just for being
here in particular um i know things get
a little chaotic every so often man but
that's pretty cool to see shout out to
slo-mo um we have fame we have forte on
here
we did that
that's right hey and i'll just say you
know i don't know if y'all watched the
everyday struggle that you showed up his
own complex it used to be on camera
but that this was my young jeezy moment
like sometimes you can't really say much
but sometimes you just gotta sit and say
nothing to soak up game that's kind of
what i was doing and i really wanted all
of our guests to excel like you know
it's great to see 3mg great to see dutch
it's great to see everborn it's great to
see everybody here who i interact with
on twitter and y'all make sure y'all go
follow everybody i'm gonna put my
channel in there put your channel in
there brother put your channel in there
bro you did that's right
and it's okay to agree to disagree
civil respectful
[ __ ] that's what it's about man and
indeed you know you know one last thing
yo shout out to y'all like
and i'm glad foreign was on here like
i'm super clever
ghetto yeah
incognito i'll say this to you you know
we say it behind the scenes all the time
but shout out to you for always you know
pulling your people back up dog like no
matter what no matter what what the
sound
crosstalk doesn't matter like it don't
matter for real but you always make sure
you go back and get you never forget
about laura brown or little assists in
them so i see delilah in the chat you
know gmg i see y'all and i see gwg in
there it's a lot of people the attic
show yes i'm there too so if y'all want
to see me and get more of my perspective
on this whole thing uh
we're going to get the work on tuesday
bro
we got to yeah we got it yeah i feel a
lot better than i did last week indeed
let's get to it let's get to it business
oh dutch outros ever born outros ricky
outro
anybody up
i'll go first i'll just say like yo
thank you guys again
um honestly this was this was beautiful
for me i didn't even realize how long we
was live i've been chilling
[Laughter]
i would've probably been just relaxing
doing nothing anyway so this is
beautiful man i appreciate everybody
here
um again my name is just 3mg live
everywhere
everybody
we got to get something going again
because this is my type of vibe you know
what i mean i look back at like the last
10 years and just even from
how i was viewing games then and
endorsing and like the weird toxicity to
now and i just i love the space that we
in
um me me chase and i we speak about you
know iron lords all the time every time
we reference a group of guys who even if
they
have a brand that they support they
support everybody so we just we got a
lot of love for y'all man
thank you thank you thank you brother
appreciate you man
the ever born saga we're going to find
people find you
so i'm ever born saga everywhere that's
uh
instagram twitter um youtube also
everyone so i just put that in the chat
we uh king is a is like an honorary
guest on that show we do on the real
that's coming back in february and we're
gonna do some creative content because i
know it's a lot of people that's out
there trying to do a little bit of what
i do which is create comic books and
worlds and storytelling and things like
that so i want to do some videos to kind
of show how people to get into that self
publishing when does that second book i
mean that book [ __ ] man
oh that's coming out february i got it
that's a month early it's supposed to
come in march but the lettering we like
35 pages into the letter what's this
type of book that you can do what is
this
beautiful that's the ever-born saga so
we basically create the mcu of fantasy
and uh manga all mixed together right we
got four series well there will be four
when when the remnant drop i'll show you
guys that later it's not out yet but
basically it's four series following
four different characters all telling
the story in the same world and there's
it's crossovers and things like that so
it's basically all of my favorite things
going up which is anime and manga and
and and and how the the connectedness of
the mcu um and and sort of sword and
sandals fantasy so it's all that in one
and we put it together and and i've been
i've been telling that story for about
three years now and we're just trying to
expand and we're working on the game
that'll come soon also so it's it's uh
one big smorgasbord of uh a universe i'm
trying to love your brother trying to be
the black child uh george lucas that's
what i'm saying your creativity
is amazing you know i love what you're
doing you know
as a person of color to see
entrepreneurship and to see the
intelligence and what you're doing out
here is really inspiring and we always
love sporting you and i was glad like i
said we got boom on who
gave us life hit 10k you know what i'm
saying he hit
look how things pay forward right you
don't say like he gave us a shot with no
one else and got us to 1k we blow up we
get him to ten then that introduces me
to whatever born in the dutch and it's
just a it's a beautiful thing and
hustler just it's dope and it's dope i
love to see it you know what i'm saying
but i gotta i could be remiss i didn't
shout out my brother the wondering one
himself
dutch of the midweek fat fox
midweek mix-up podcast yeah i love dutch
because
sometimes being dutch no decree
but the way he had do certain things but
we really agree actually we do agree i
just sometimes i'm like damn that'd be
going hard
you know
but you know what people go hard but
it's like you know i love the passion
and i want to give him his flowers we we
talk a lot behind the scenes and i love
him as a consecrated been on the show a
couple times he's been on here brother
talk to the people where can they find
you what you have going on and thank you
thank you for coming and being
respectful because i know how passionate
you were about this subject and to see
you come in with the poise and humility
and conduct yourself in the way you do i
love to see that bro so talk to him
yeah definitely i definitely go hard
sometimes but i try to go hard
respectfully
i don't i don't directly attack people
um it's normally the situation i attack
which is a bit different
um but no i appreciate absolutely
appreciate it um i come off the back of
my own smaller podcast on a sunday now
um jumping straight on here let's go
what's the name of the podcast sir
podcast
midwife
day and time and what's going on what's
the record yeah so we've got we've got
wednesdays and it is uh
2 p.m est um for the american time 7 p.m
in the uk
um and now sunday's as well at 6 30 um
gmt um obviously 1 30.
as well and that's a smaller show that's
just to wrap up some of the little bits
that we don't get to on a bigger panel
on a wednesday
um i've i've i've been in the position
where you and i hats off to you because
i know what it feels like on our
birthday show last year we had about 25
people on yeah
and that was just insane to handle so i
appreciate that
the way in which you conducted this
today with the amount of people you've
had on is honestly it's uh it's
something to be
of awesome short thank you for letting
but
proud
me get my bars off getting
oh he said it yes
we got just to save bars let's go
thank you for that no appreciate it and
great points by everybody as well um
chat like you say for the most part have
been absolutely awesome um you see the
few a few little
questions and questionable characters
here
thank you for moderating that
yeah
outside of that um absolutely awesome
always a pleasure to be here and some
amazing guests and of course if
everybody isn't already following
everybody that has been in today then go
and do so it's great to hear a point of
views from every angle not just an xbox
guy not just a playstation guy a piece a
pc everything
um get the viewpoints across and and the
way you've conducted it is applaudable
and much to what uh everborn was saying
about boom hitting 10k
yeah same same for yourselves though
he's much like yourselves you you've
also engineered and helped us go to
where we are so far um over 1200 subs
for us um
but yeah it's i'm i'm trying to kind of
model on the perspective that you are
going and i think obviously i want more
conversations around the business aspect
of it as well
planning bigger things
but always a pleasure i'm going to drop
the links to our please
here in a second and uh
thank you so much
again to everybody today and now hope
you have a great rest of the evening to
everybody that's watching no doubt
solve do you need to i can do a pull if
you need time to pull up no no i i'm i'm
ready because i'm essentially scrolling
all the way back up all right i just
need i just need um i need a kick to
mirror me um because i they came in so
hot now you man let me let me read the
poll though
let me say something real quick um
we we are starting to stream more on the
twitch channel so definitely go over
there and uh
uh i put it in the chat go before be
sure to follow the twitch channel yes
there yes please there you go so look
while y'all queue up all the chats
there's gonna be thousands um
the new poll with the massive
acquisition of activision blizzard by
microsoft which outcome do you think is
most likely to occur in the future
choices are a microsoft consolidation of
multiple large studios feels
monopolistic and not good for the
long-term health of the games industry
b microsoft's acquisition is a positive
step towards saving activision blizzard
work culture reviving dormant ips and
providing more value to game pass or c
i don't care i still desire to talk
about call of duty's exclusive or
non-exclusive status for 18 months
salute to all the lords in the realm we
had to get that off it is up now so go
check that out on the iron lord podcast
twitter account go check that out solve
we got business everybody else feel free
to rock out if you have to because we
got a bunch of homework to do with these
superheroes we got an insane amount of
homework so hold on man i'm trying to
help you as much as i can what's the
first one you're gonna read hold on one
second i'm getting paid right now so we
got three
yeah good luck robert robert robert
robert braswell five dollar could chat
aka brooklyn nets one
okay
that is the first one i'm going to read
okay and that's after and the thing is
this might have jumped because i i have
it after 3mg's uh 100 super chat um but
it may not be actually in that order but
it's robert braswell mm-hmm
okay yeah i got it okay okay i just
control f look forward to i think with
the c now i just peeked that he's
ridiculous
and just just just keep an eye on if i
see see we got one more coming at the
end that was a mistake i didn't mean to
do that i was typing too fast but i can
do that
okay so uh just remember decado five
dollar super chat is the last one that
is on the actual chat that just came out
no actually there's another one that
came in afterwards so yeah i'm looking
at this i'm looking at the new stuff
yeah keep your eye on those because i
it's just too much going on it's crazy
um we got robert braswell five dollars a
chat aka brooklyn nets one finally able
to listen live with football over very
proud to support and finally become a
member
being a new york city boy had to support
thank you absolutely
yes sir
necromancers ale five dollar super chat
have been waiting for this since the
news broke
i i hope we delivered i hope we deliver
then we have colton yoder five dollar
super chat and with nothing to say but
of course yeah i can say something
anytime super chat please say something
then we have x atticus with the 10 super
chat i'm surprised i haven't heard
anyone saying the only thing that can
probably say playstation as far as
services is spartacus being the netflix
partnership
i said that before yeah king actually
put that out the energy out there
and that's still on the table
then we have lucious augustus five
dollar super chat shout out to the swami
himself he told you xbox has something
coming that must have been early with
those toast ones
he's a barrier those are what the masks
out
yeah i'm definitely not gonna be able to
keep up with you you're all over the
place
so i'll help out when i miss when i miss
just jump in because
you missed a lot but i don't know if
you've copy and pasted somewhere else
and it jumped me when i wrote back i
probably wasn't able to because they
were gone
so uh five dollars from dirt griggity uh
2017 five studios to 20 we said that
no no no okay
20 22 32 studios oh my how things have
changed got to find out you picture from
underground gamers sony boonies got
caught lacking in that school bathroom
fight now they on this cl the ground
sleeping and
i'm not saying that long lift king long
live oh julius center very very we gotta
find all this trap from davie
just remember
96
phil carl de sony went like this all
your base belongs to us
in memory of the sega
mega definitely kings bars
yeah then we got a five dollar switch
from king one supreme get my man dirt
griggity and sean on the show dirt
working on
and my next one is lord metroid two
dollar super chat you have that
no not even close oh jesus i know i got
johnny phillip
uh so we got bret uh we got a two dollar
super shot from brett bringingham
king now needs an hour to do his stand
up we got a two dollar super chat from
earliest gt phil spencer xbox i am
inevitable
we got five dollars super chat from four
uh
thank you phil for letting mlk talk all
day it's time we appreciate the gesture
and xbox is the goat we got a two dollar
supercharger from everborn saga
for the watch i knew that you got a five
dollar super chat from cinderella i
don't know we're gonna move past that i
woke up late get ready for work and the
podcast is still going half the night
almost i
will get to hear iop we gotta fight 50
kr super chat i don't know what's
currently as we're gonna move past that
from jake and novan what disney brought
to uh two century the us government
forced disney to sell something they
owned to be available to get the deal
wonder if microsoft needs to
we got a five dollar superstar from kay
johnson hey fellas i have no idea who
kay sean is i'm a woman but shout out to
that dude though
gtf
keyshawn
okay so now i'm up to
where
um
r kelly said that man i got to say it
that was right you walked down yo we
actually
you remember the last super chat you did
before you went into this
no the did you get the
did you get what was the last one you
did before on the last set
what do you mean from the last set the
last set you read before the paul before
we took it oh it was it was lucious
augustus five dollars okay you go ahead
and read all you have
it was a shout out to the swarm himself
he told you xbox had something coming
for you yeah okay lord metro five
dollars of track king who played sky
resort at 480 that was two dollar super
chat and that's where i am that's where
i am right now let's go okay okay keep
going and we got no idea
i played that
at 480p yeah that's right you're right
that's true i beat it though i beat it i
want to point that out
then we got lord roughness five pound
super chat hello lords phil's in the
streets i got that game pass joey even
the switch crew looking over
[Laughter]
there we have colton yoder 10 super chat
cod that's why he said god that's it
right all right you think about it
then we have ford's a legend two dollars
super chat if they die they die oh the
book of acid ivan drago quote
[Laughter]
shout out to drago oh there we go who
know matt i'm just gonna say five
dollars super chat i don't know that
currency
hey king you got this jacket for free
with the tcl tv greetings from
switzerland that's disrespectful are we
covered in my bed
that's what's up
[Laughter]
uh king uh go ahead and say your bars he
has to go okay oh yeah no no it's just
i'm we got a lot of kicks
with the turnout um
you know from dutch to ricky uh to to
everborn to boom to to everybody and and
the fact that we were able to uh help
boom uh reaps that threshold to be
honest with you i think that's something
amazing i think you guys in the chat or
something amazing something to behold um
and you guys all week long was waiting
for sunday it was waiting for you bro
like every other day bro i was so proud
of you with that because they were like
yo bro where he at where he at
2k
in the chat watching
dude i remember when it was 2pm oh
you know what it was i i i was texting
my wife
it's 2 000 people like crazy a lot of
times if you see me cutting through
first of all i don't have all my boiler
so if you see me wearing gloves or if
you see me cutting out and i'm i'm
blowing my nose because there's
hell down man i'm down in the basement
but on guarding them
you guys give me heat yeah
it was only and and and this this is
this is the truth like
two people to 2k
you know
that's some absolutely humbling thing
yeah humbling crazy crazy you guys are
amazing and and there's nothing
i'm speechless they showed out bro they
showed up
during the you know
i'm getting emotional during the whole
show like they didn't nobody knew we had
this this cast of people coming through
so literally they were coming to hear us
talk yeah
and then and then to be surprised by
other people coming through like king
they were called they were coming for
the smoke baby
you know it's just
it's all about games it's all about
jokes it's all about fun
and and and and like i said when you
when
before the show started i was going to
give you something to laugh about if you
had a friend with a weak blood please
and i was going i was literally y'all
put so much pressure on me during the
week and it just kept building and kept
building and i was like what the hell am
i gonna do and i went through the closet
because i had to get a scully i was like
i keep my head warm
and i found this joint that i had got
and i got this from um going to one of
those shows
and i said
i got it
so i didn't none of this stuff was
planned all the stuff is organic yeah he
off the verge of off the top with it and
i love you guys and i love everybody
here man
we gotta hook up catch a movie together
again brother
um hustle
always the hard work is it's it's
magnificent ricky that room i could just
chill in your room all day i could just
chill
yeah that's crazy thank you man
dutch
i'm so happy to be on the last episode
of the year for um a weekend mix up um
please uh you guys go over there support
just support everybody you know because
like i said when when those the sales is
raised i i lost words man
when the water's raised i know everybody
feel good whatever
when when the deal went down king was
the first person i called yes
and it's and it's a big deal that i'm
here that's why i wanted to make sure i
came here today to to to talk about this
thing so it's it's huge and i just want
to definitely take a moment to give you
guys your roses because a lot of the
kickstarter success and and just people
knowing who i am and what i'm trying to
do here you know it started with boom
and then that connected me with you cog
and i was always a fan of the show
before that so to be here to just be
like yo i could hit cog up in the dm you
know and then be on the show randomly or
i could just call king when the
acquisition goes down that's a big deal
hollywood over here you know it's it's
crazy man so i shout out to you oh
brother
listen i gotta i gotta get there bro we
got these super chats we got you i love
you you put your work on i'm gonna get
out of here
always love
we got wolf of darkness with the 18 uh
uh arab uh
they're durham's they're called durham's
18
uh what's up podcast i'm waiting for
this podcast king please please please
show no mercy
he did not he didn't do that
and we got sin jutsu sage five dollar
super chat cog remember what i said
about a certain other company microsoft
isn't finished they just got to keep
their nose clean for now but it's gonna
happen
they can't commit any crimes time
and we got brett bingham five dollar
super chat filled with jim ryan on july
1 2023 you know how i said i'd keep
called on playstation i lied
then we got spartan go 17 two pound
super chat unleash king
in game pass spartacus d.o.a
then we got eagles fan 76 five dollar
super chat i desire for microsoft to buy
e308 they already have e3 it's being
changed to p3
then we got corey hell member for 19
months thank you sir activision blizzard
acquisition plus 49ers win in lambeau
awesome week
then we have splendiferous remember for
four months
did my man the non-believer just play us
a clip of him saying buy activision
turn off in on that
thank you thank you
i was all in on that one pause but sony
was seeing them bushes in the psvr
that we have the last war two dollar
super jack king said the last
playstation yeah that's right
he'll be consistent with that we'll see
then we got louie's revs and rides two
dollar super chat
live that promo live
from the shop
absolutely salute him
we got a lifetime of a lifetime supply
of salt now yeah there's a lot of stuff
there i gotta say
there we got thx 1138 10 super chat phil
spencer should promote microsoft cvp
sarah bond to new role as ceo of
activism blizzard should keep microsoft
vision going and clean house at
activision blizzard that is going to be
interesting if they do keep
some kind of hierarchy there that'd be
that's interesting to see
royal boyle 785 super chat what's good
lords always here to support my guys
have a beautiful day
that's the homie that's new york that's
that dude
or something too he's actually from the
town
then we got rain g4 two dollar super
chat activision has left sony text on
scene
[Laughter]
then we got governor grimm five dollar
super chat some people just want to
watch the world burn king wants to watch
the world burn and bathe in the ashes
light them
we get caught into that you notice that
exactly you get jake marshland five
dollar super chat the most important
infinity stone in the xbox gauntlet
blizzard tears of joy battle net with
the pc gp game pass catalog next ubisoft
by facebook slash oculus bet oh my god
i'm going for it all i'm going for all
of it i think
spartan ghost once again two power super
chat failed the gym on the phone so how
you doing playboy yo
by the way who do you think called who
when phil all right who called who we
did
that's what i wanted yeah that's funny i
could see jim calling him like mother
effer
jimmy he called him
6 18.
man we all land at this point
my wife is drafting up the the divorce
papers these people
handle that we got robert braswell five
dollar super chat aka brooklyn that's
one dancing jim can jim you can have cod
and that knee and continue the borg
assimilation and put game pass on ps5 we
hear good we eat good over here hashtag
xbox
that we got hustle and motivate remember
for 15 months hit the like button let's
get to 1k likes please we got the like
fourteen hundred i do believe that thank
you
wow that was what bruh sixteen hundred
sixteen
like this that's a beautiful thing
beautiful thing then we have dirt
griggity five dollar super chat 2017
five studios to 2022 32 studios oh my
how things have changed yes paradigm
shift i think you finished all right so
yeah you know you could skip that and go
all the way up to
jacob
because that's where i was so uh har gi
chinese 5 super chat how long before
those ps bangers release on xbox game
pass i have that that's my god okay so
let me find out where that is
let me just read up to you tell me where
that is okay because this is everywhere
i don't know what it is it's although
dude it would just it you yes they were
coming so fast it was ridiculous
it would be okay yeah okay keep going
okay that's after all r kelly keep going
you're okay so hard get your knee okay
so hard get your knee five dollars super
chat how long before those ps bangers
release on xbox game pass phil you want
cod i want god of war spider-man and
horizon and game pass
we will see then we have neo mental five
dollar super chat king is gonna remix
major luck screaming xbox
then we got bret bingham five dollar
super chat
uh iron lords podcast jamaicans and ryan
holding on to them chicken bones like
king willie off of predator 2. wow
i don't know
who's jamaican jim i don't know who that
person is who is that
we got emma boyd saga two dollar super
chat my only question is how many segas
did this cost this caused a whole bunch
of saying it's like when the deal
happened that's all i was saying this is
cool
but it's not safe
yeah i actually put on twitter i said i
ain't gonna lie i wish it was sega
so that i would have been glad to be
glad jiu jitsu fifty ten dollars will be
chat so many guys saying xbox guys only
talk studios not games studios is
talking games love you guys thank you
sir love
likewise don't worry if we write rhymes
we're at checks
jesus all right all right okay
then we have lucasfox 10 super chat
listen to the bethesda acquisition
episode to prepare for this show when
king said that you guys hadn't seen
anything yet and that phil had one more
big move to make never bet against the
prophet
it was true
then we got smitty smith five dollars in
a chat remember when xbox was down but
then microsoft said on your left
it's hilarious they literally did the
last seat of end game with all the
studios it's crazy
then we have clayton st sire five dollar
super chat phil has become the almighty
spencer in my eyes salute king take your
w no doubt then we got rain g4 or five
dollars we chat microsoft taking
everything including the ice cubes out
of the ice trays
[Music]
then we got black rodent member for nine
months king is like phil spencer's real
talk interpreter like
a keegan key for president obama he did
this
then we have assembled with the five
dollars
yes that's our boy as king said last
week little money can't play with big
money that's for sure
then we have to put the crush in the
chat for zenner white welcome to the
realm sir put the crust in the chat
whoever's left
here we got shafiq baxter five dollar
super chat phil de soni the price of the
brick is going up
wow these are good
we have the forgotten dumpling with a
hundred dollar super chat love that last
on the playstation you're funny
when's the last time microsoft game won
game of the year should have won this
year microsoft is selling gas station
cupcakes quick cheap and no flavor while
sony is making prime rib takes time to
make great things you can half cod and
crack down for all of a sudden cod don't
matter now
yeah can i answer that really quick
answer that really quick cause we got
perfect dog coming we got
we it all the other studios that me and
adam constantly talk about we got all
that other stuff coming so i don't know
you you can't really respond to that
yeah yeah
and i was upset when when there was some
street fighter so yeah that was that's
stopped being so narrow-minded thank you
appreciate it
we got bigger five dollars from that
uh to think i think microsoft can still
acquire by sidestepping because they are
more than gaming wb and bandai namco
both have been rumored to be working on
killer instinct too we will see
then we have doofy five dollar super
chat phil dominance maximus aurelius
spencer in the mf building in three
years the fatality will be a take-two
acquisition
sega remembers
then we have lady infamous gwg in the
house five dollar super chat shout out
to chase ricky the lords and everybody
in the chat let's go niners
you already know what it is ready go
where y'all at
no doubt no doubt then we have hargie
cheney 20 super chat
sony's in trouble sony's leverage beyond
their value over 2 trillion in debt
activision blizzard king will hurt
people want playstation to buy a
publisher but that's more debt whole
lending money when microsoft says
they're all in this is what you get
what did you expect then we have
keyshawn thompson five dollars
y'all need to talk about the possibility
of apple buying sony yes like colin said
it could happen
then we have zenner white with the four
pound 49 pence super chat next buy that
would make the most sense in my opinion
is capcom with crystal dynamics plus
tomb raider as the icing on the cake
anything is possible we live in the
matrix then we have uh quarter global
with the 3 900 something i don't know
what that is but thank you
i appreciate that phil said sony is an
important part of our industry which
confirms taking away call of duty can
damage sony which may set them up for
downfall and might ultimately hurt the
industry overall
then we have blah blah blah with the
five dollars
blah blah blah blah
blah
five dollar super chat why do you think
day one content on xbox game pass works
but day one content on hbo max doesn't
work
then we have smitty smith five dollar
super chat sony fanboys microsoft is a
monopoly me we'll get your punky ass off
baltic avenue
oh my lord oh my god monopoly references
thank you thank you appreciate that then
we have baz gaming with the five pound
super chat with microsoft buying
activision maybe we will see a spiral
four or prototype three in addition to
other things that sounds great
now we have jd gamer with a hundred
dollar super test
i see knees in the air knees in the air
great entertainment gotta respect the
truth that is sovereign and king are
both nostradamus
prediction
sony will become a niche console maker
not the first choice not the second they
will become hold on secondly scroll over
they will become the afterthought locked
in the closet shout out to jd gamer for
constantly being objective i love you
sir
then we got k mega 10 super chat let's
go rams what microsoft xbox did wasn't a
monopoly it was just capitalism at work
absolutely
can't hate the game the wise old game of
five dollars for chat phil singing young
ralph is a young ralph a young dolph i
don't know what yeah
when you see me switching lanes in the
bubble gum range on them all set wheels
man guess guess what i did i bought that
yeah
i think xbox will use fomo making cards
exclusive for a year forcing sony fans
to buy a console or subscription to
gameplay that would be crazy if if they
still take it away for a minute
no that you there's a year exclusivity
where they're always a year call of duty
behind you know that that would be
hilarious
that would be hilarious being is that
any time the exclusivity on playstation
is essentially exclusivity for forever
because
you get a new game every year so
then we got warlord 10 15 10 super chat
boomstick kept shouting out a fellow
smaller channel and i checked them out
that channel was the iron lord's channel
yes sir
i've been here ever since congrats on
10k brother no doubt brother love you
brother
then we got michael mooney with the five
pound super chat what about the sony and
nintendo rumor
i think that's just a rumor i don't
think
i mean but again we all know it's a
fluid situation damn we don't know what
everything is
um just real quick um back in 1994 that
was supposed to happen
yeah that was that as well sony exists
because that didn't happen and they went
oh yeah they made it happen on their own
yeah
everything everything
was like pepperidge farm so you might
not let that go yet
not yet
then we got viper xt five dollars super
chat congratulations boom one hitting
10k no doubt yeah absolutely then we
have cowboys fan 404 10 super chat
microsoft doing all this buying go ahead
and buy the dallas cowboys we need a
cultural change too
hashtag we ate them boys
then we got viper xt shout out to him
put the crush to the chat so welcome to
lord bronze coming in absolutely thank
you sir then we got k mega 405 put the
crest in the chat for the homie k megan
welcome to lord bronze thank you sir
then we got gsd aka getting stuff done
with the five dollar super chat how do
you guys feel about microsoft not xbox
doing this acquisition and using these
studios to help develop their version of
the future metaverse uh the fact of the
matter is that phil spencer helmed
all of these meetings
he was at the front of both of these
acquisitions so phil spence is in the
building it's not satya making these
moves it's phil
then we got slobo backslap five dollar
super chat boom help me hit 1k while
live on breakfast with boom i absolutely
love watching him hit 10k live here with
the iron lords this community is awesome
yes that was a beautiful moment
then we have lord saying 50 super chat
thank you for all you do gentlemen love
the guests and the chat paying my dues
for the next few months thank you ladies
and gentlemen i think i said lord say
ladies
ladies saying apologies then we have jd
gamer 5 super chat i want to see a
commercial with crash and spiral at
sony's headquarters with a megaphone
daring aloy and spiderman to come out i
want to see
where i am
i know you're watching this is the idea
i would like them i would like to make a
spiral and
um crash game like somehow they're in
this i think
i think it's a vocal closure i do i
think that they're going to have you
you're sitting on a gold mine for optics
let's be real i think man there's so
much there's so much possibilities crash
as the use crashes the mask all the game
packs they could literally they should
that's the scary part
and i wanted to mention that earlier too
um
they it's a family-friendly super family
friendly console now so you know they
got those those ips and what's the name
of that company that's over there um
choice for bob yeah they got something
to really do over there because i did
some research you know just upon before
even coming on
high moon studios and a bunch of them
everybody just went to call of duty
exactly yeah and you know yo shout out
to phil spencer really changing the
culture like eric bishop out here though
he really changed it
they really going like because we we're
seeing them we're seeing other studios
just flex and just work on whatever it
seems like they want to work on that's
that's like good for the creativity so
you know shout out to callum but i think
he had mentioned that earlier yeah i
didn't want to cut nobody off but no it
was a good point we phil kind of ran it
was like not enough we're going to
change all that and we've seen it
already we've already seen it so
you know i don't think they're going to
deviate from that plan so shout out to
them for that man
i'm looking forward to it
oh yeah for sure we have the professor 5
super chat with all the characters xbox
has we need to smash bros for xbox yes
the potential with the ips is there yeah
that's for sure then we have m marquise
20 super chat last generation xbox watch
sony take a ton of exclusives including
street fighter 5 xbox decided to go full
nos esco unless sony know your arms are
too short in the box
we doing the ball okay okay let's go
bless flows you know me okay i remember
that one oh baby i am mike five dollar
super chat somebody knew something
didn't forte have a tweet of a girl
trading in her con edition ps4 for xbox
before the acquisition was announced
then we have segment murray three dollar
super chat thank you so much for please
say something appreciate that
then we have
lady boom herself joseph rivera 50 super
chat thank you so much ilp and this
awesome gaming community for helping mr
boom realize his dream much love misses
boom
thank you so happy that i'm so happy at
10k whatever yeah
that was the most beautiful very
stupidest thing that could happen it
happened fast too quick he was like
three minutes three or four minutes and
he added
i think it was that
nine nine three or something and that
i'm joined it just went
then we have necromancer zale 20 super
chat here's a question who would you
like is as next for microsoft wb with
the fear series and mortal kombat ea
with titanfall and dead space you'll be
solved with assassin's creed series and
rainbow and rainbow series sega with
their legacy ip at the exact same thing
with the legend
the the correct answer which this
gentleman didn't include take two
take two jesus we see myself not playing
no more so hey look they they pulled 16
68.7 billion dollars out of the shoebox
they came in the lock is hot don't
hustle the block is hot yeah
[Laughter]
we got nc ghost of lord five dollars
super chat took a break from playing
tomb raider on the backlog to show some
love to the lords on the lord's stage
just to watch king flex game pass book
of x no doubt then we got my favorite
will bogaki
it drives me mad when people cry foul
over consolidation of the gaming
industry will at the same time tweet
about how much they love the mandalorian
one division and excitement on x-men 97.
rahu was saying about the
a lot of hypocrisy
then we have brett bingham five dollar
super chat jim ryan calling phil spencer
acting like the seagulls off of finding
nemo about cod and third-party
exclusives mine mine
then we have always cola five dollar
super chat
sony seen his heroes controlling what
happens to games slash ip they don't own
street fighter 5 or 6 potentially final
fantasy 7 remake spider-man etc
microsoft purchases basically says what
gone george
then we have pragmatic eagle five dollar
super chat salute to the laws for always
fostering peaceful discourse
disagreements are healthy folks they
allow you to grow thank you very much
very well set
then we have lucious augustus 5 super
chat last gen sony was stopping xbox
from getting games how was that brick by
break i support uh ss but i don't agree
with colin and sacred symbols but i
don't agree with colin here rose-colored
glasses yeah he's speaking from a
personal point he said that as much yeah
he said it
don't know taco 5 chap i like how colin
acts like playstation started off
homegrown they money-hatted their way
into the game was actively killing off
competition
i'm gonna move on
let's just move on
then we got the rubber nah five dollar
super chat i'm a bit late to the show
just wait just wait till take two comes
over they said we the salt will be
overwhelming yes if that happens then we
got jb golden 5 super chat i remember
when microsoft got torn apart for
getting rise of the tomb raider
exclusive yet now that sony does it it's
okay somehow
yeah a lot of conversations happen clap
clapperdan
xbox stop timed exclusives in 2015. it
didn't start until this gen sony began
at the same time with call of duty
through now stop capping calling they
were not happy with calling americans
that's why i'm glad we had them
exactly like you can't be an echo chain
man got it it can't be a different
perspective
lord nader 10 super chat when sony does
a timed exclusive they kill the audience
on xbox etc final fantasy and persona
kill a jrpg kid have killed the jrpg
scene on xbox and the side effect is
developers don't want to bring jrpgs to
xbox because they don't have an audience
that is very true and that was the plan
the whole time yes
that is the plan and that that's
business i ain't even mad at them
because of that just it's not your
friends yeah exactly at the end of the
day like i go back to what did you
expect
then we got brett bingham five dollars a
chat colin talks about microsoft buying
without thought and says it's uncreative
is it creative that sony micromanages
what their games and their devs make no
okay that's an assumption but okay i get
it
there we go i'm sorry yeah exactly then
we got jb golden 10 super chat another
thing when microsoft did times
exclusives it went for the time it was
supposed to destiny one on xbox didn't
get its last dlc until destiny 2 came
out because sony extended the time
period look at ff7
remake yes that is true uh then we got
gas five pounds super chat
colin you have been a proponent of timed
exclusives that have proven that have a
proven track record of being damaging to
the industry why the apathy and
guys have it's your beginning
this is concern here
then we have faisal 007 with the 9 pound
super chat xbox purchased bethesda which
they had an old relationship with since
a long time ago these studios sony
bought and worked with because only two
main consoles
all right then we have mr wolf
four pound and 49 pence super tan i
think it would be interesting to see how
sony would behave if they had the
pockets that xbox has at the moment let
me clue you in on how they would behave
they would have done the same thing
that's just fact xbox saw blood in the
snow they would have done worse because
it wouldn't have been no we intend to
keep anything on them yeah it would have
been like i will pay the fine you're not
getting it that's it yeah for sure
then we have some jutsu sage five
thousand chat if microsoft had no plan
for activision why did microsoft partner
with timmy studios same studio that
makes cod mobile for activision
microsoft has a plan
yeah we'll see
i have spartan ghost 17 five pounds
super chat respectfully disagree colin
sony isn't buying uh because they want
to sell organically built games they
haven't because it's too risky and they
got comfy yeah that's one way to look at
it then we have clapper dan once again
10 super chat xbox built up playground
undead coalition 343 rare old rare left
every indie team xbox bot is building in
exile is building in exile compulsion
ninja theory double fine all building
xbox xbox made time to build up devs wow
we need some punctuation here sir but
thank you clapping
basal 07
four pound 49 pen super chat can colin
tell us from where he got that microsoft
has no plan with activision people
really really is this was exciting
yeah we know what part of the podcast is
microsoft is a big company every step is
calculated
then we have dono taco five dollars
super chat sony third person narrative
adventures feel as stagnated as card
releases
man that's i like that take
some jitsu sage
timmy studios is owned by 10 cent
microsoft partnered with them in may
last year they make cod mobile with
activision i disagree with colin on no
plan
then we have mr irishman member for
seven months wonder if spider-man and
final fantasy was brought up during
phil's phone call to jim about the cod
situation hmm just like i said
you never know
we live in the matrix
mike 10 super chat oh my god i'm dying
right now
second party games are still games that
sony paid to keep off of competing
platforms if we just talk games over the
last two decades sony has kept more
games from competing platforms than
anyone else i would say that probably
makes sense
then we have kendrick starr ten dollar
super chat colin's fear is over
exaggerated no way home proves that
people will pay for quality content even
though the window to streaming is
shorter than ever fomo for the next big
thing will never go away that is true
then we have sage once again five
dollars for chat did colin just say that
playstation plus collection is better
than the entire lineup on game fast see
why i can't take him seriously
slow down
this is all in the past but i will say
what he means is like they're all sort
of aaa titles in there as opposed to you
know he's talking about quality-wise
like in his opinion god of war is better
than anything that's in game pass stuff
like that
yeah he's still opinion based but yes
yes disturbed by children
then we got jonathan b remember
coming back into the fold hey guys let's
just all chill out and go play candy
crush no doubt i'm playing that on my
phone right now hashtag who did that for
you love the show guys check out the
fighting duke yes sir check that out
then we got warlow 1015 5 super chat we
handle colin with kid gloves i respect
it but he's not being intellectually
honest he ran as soon as gaz opened his
mouth no
that's not it he was going to leave and
and
the point of handling him with kid
gloves like we said
he was we we wanted him here to express
his opinion in a forum that was going to
be respected hold on hold on hold on
hold on we're not going to be attacked
we can't act like just because we don't
attack someone viciously because we
might disagree with their opinion
like that is that is absurd
like we we we we get at you guys in the
comments section for doing the same
thing so why would we do what we we
always
do what we put out there like we put the
same energy that we put out anything
else so if we're telling you to respect
people why are we not yeah why are we
supposed to cut them off not let them
get his ball and say yo you wrong
families like calm down it was never
gonna be that it was never ever gonna be
there if you thought this was gonna be
like i said somebody's supposed to get
jumped
over here like it's not that type of
party bro we're gonna let everybody get
their perspectives off regardless and
then with the lords we had to wait
respectfully for an epic type of show
that this is for us to go at the end to
truly because otherwise that no topic
would get complete because everybody
interjected back and forth saying how
they disagree and agree with this and
that exactly yeah exactly at the end of
the day you can disagree on how we
interact with guests and you could say
it's quote unquote uh
whatever that that that said
kid clubs like we just first off that's
the reason people feel comfortable
coming in here they know we can have
engaging conversations why would we be
like what do you mean calling and now no
no we're coming back
let's call it a book okay that's why not
to be disrespectful but that's why a lot
of certain content creators get
frustrated when they can't get to where
they want to get because they don't know
how to be respectful they don't know how
to disagree without being disrespectful
and the minute we see the disrespect
you're out of here so that's how this is
always going to run so i apologize if
that is going to be that's not what
you're looking for i'm sorry this is not
the show for you if that's what you
think this is continue yeah no doubt
then we have mitchie pooh
shout out to the iop log that love what
you're doing with this community first
time i give money to any show and shout
out everyone in the chat
spitting facts and counterpoints exactly
that's what it's all about
then we have splendiferous two dollar
super chat guys i appreciate you bro get
him he talks reckless yeah you know what
he does talk reckless but i love the
fact that he stands there and takes this
i love it love it
ladies saying 50 super chat this is for
gas and hogue responses to colin's
arguments colin's argument is a lot of
feelings disguised as objectivity call
out his nonsense gas and and and hoag um
yeah there's feelings there and he
admitted this feeling's dead
he did what he did
again a lot of what he says makes sense
those feelings right yeah 100 percent
so 100
you know what i'm saying i don't think
he was trying to mask it as objectivity
he did say like he says he specifically
says if you go back my myopic view
myopic
that's me selfishly what i want yeah i
respect that you can't be bad at that
100 percent
jd gamer five dollars for chat shout out
to jazz on camera xbox two going all on
camera that'll never happen
shout out to jazz that red filthy red
filthy rags
oh man i love red it's a joke
yeah we got clutch man 01 5 super chat
loving the show the only podcast that
can seamlessly rotate 12 other podcasts
during their own podcast in between two
other podcasts they're about 18 to 20
sir give us a little while
oh man then we have
mandingo brexit
super chat wait so it's perfectly fine
for sony to lock out content for years
yet the fact that microsoft buys a
company that was fractured it's suddenly
bad how many spider-man games that were
on xbox are now gone
we've not anymore not anymore most of
them were made by activision
let me take over
no no i'm good okay
you said a minute ago he was gas that's
why i don't know i'm good i'm i'm
getting there but don't worry about it
then we got nuisance nuisance five
dollar super chat
xbox do it bad sony do it good miss me
with that bs
then we got bad dingo mcthickens once
again
five dollar super chat loris i have to
say it's okay to be respectful so to
keep it a buck colin was arguing with
feelings we know his history feelings
are not facts but he admitted as much
sometimes sometimes guys are busy
like replying to stuff and not listening
to what's being said thoroughly right
yeah i know you're listening but listen
thoroughly you will see that that nuance
was in what he was saying
we got atl member for 12 months thank
goodness
is the united nations of gaming podcasts
yes we are
it's my mind the geneva convention right
here
and we got brad word fight seven dollar
super chat rapper
yo king remind everyone who did this for
you
oh he did yeah he did he did
then we got the rubber knob 20 super
chat if this deal does not go through
the industry needs to be aware microsoft
got 70 billion to drop personally i
think it's a bad purchase i feel
microsoft could get so much more studios
ip for that cash
then we got one bad mother five dollar
super chat
appreciate how iop sets the standard of
respectful dialogue of differing
viewpoints within the community and
king's monologue stickamon
one bad mother we tried man but this
chat wants us to go extra all the time
then we got donald taco five dollars
speaking of crunchyroll ask colin what
he thinks about sony's consolidation and
monopoly of the anime market i bet his
knees i bet his knees he don't care
again he probably doesn't care about
that stuff like he's got to be at evolve
with it
oh then we got elemental p.o
someone told tencent google and amazon
to stop microsoft's sesame cake
and on another note nights like this i
wish rain chops
with the heartbeats the 5 heartbeats
let's go
leon boy
yes then we got black road at 3 5 7 5
super chat dear lord if we get
crossovers from doom and halo and cod
and vice versa i'm down for it just no
nfts yes down with the nfts
then we have elementa pio once again
five dollar super chat first of all stop
eating microsoft sesame cake second
night's like this i wish ray drops i
think i got it twice
there we go big of 2 super chat phil
peaked at jim's poker cars jim bluffed
then we have tea and violence plus jazz
with the
one euro
one whatever 49 pence super chat thank
you so much appreciate that then we have
uh brett bingham five dollar super chat
the iron lords podcast gamers gamers
seeing activision blizzard being
acquired by microsoft a small price to
pay for salvation yes
jesus christ phil spencer
then we got michael nemesis is the god
five dollars of a chat what if everyone
not understanding the power flex that
phil spoke to the heads of sony and not
playstation ceos can go over
playstation's head did i mean
i mean he is very careful with his words
so that could have possibly been the
case he didn't even take jim's call he
said i want to tell you
i want to talk to you
behind the man
i do i do want to point out why you're
reading those this will probably be the
last day for the 10k merchandise on the
on
the store like
and actually remove the stuff i know
we've been slacking because we should
have released it but we wanted to give
you guys plenty of time it's been plenty
of time and shout out to y'all for
getting us over 11k subscribers that's
fantastic
then we got dede lee member for 19
months great episode guys king is always
right as far as xbox having activision
exclusive i don't care i own everything
yes that's that's the way you should
think about it
then we got victor brick gaming
oh that's that guy back in the building
baby guys
two dollar super chat just got here what
did i miss that joke show was lit lit
thank you sir no doubt then we have done
otaku five dollar super chat xbox one
the 360 gen by money made even if they
barely lost console sales yes that is
probably and attach rate don't attach
rate but remember um how many people on
this panel had more than three xboxes i
know i did
there you go
target cheney five dollar super chat
keep in mind that from software is not
owned by another publisher so activision
blizzard king could still work with from
on future games that is correct and if
you want to see second row come back
that is how it's going to happen then we
have michael nemesis the god five
dollars jack phil dominus maximus
aurelius the conqueror spencer okay then
we have mr irishman five pounds super
chat ilp's avengers end game episode has
already made my year amazing episode
gents thank you so much
now we have mass racks
member for 10 months
i'm massarect and this is my favorite
podcast in the citadel thank you ilp for
everything you do for this gaming
community one love thank you brother
appreciate you then we have spartan go
17 two pound super chat a hundred
percent
salty super chat just get one year of
game pass no doubt no doubt and we're
back to the normal list and we have uh
dicato five dollar super chat i wake up
late get ready for work and the podcast
is still going half the night almost i
will get to hear iop yes if you're
traveling halfway across the country
you've got content bro
you're going to go to europe today throw
this joint on baby five hours baby
you're good
and i just got jumped crazy so i don't
know what which one did you read was the
last one you ready
was the last okay so we got a five
dollar super chat from graham c
absolutely
class and how thoughtful
uh
fake
i can't even see that it's so far back a
discussion by laura cognito and come
penny
we're gonna yeah we're gonna go with
that uh we gotta find out from drunken
ninja this might be the greatest iop
show marathon ever i'm happy to be part
of this community and gaming as a whole
is blessed to have this show
appreciate that we got five dollars from
kendrick hardy twenty dollars superchat
from kendrick hardy who's that peeping
through the window
from
the one one three eight i said we take
off the new the entire site from orbit
it's the one only way to be sure that
has to be from a tv or a movie or
something like that we got a five super
chat from nordic black
how you going lords finally get to watch
from australia xbox coming
to hell uh help the activision like
cinemax deal bad for devs
w-o-t
then we got a 10 out soup trap from
kendrick hardy anyone buying sony means
sony loses spider-man
disney long game i got it from here i
got it right now i'll finish it off we
got flame two dollar super chat quite
quite the especially short podcast today
huh
yeah it's very
very very short very short then we have
og tk cole three dollar super chat that
activision blizzard culture change was
needed yes this is and this is kind of
the only way it would happen
um then we have random citizen 20 super
chat best pod ever the book of acts
[Music]
thanks to you guys it really is
then we have
max arthy with the five pound super chat
iop acquiring guests for this episode
like phil spencer is with studios
fire best episode yet great work
everyone no
then we have jd gamer five dollar super
chat if microsoft gets sega let me say
that again sega
screen show everybody write this
[Laughter]
jd gamer aka emma saga what dorman ip do
you want to see bro back i want to see a
panzer dragon saga remake all my heart
my heart my heart thank you so much and
you already know what i love
you all day let's go yes sir
then we have hip hypnotic
17 with the hundred dollar super chat
thank you so much got it yeah hold on
hold on i got his super chat right here
i told him to leave a message oh okay
okay okay okay okay let me make this
full screen give me one moment
he got a message he got bars with it
let's go yeah he said um
whoops
i know i'm blind i can't see yeah
sir
had to throw this blessing you guys way
most enjoyable show on this topic thank
you very much for that
um i'm proud to contribute to people who
look like me
my man i'm glad you put this in here who
look like me discussing the topic at a
higher excuse me the testing discussing
the topic at a higher level than most
hey we appreciate you first thank you
brothers thank you and i killed i
co-signed that message i promise you
that i appreciate it thank you beautiful
appreciate it man then we have grace
2256. five dollars
since i was a teen i've always had a
feeling cod would be exclusive for xbox
and now that could be a possibility it's
crazy to think about yeah that's it the
matrix i love that hardcore gaming
absolutely yeah i love it jd gamer 20
super chat lord cognito when are we
going to see phil on the show
you guys got to go to that twitter man
let him know about the epicness of
today's show let's go everyone here if
you want to see him there man go tag him
obviously don't be saying so crazy yeah
a little crazy tell me you want to see
phil mcfencer and sarah bond not
obviously not together you want to see
both of them on the show eventually same
time
that we have splendiferous once again
two dollars if we have much respect to
colin yo love the combo it was tough
love colin always about that smoke i
appreciate that then we got smitty smith
remember for 24 months thank you sir
salute to the panel and chat the book of
acts
then we have david james oroz five
dollar super chat is this still
happening yes it still happens
oh man
he'd be loving the long show so he's
loving this
then we have hold up i got jumped a
little bit here please please
please please let me
make sure i have this got a member for
five months okay yeah i got it i got it
lord mario hoof remember for five months
hello lords what an awesome podcast
today keep up the good work sir thank
you sir then we have decado once again
five dollars to pretend i am working 12
uh i i guess 12 to 1 a.m help uh helping
get this to six yeah
no they're just extending us right now
then we have smitty smith five dollar
super chat phil spencer went from voodoo
vince to the xbox prince hashtag the
book of x my god a lot of scripture
being written today
then we have mariano
five dollars
appreciate you guys for always keeping
these combos civil we all could learn
from this it's all about the games and
we're going to be eating good that is
for sure everybody's going to be eating
good
then we have spartan go 17 2 pound super
chat buyouts are done with metaverse
slash communities in mind
yeah i don't okay fine
[Laughter]
okay we have kadrian hardy two thousand
chat it's me fozzy attic act like you
know me
what's up fonzie
then we have carlos x
super chat shout out to you sir
appreciate that super chat then we have
doovey 5 super chat what i'm about to do
to your stubborn annoying little card
i'm gonna enjoy it very very much thanos
spencer oh my god wow all right so let
let me snatch these a little bit now
look i don't know if i missed some of
you i'm only gonna read the ones that i
the where i think was missed but if if
we missed it we apologize you guys are
so sorry
we got a five dollar super jeff from jd
gamer let's not waste any time good
morning lord sony is screwed six ways
from sunday
somebody get him over there and help no
multiplayer games no western rpgs no fps
we got a ten dollar superior from
centric h microsoft told sony stop
chasing bro we gotta find out the
superchat from the wise old gamer
hopefully this episode is better than
the man in ground taking right now
behind the pulp
sherry we did that
i read all that yeah i read all that
okay okay then we're good we're good
we're all done
yeah because that was that was from way
back in the beginning that was way back
in the beginning epic this was for the
culture
what's up bro uh some more did come in
did y'all get the one from doovey the
five dollar super chat yeah dude yeah we
got it
yeah
yeah good looking
cool and before we leave i do want to
send them some so
tell me right before we leave okay like
right before we leave oh okay i got you
no doubt oh one of the dutch still
rocking out no doubt oh man pragmatic
eagle
five dollar super chat if you didn't
know now you know
this is why i love the ilp this is
quality podcasting love you guys amazing
job mods yes i can't say that wise old
gamer says we missed his ten dollar
super chat
what did he do
we apologize brother hopefully we can
find it before we rap but um yeah man
again this is why you guys looking this
is for the culture they go on farsi two
hours to check great show guys legendary
salute yeah man thank you everybody
everybody that came to everybody that
pulled up you know the list is long we
we had the who's who of of gaming
content creators in here anybody that
could make it and uh it was great and
people would hit me up constantly i want
to be a part of it i want to be a part
of it so thank you so much um did you
guys find it let me know because uh we
got boys
we got more stuff planned um big year a
lot of fun guests different type of
guests as well
season you know this season at iop is
gonna be fun man you got we got some
real cool things put it in the put it in
the chat real quick yeah just put it in
the chat and we'll read it while it's
okay but just just put what you actually
said in super chat and we'll read it
shout out the royal ball i see you boy
um yeah just put that in there and we
would definitely read it now if you're
still in there while getting because we
want to respect you man yeah and then if
we miss any of them you know i apologize
to you guys we'll do like a free stream
or something for like a free live stream
or something yeah i mean apologies but
you guys were raised
that's all i got anybody got anything
else before we get up on and out of here
yeah one last thing for me i was right
i don't know yo you was cold-blooded you
was cold blood i love what you did i
loved it
why would give him a couple seconds to
put that in there
man
weapon will this is the first episode
back man like you know i gotta always
give it to bg bg's always been one of
the most real people in this thing
it don't matter how big how small he
gets he doesn't care who he brings on
there go in there and say i'll pee sent
you
send him some
he has so many bars he probably forgot
what he said
we will make it up to you brother and if
not like i said you listen to it after
the fact dm hit us you already know the
vlog actually
yeah
yeah and sorry about that man but uh
here's the here's the link
but if if we'll get it next week just dm
one of us and we'll get it next week but
go to that lake tell them i'll be sent
to you i ain't even finished i forgot
the merch
real quick and before you get the merch
uh put the crush in the chat for hip hop
6 17. welcome to man welcome to the
realm you already know so let's get my
man all right we got somebody my man on
anonymous he got that he bought a little
man sticker salute to him you know what
i'm saying got that little man he
outside with that then we got the doctor
63 for the classic t got my initiation t
he got the 10k yeah you better get that
because they ain't gonna be lasting long
that's gonna be off the site soon then
shout out to anonymous say your name
brother he got the tribal entry t for
all console colors and unity green but
the xbox blue with the playstation red
with the switch and then we got somebody
that got uh turned he got defeated he
said got me some swag to celebrate y'all
blowing up mr bassoon ahead but this
last fact
shout out and there we go everybody
anonymous who got the field dominance of
really the new one with the scepter and
the chain and the nice yeah you got the
new giant and i think all right now
we're caught up on merch on the scene
one would just fly in yeah yeah thx 1138
five dollar super chat ilp great
spending the day with the crew double
header pocket more like a triple header
junkie ninja if you're looking for the
uh merch it should be pinned at the top
it should be there if not um actually if
you look at the youtube channel it'll be
on underneath the the
underneath the video you should be able
to see the store embedded so if you
can't find there go wild game he said i
said king david from a beaded leather
jacket to who's bad leather jacket you
know i'm bad i'm bad and the whole world
has to answer right now to tell you once
again who's back all right we ended the
show now
you got it remember go go go not one
foot try to say that say we sent you man
i want them to know yes
i was right
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you